good morning it's now
9 30 and time to resume
this inquiry into an appeal
made by gladman development limited uh
against the decision of finance district
council to refuse outline plan of
mission for the erection of up to 45
residential dwellings
outland on the north west and south east
sides
of shotenbane road
margate
uh
welcome back everybody
so this is day four of inquiry yesterday
we got as far
as
mr ball and his uh planning
evidence we did his evidence in chief
yesterday afternoon so in a few moments
we'll move on with his
cross-examination by
mr upton
[Music]
um just one or two
housekeeping matters from my point of
view i've received the uh
section 106 material
so thank you for that along with
an email or two emails from kent county
council so thank you i've got those
um
i think yesterday when we were talking
about
closing uh
submissions i think mr bakeman you asked
a question is mr dickman with us yes he
is you asked a question about would you
need to provide a i think a copy of
those
i think ideally from my point of view
if you can email a copy of what you're
going to
say
to the case officer holly dussen
at the planning inspectorate then that
would be most helpful
to me
uh
it's not you don't have to do it but
that generally is the uh convention
and i can look at that rather than
scribbling along
thanks for that information sir uh mr
hand is uh watching this and i'm sure he
will be doing that um as we uh speak at
the moment
good okay thank you
okay
before we
move
back to mr ball anything else anybody
wants to raise
in terms of
general matters
no thank you sir
i've got a couple of hands um
councillor
good morning
good morning um i just wanted to check
if i could make a small
uh contribution to a close to my closing
statement please
um
it's not normally conventional for sort
of other interested parties to make okay
statement um
one possibility is i i don't know how
closely
and i don't want to say that you are
closely aligned but how closely you are
aligned to mr dickman in the rule six
party
and whether or not if you are sort of
closely aligned
anything
well we have thought about that but this
is a particular it's just two
issues it would be very short um
regarding um the account it's from a
councillor point of view
see
uh and of course that wouldn't be
appropriate we did we did consider that
but uh
i see but i couldn't
um
i mean it's not the rules don't say that
other parties can't give closing
submissions but it's just not generally
the convention mr williams have you got
any any sort of views on it
so the reason it's it's not done is
because a rule six party has a
particular status which involves
providing an opening summarizing what
its evidence is going to say
calling its evidence having its evidence
tested and then making submissions in
light of the evidence that's been heard
whereas a third party whilst fully
entitled to be heard
provides its representation as a
comprehensive
representation really and that's why
there isn't the
ability to come back and have another go
if you like because closings aren't
about
providing new evidence at the end of the
inquiry
okay thank you yeah it was about
responding to a couple of things that i
raised but i mean what if i just put it
in an email well i think as i said
yesterday it is too late for me to start
accepting sort of late bits of evidence
there's obviously been several deadlines
we've had lots of british
representations oral submissions
i think it's also very important that
the yeah the appellant this is the
convention with all appeals and out of
fairness has to have has the final uh
comments
on
any any matter
so i think that obviously mr dickman
will be giving his uh closing submission
but i don't think in this case
i want to open up closing submissions
for any other interested party
because i don't know where that's going
to actually take us because i've heard
all the evidence
the appellants had a chance to respond
no new evidence can be provided during
closing submissions it's absolutely not
about closing and not about more
evidence
[Music]
very clearly heard from yourself another
resident so i'm very clear what your
position is we've had quite a full
discussion on several matters plus
written submissions so
i think i'm going to have to say i'm
afraid that in this case
i i can't allow you to do a closing
submission but i have got all your
evidence and i've got all your
submissions and everybody else's
submissions which are all very very
helpful so i'm not sure what else it
would really add because we can't be
introducing well i can't allow you
parties to be introducing any late
evidence so you do want it merely be so
repeating what you've already said and
i've already got that so
okay i wanted to respond really i think
to miss one of the things was mr
williams and his comment about will of
the west and i'm not sure
um will have the worst decisions and i
wasn't sure whether we had uh clarified
that issue
at the time i've heard i've already
heard comments on that already okay so i
you i mean that's been referred to but i
think maybe yourself from somebody else
as well which i i've listened to so
i'm
saying it's a i've got to stick to the
formal proceedings in the
program so
i'm sorry but it's not to say that i'm
not sort of you know listening to your
evidence at all but we have to sort of
keep to the
the program and the overall conventions
i'm not sure allowing other interest
parties to do closing submissions would
really add anything from from my from my
benefit because by that stage i should
have heard all the evidence
okay
okay thank you mr
mr black your hand is up as well yes uh
thank you sir um it was just a regarding
the um site visit that we spoke about
yesterday um i've had comments now back
from
both the uh
um
the sanic council and
uh mr hand
of the rule six party um and we've
agreed uh the route to go through so
i'll
sketch it on um aerial photograph and
email it across to
miss dutton uh sometime this morning um
and then we'll just have to just arrange
the time to meet him okay
good as you as you're in front of me and
that's councillor pharynx is in front
for me i think council of france you
indicated you want to come to the site
inspection as well which is which i'm
presuming is still the case
yes thank you yeah uh so as you're both
hearing everyone's here that would be
involved in this i think i in terms of
my timings
uh
i'll be coming by train
not that's part particularly relevant
for your point of view but if we could
start
at 11 30.
that will just give me traveling
straight from home and that would just
give me a chance to get there without
getting up at some completely unholy
hour so uh
is 11 30 acceptable for everybody
yes that's okay
and i'm hoping i i i difficult to know
how long these would take but based upon
what i did for my pre-inquiry site visit
where i walked around sort of all the
footpaths all the roads and through the
cemetery and you know quite some sort of
and from back from the station etc so
that sort of probably took me
about one and a half a couple of hours
or so so i'm hoping that 11 30 gives us
a chance to sort of reasonably finish
around about lunchtime even though even
albeit it might be a late lunch for
people but just to give a an idea that i
expect sort of one and a half to a
couple of hours is probably going to be
appropriate and there's also what i
could also do if i need to see other
things on public land
uh and we've sort of got to the time
where everybody wants to disappear for
lunch i can go off and look at those
myself
uh sort of directed by the parties at
what they want me to look at so if
there's some very distant things or
whatever then i can still look at that
as myself which is what i would i would
normally do on an accompanied basis so i
hope that's acceptable for everybody and
yeah
thank you mr uh black in advance for
sending through the uh
programme and to mrs dayton as well i
know you've contributed to that as well
uh
i'm sure as well
okay thank you thank you everybody um
good okay we can move back on to
item
on the
program and
uh mr
you may now cross examine mr ball
thank you uh and so obviously to the
documents let's see if i can
assist that people happen to hands and
if we need to go to them we have them
obviously i'm
it's only conscious my list is a bit
long in terms of time limit but uh we'll
see how we go um obviously
we'll have your proof to hand in a
rebuttal but helpful to have mr hester's
uh proof in his appendices
uh and mr cordre's rebuttal proof
um
and i think also linked to that is what
we have is called document 2.22 which
was his june 21 work
[Music]
uh and then in terms of some policy
documents so i hope you got access to
the mppf i didn't think we got as cool
document but i just thought if questions
arise obviously it's worth having to
hand yeah i've got access to that just
go back a second sorry because i'm yeah
i've known i'm behind i'm getting my
documents
open
give me a second
all right cool documents
sorry
right i've got to the core document list
so
yeah so just just so i'll start again
obviously the the proof um
um but i thought also worth having mr
caller's rebuttal proof
uh and then within the call documents um
just in terms of
perhaps in terms of numbering they it
was
court document 2.22
which is
um
and then i think the local plan
uh which is i think it's given
6.01 and i kind of that's correct yeah
yeah
[Music]
but
potentially the design access date which
is 2.05
and then a couple of the plans which is
2.07 which is the framework though
if we need to go to the later one
obviously that may be relevant as well
okay
sorry what was the design access
statement core document 2.05
2.05
okay and then the
plan 2.07
development framework plan
yeah and then the parameter plan 2.08
um which as we know is revision c
uh and i think um maybe that'll be the
core it but also just maybe just talk
about what's in the united undertaking
but it's the general point um but it's
worth having it hopefully available
again
yeah we have it now then um we're not
having to delay when we get to it
um
okay
but well hopefully we can
uh
restrict it to that but we'll see how we
go
um
can i start with a general point and
this is where the mppf becomes relevant
and
um
it probably is worth just turning it up
just so that we have the wording we're
not going to be disputing what it says
um
and obviously paragraph 11 is the is the
starting point for this
and
at the bottom certainly of my copy of
slide 2021 page six page 11
d
uh this points about
policies which are most important for
determining the application or out of
date if footnote
a applies one of the things which of
course we are agreed does in this case
um
so the most important policy is
determining the application are out of
date and so i understand that
there's no dispute i suppose the
policies that we've been talking about
in particular sp1 sorry sp 21 22 and 23
um
in particular would fall within that
category
well i think what you have to to
separate has
made clear in my evidence
my interpretation of policies out of
date is um i refer to it as a procedural
trigger
so where there's no five-year land
supply or hdt has been failed then i see
it as a binary switch and policies are
deemed out of date
by virtue of that
because this is what i wanted to check
within the the way in which the mppf is
written
the application that says the policies
are out of date which is why i want to
make to just check
the division between us
if they're out of date they cannot then
be said to be up to date can they for
the purposes of the mppf
well i think what you're referring to is
weight
so
a policy is deemed out of date by virtue
of the fact that there is no five-year
housing land supply when you get to
carry out your overall planning balance
you then determine where there is a
policy conflict
whether that policy where the way to
ascribe to that policy if there's been a
deemed conflict bearing in mind
that that policy has been deemed out of
date by virtue of the framework
yeah and and as you say that then goes
to wait within this balance that then
needs to be struck yeah and because
there were obviously some arguments in
the past that you then
um left plan policies on one side indeed
it's cased by gladman in the court of
appeal this year that uh it was
confirmed that's not the correct
approach but
right what i wanted to ask today is
really this uh philosophical point
as a result of 11d
saying they're out of date
surely the 11c test can't apply it's
neither all it's because they the mppf
has told them told us they are out of
date they cannot then be up to date and
we can't use 11c
um that's not my interpretation um i
think
your starting point is obviously
legislation
um and the the planning you can put
through purchase makes clear
um in fact we'll go to it in my evidence
it's probably helpful um just to read it
for for members of the public
well
very cautious about love's repeating
things that are there but please do for
this purposes i just conscious about
timing yeah yeah sure so i'll be very
quick um 3.1.2 of my evidence if
regardless to be had to the development
plan for any purposes determination must
be made under the planning act the
determination must be made in accordance
with the plan unless material
considerations indicate otherwise so as
set out in my evidence my starting point
is the plan
you carry out the assessment in
accordance with the plan
um if you're in accordance with the plan
then
planning permission should be granted if
you are found to not be in accordance
with the plan then you switch over to
material considerations or the second
limb
of that part of the act
yeah but let's just say it's a
philosophical point because
in terms of the nppf being material
consideration it tells us the
development plan is out of date
and how to apply in terms of paragraph
11d
the approach one should take to the
development plan and other material
situations 11c doesn't arise does it i
disagree unfortunately
because as you know of course the
council's offices and indeed council's
case has been concentrated at 11d where
of course you've also addressed the
point
um
but
you understand that's why 11c has not
arisen as is the issue
well it may be the council's point but
that's not my point and that's not my
evidence my starting point is 11c
okay as i say i just wanted to check
that because um then in terms of the
mppf itself um
i think
we agreed that
suppose the policies that are most
important a the sp 21 22 23
still carry considerable weight and it's
not being said by you as i understand it
that they are there are
the material points in the mppf that
suggest that they are not in substance
up to date
um
well i haven't carried out that test
within the evidence which i acknowledge
um but bearing in mind that the plan was
only very recently adopted
um i think you can conclude that
the the most important policies given
that they were found sound within the
past year can be given very considerable
weight
in the original planning problems yeah
that makes that means i don't need to go
into
much but can i
just check in terms of the mppf
a couple of points um
paragraph um
63 can we just go to um which
deals with
um it's in the section on delivering
sufficient supply of homes
you may have it as page
17 of the document
that it makes the point that
affordable housing expected to be met on
site isn't it
well there is the caveat at the end
which says unexpected to be met on-site
unless
off-site provision or appropriate
financial contribution in lieu can be
robustly justified
that's set in clausee
because that's one of the phrases i know
there is the ability in this instance to
review um the level of affordable
housing
but that would be uh sort of
very much a plan b wouldn't it it's not
the preference for creating
the mix and balance community on this
site
if more affordable housing can be
justified i mean the
provision of further money doesn't
address how this site
will work
well the allocation
expects 30 percent onsite
um the review mechanism
was requested or suggested by dsp
um it would still deliver affordable
housing
is this on the site yeah and but it's
strategic sorry for a strategic site
you understand the intention is that
30 should be provided as part of the
site itself
unless development isn't viable
yeah but the local planners so recently
adopted considered that was possible
delivery of thirty percent on site just
to
clarify your question
yes
um the local plan obviously says that sp
30 on site unless it would demonstrate
to make development unviable
yeah
so i don't want to press it because
obviously we can see how the magazine
works the other thing i want to pick up
um here and it's it's sort of been in
the background that apparel 65
mentions for me to develop
uh to be available for full home
ownership now
that hasn't
really featured in in this case and but
i just wondered
um how you approach that do you consider
there's a sort of a bottom line of 10 in
terms of the policy now because there's
been much debate in the past but how do
you approach it
well i think it makes it clear in the
opening sentence where major development
involving the provision of housing is
proposed planning policies
and decisions should expect at least 10
so when you are setting planning
policies the mppf
in effect creates the baseline of should
expect at least 10 percent but it's a
policies and decision-making
yeah um
i'm slightly jumping ahead but just
wanted to check in terms of the initial
um submission in 2020
was this the reason for providing you 10
or was it the viability evidence
um as made clear in evidence in chief it
was it was the culmination of a year's
worth of examination work and background
work and working with offices and
looking at what the site could optimized
what what
how you could optimize the site to
provide the quantum of housing and
affordable housing
we've never had the starting point that
we're going to have x percentage
affordable housing when we looked at the
site at the at the outset it was a blank
canvas bearing in mind
just i can understand in terms of your
approach you didn't for instance say
well paragraph 65 is our starting point
our approach on first instinct was
look at the site
look at the policy
look at the constraints
and begin to build up iteratively you
understand the question it's not that
you said well we need to meet paragraph
that's not
approach which is trying to achieve 30
now your
percent
no thank you
um
that's great i don't think i need to do
more in terms of the mppf so
one of the documents one can move away
from but can we pick up then the the
local plan please
sure
and
can i uh
sort of dealing with the housing
policies
uh therefore move within this document
to
where it talks about location housing uh
it's page
36 is the start i think the chapter
location of housing
um
and sorry i think actually i can go
further on than that um be a bit quicker
um
page 38 we have strategic housing site
allocations yep
pdf page says
yeah and the paragraph number within it
would be paragraph 317 onwards
we want to make sure on the same page
at the moment i'm not i don't think i'll
know on that right bear with me a moment
terribly sorry
which page are we on sorry mr upton
sorry
within this document the internal
numbering would be page 38.
you have a paragraph reference and
paragraph reference would be three point
uh particularly for this one eight uh
but its start section starts at 173.17
and its strategic housing site
allocations
yes
thank you
yeah
now
it's
a question that goes to suppose the
extent of the site is being used
it's
3.18 it explains for all of the site
allocations appointed by their
geographical extent
um
indicated for sign allocations
represents the anticipated maximum land
requirement
proposals which we will be expected to
consider and where possible accommodate
notional maximum drilling capacity is
indicated
together with all the relevant positive
requirements within a lower level of
greenfield land take now obviously this
is a greenfield site
but
it doesn't appear to have been part of
your consideration whether a lesser
area could be used is that correct
lower level of greenfield land type
just to clarify your question is it did
we when looking at the site consider
well
we have all of this land
could we therefore not bring forward all
of it to deliver the policy allocation
in a sense yes so to be clear as it says
given the notion of maximum draining
capacity in this case 550 for this site
uh it asks you to consider whether a
lower level of land take
for the 550 would be possible and my
question was is that something that you
looked at or did you basically deal with
the
whole site
we dealt with the whole site to optimize
the whole site
okay
but it's as you know i suppose at this
point it being agricultural land being
green field
uh one seeks to
use the word optimize it's only
something to come back to
uh if you're going to develop on
greenfield one should use it
to the best um but equally one shouldn't
take land if you don't need it
i think this goes to the point of the
mppf of efficiency of use
so
we have an allocation
the as part of that allocation it sets
the overall site boundary
um
the policy sp 21 sets the requirements
of the allocation and the expectations
um you use
what's within that's our boundary to
achieve what is set out within the
allocation policy
last question general point but if
it turns out that
in this instance that you're providing
more open space than might be seen as
the minimum for 550 houses
why is that then included within the
site just one way of doing it would be
to leave it out of the site
no i don't agree with that based on how
the um the parameters of the site work
from a constraints point of view
um as part of the site we obviously have
to have a drainage solution that works
um there is a large swathe of open space
that's lost to the surface water or a
large wave of land within the northern
parcel that's lost to the surface water
flow pathway that cuts through
okay
can i move to um the
i suppose the probably the first one the
general housing policy requirements it's
quite a useful
um point the sp 14 hasn't really
featured because i suppose it's like a
sort of capsule policy but it is useful
therefore
summary that i can just ask a couple of
questions
on
um because this obviously applies to
this site
um
and has a number of requirements and
additionally for proposals over 10 units
it then lists what should apply
um
and
that's what i just wanted to
check that um
under the second list of criteria first
one number one is provide an appropriate
mix of dwellings
to meet the requirements of policy sp
22. now
in your instance understanding that's
something that can be picked up but
reserve matters stage is your approach
that's what said i might have in my
evidence yes
uh but equally in terms of
when that comes and i say as a sort of
hook for some general points and if we
need to go further we will but
um in terms of working out the
appropriate dwellings poor csb 22 and
its supporting tax refers to the smart
isn't it the housing mix the evidence
from the strategic housing
market assessment
correct
and the state of this policy uh when it
was written and adopted there was the
2016 document and that's
reflected in the text
in policy that supports sp 22 isn't it i
mean the two tied together
so i'm just going to sp22 i believe it
is but just typically check
thank you please as i said i'm trying to
take it quickly quicker but sometimes
apologies yeah you are correct 3.2.7.27
you've responded to this point about
whether there has been an update to the
shema
um because we've now referred to the
2021 um housing needs uh review
um
can i see if i can take it surely
that's a document as a piece of evidence
that's been published but there's a
consultation regarding the local plan
review is to um i suppose overall what
the
local plan review should contain so when
you've referred to consultation meaning
that the housing needs assessment
carries less weight it's in that context
isn't it it's not that the housing needs
is out for consultation
it's the policy point that is
the housing needs document is out of
consultation
as part of the evidence because we're
preparing reps to it
all right we're good to
know um
but okay then it's a theoretical
question isn't it that
uh
once you're satisfied it is the document
that would then be the document to which
any decision maker would look when
looking to judge sp22
yeah i mean i think i can bridge the gap
between us my point is a fairly simple
one it's a consultation document at the
moment um i think in mr hester's
cross-examination he referred to or
possibly evidence in chief as being
given significant weight
i don't see how a consultation document
can be given significant weight without
making that consultation entirely
tokenistic
but as you heard he drew the distinction
between it it's a piece it's a document
that records the evidence um and that's
distinct from consultation on the
this was the local plan review
well the the council is consulting on
the contents of the local housing needs
assessment 2021.
if we assume that nobody's going well
the council can't just assume that
there's going to be no relevant com
comments and that at this point because
it's a consultation document
you cannot therefore give it full weight
because to do so i mean what is the
point of a consultation
okay well like as i say i think it's a
short point and useful to pick it up
there
um the other thing of course this
general policy sp 14 refers to is the
uh sp 23 which um obviously we know
well as well to just check and
the approach that you're taking you're
you consider there is adequate
financial information to show that the
um
lower level of provision is justified by
the viability evidence that's your
approach isn't it that what we have
falling
from mr cordre is
enough to satisfy sb23
yes that's correct from application
stage throughout yeah
it's it's not the case i just wanted to
check that you're saying that
even if the which was satisfied that
that evidence was it was too weak
that the your full house requirements
would be outweighed by other benefits
that the housing scheme produces
that's not the argument is it
now the focus of our evidence is the
fact that we have demonstrated through
the exception within sp 23 that the
affordable housing quantity can be
reduced
yeah
um
thank you uh now i'm conscious that one
thing isn't listed here is policy qdo4
which is about in the middle of some
standard spaces but
i understand again that's not a matter
of issue that would be picked up at the
reserve matter stage in your opinion but
equally there's a condition that
requires it
yeah it's also referenced um so just for
your reference in the statement of
common ground
yeah i don't know
let's say i
it's three points
3.1.7 just for notes thank you
so just it's worthwhile just picking up
at this stage
now the other
policy therefore i wanted to go to
is sp 21 itself
now that comes in this document on page
46 i hope we'll find it
okay
and
with this question that's been made
about well
well firstly the point about the numbers
uh being up to
um
in this case
split between north land north and lyon
south of throttle dane road but
um
just wanted to check it suggested that
you can provide
up to uh would still be in accordance
with the policy i just check how far
that goes that someone came forward with
a scheme for a hundred dwellings
would you agree that there'd be likely
to be a plenty objection that this
wasn't meeting the requirements of
sp21 um
supposedly on the basis of
why the applicant has determined the
hundreds is appropriate
um but you see
okay and then
she said just another point about the
language um
a minimum of four point four hectares of
open space which is point one is
mentioned here
uh if someone came up with a site that
while they're providing ten hectares for
instance you would say well that's still
in accordance with the policy on your
approach to the language wouldn't it
um
i'd have to say i think that's a bit of
an oversimplification because it really
depends on the evidence that's informed
the application
and i mean in this instance the wording
is clear
we have a an allocation that's for land
up to
300 and up to 250.
and we have a minimum requirement to
achieve
4.4 hectares of open space and as as
part of our submission
um as part of our application we have a
very well evidenced application that
demonstrates why our development is
acceptable and appropriate in line with
policy
but the there was a language point so i
wanted to check you that
being a planner you wouldn't
normally sort of be quite so uh wedded
to up to and minimum it's
if one was looking this is strategic
allocation and someone for instance
comes along with us 100 houses and 10
hectares
you'll be said to be that's not in
accordance with policy sp 21's well i
suppose
objectives let's put it that way
again
it would depend on the reason why
um i mean
i think it's a it's a very
i don't really take
the point really it's my
is my comment because
i mean there is no scheme before us that
that looks at a hundred schemes and ten
hectares of open space
no it's getting before us that looks at
450 houses
but this this is this is why i want to
check because
a woman looks at what was assessed as
part of the local plan and the
contribution that this site should make
to the strategic
requirements of this borough sorry this
district
uh
that
those numbers are not intended to be
um
at large you're meant to get as close as
possible to them aren't you you're meant
to make efficient use of the land and
make a significant contribution to the
land supply which is 550 dwellings and
4.4 hectares of open space for those 550
dwellings there's the sort of benchmark
that's it isn't just at large is it
well
i think the points picked up in the
planning policy respond
cd
6.08
tdc eip matter statement that refers to
how dwelling capacities were determined
as part of the local plan examination
now the site's obviously been allocated
for housing when you're preparing a
planning application it's for you to
demonstrate that you're in accordance
with policy
right
um
well i think the rest of time has taken
submissions but the
um as you heard from statista doesn't
believe it doesn't consider that you're
scheme meets the requirements of this
policy given its strategic aim and
that's all you want to explore in terms
of this optimization point that you've
you've mentioned
um
in terms of the
um contribution that this site makes
to the housing there's
you're expecting other sites to pick up
a hundred dwelling somewhere on your
approach isn't it somebody else has to
meet that street housing need
um
i think again we can go back to the
planning policy response that's in my
evidence
uh also within the application
documentation
um and also to the point that was taken
that mr hester was taken to that when
you look at housing provision within the
plan
there's an in flexibility of 1300 houses
okay for
it's clear the issue between us but in
terms of um
sorry i don't think about to repeat
myself in terms of the
of the local plan process itself
and what was
um considered
your
landowner client promoted 550 didn't he
um
we weren't involved at that point
his professional advisors i don't know
who they were but
um promoted 550 is the appropriate
number
bear with me sorry my
laptop
has just said low battery
power cord in there we go
sorry um
can i just take you to
mr hester's
evidence
yes i was going to say appendix a is
that the one you're thinking of
yeah um
give us a moment
there is a reference um an
acknowledgement that at that point
detailed investigations haven't been
undertaken within the site
but at paragraph 1.7 it records the
planning age on behalf of the lander
made submissions and made these points
about numbers
um thought it could accommodate more
than 550
uh and that obviously development brief
but at that stage hadn't looked at
viability though we know the strategic
point was done but
it was promoted wasn't it actually from
at one point it should be more than 550.
um
potentially uh that i haven't seen the
actual submissions and i don't think
they're part of the um core documents
and as i mentioned we weren't involved
but this goes to the point that i made
with within my evidence that at local
plans stage um you don't really know the
full design and constraints that you're
dealing with until you really start to
dig down into them
so
i don't want to cut you off sorry
um but let's just say it's curious isn't
it it didn't look at the timing that
your application was submitted at the
same time local plan was being adopted i
mean this is not something that comes
along later it's it's basically at the
same time as you must have known about
the local plan you when you're preparing
your application
oh yeah i mean i make no um there was a
representation put in by glutton as part
of the main modifications and but
gladman wasn't instructed prior to that
to take the site forward at outline
planning stage by that point of the
examination all hearing sessions had
been heard all evidence had been heard
and we were at main mods
um but you see it's it's not just the
site is
japan's site it's that it's been in
planning terms considered the local plan
process with a planning consultant
and
exactly the same time as your
application 550 was being promoted on
the site
that's the way the actual history works
isn't it
and as i mentioned we weren't involved
in any of the hearing sessions and it's
quite clear from um
it was referenced to td 6.08 process in
which the council went through
to determine its site allocations and
development quantities
you can as acknowledge that planning
policy consultation response
they are notional maximums based on on
the work that was carried out at local
plant stage
yeah okay i don't think i
want to come to that point but just
before we dig can i deal with a a
general point about housing before we
leave the local plan
um about the um significance of
thoughtful um
i think you've mentioned it's calling at
the hannah land
point given the the case law
um now we're agreed on
the approximate range and i'm glad we're
not having to debate
how big or little the actual number is
um
but i just want to ask this is the
general question the
there is a
housing action plan in place there is um
a local plan that has sites identified
um
there are significant steps out there be
are already in place to deal with the
shortfall do like the first point there
are other steps that
should be identified
uh well look the council's carried out
the requirements part of the action plan
um
but we still need to see
we still need to see the workings of
that
yeah
let's say i'm not surprising the
consequences of those steps that have to
say with the issue but the significant
steps are in place but the the actual
shortfall
um
in
this context it's taken isn't it we've
gone to a 20 buffer not just a five
percent so
um
if one was looking at five percent it
would be much nearer to the five year
number wouldn't it
um potentially but that's theoretical
we're at 20 buffer
and
specific
uh
you seem to attach um
well ask the inspector significant
weight to that shortfall um but it's
i'm supposed to put this right it's not
a significant shortfall is it the we're
not talking about in some instances
you've got authorities with you know two
or three years numbers this is you know
before and north of that
it's still the shortfall and it's still
a relatively new plan and they're at the
first step of their trajectory which is
just about to increase substantially
[Music]
thank you but as you as you correctly
identified the way in which the housing
is approached here is that it it will be
stepped because
it relies on the plan relies on delivery
of strategic sites
do indeed as hopefully as max as much as
possible on the strategic sites
and that takes time to come forward
it takes time to come forward um
strategic sites
i think you mentioned maximum
maxing the sites as much as possible um
obviously in relation to this site my
evidence is fairly clear and i'd just
like to correct um
one i take as a misinterpretation
of mr hester about step trajectory um
and i may be wrong here but i took from
his evidence
um that it's okay for a council not to
have a five-year land supply when there
is a step trajectory in place that's not
how i interpret things when the council
when the local plan examination was
carried out and it was found to be sound
it was on the basis that there would be
a five-year land supply
whilst those
strategic sites came on stream
yeah and at the time it was the
eurospecies reported they were satisfied
that there was that's five years number
one there was at the time of the local
planning examination but clearly there
is not now
yeah
um
i won't go back about the point about
this gg points and you're quite right to
pick me up on the way i asked the
question but
i think that's all i need to ask in
terms of the um
local plans so
i think
i don't need to go further to that
document
um
could we then
deal with this issue
uh of how you did approach it the design
and access statement
i think there's um
there was a revision to it is it's um
so i think the one that we're dealing
with now is 2.05 is it's the latest
iteration of that document that
what was referred to as revision c
submission
correct
now
in terms of of this document
there is uh there's no discussion is
there of
a scheme for 550 dwellings
uh there's no sort of
sort of
the way in which it's it works you've
not
apparently
as you mentioned earlier
started with any assumptions about the
what could be accommodated on site is
that the way you've approached it
from the outset the site we looked at
i don't like to use the word but as a
blank canvas as in what can we
accommodate on this site bearing in mind
the local plan policy
okay
thank you um
i think usefully within this document
we've got the parameters plan to see if
i got this right that's
page 33
um
it mentions parameters plan and then 34
has
um
i'm going to hazard a point see if i've
got this right what we now have is the
parameters plan just embedded in this
document so that would be the practice
plan that would be approved am i right i
just don't want to
start on a false premise
no the suggested conditions um i'm sure
we come to it in the next session um
includes the parameters plan as as one
of the um documents
but just want to check that the version
we've got here
in this document that the design access
statement is the one that would be
approved i just didn't want there to be
any more you start off in the wrong
course
well put it this way mr paul if there is
any issue i don't mind you picking it up
um i'll work on the assumption that it's
the right one okay
um because what i want is just to check
is the
uh the scope for what it
permits
um
and we can see that the
housing areas
uh and they would total 11.73 hectares
and they're the ones shaded in yellow
uh and there's a mix of two two and a
half and three story dwellings
mentioned but obviously depending on the
depth of color of the yellow as to where
they go
um
can i just check in terms of how you
interpret two half stories and three
stories those are
two different heights and two different
capacities of building
uh in terms of their
floor space and height
um
well
they are two different heights but it
depends on what the internal floor space
is used for
um but i think what we need to recognize
is this is a parameters plan um
and intended to inform urban design
yeah well it's um but all equally it
isn't it's it's partly about the
capacity of the site isn't it
and urban design i mean this sets the
principles for when the reserve matters
come in
um those requirements were called with
the parameters
so the council knows although this is an
outline scheme and everything's
indicative
it can
expect to see something like this as
part of the reserve matters
uh and just gonna change the there's
indicated on the
key and we can see where at schotton
dane road where it is the safeguarded
land for potential future road alignment
the 0.38 hectares um
area
yeah and obviously that came on uh later
in the process isn't it if we look to
the parameters plan i suppose initial
submission that wasn't marked off yeah
now
as i understand it just really for
clarification the
uh if the road goes ahead in that form
you're still able to accommodate 450
units on
on the site as a whole it's not that
that number has changed
no we reorganized um the developable
area
uh at the southwest site
thank you um
because i felt i was trying to puzzle
how to fit in but
the consequence of that is that
that demonstrates isn't it that
you can increase the density in other
bits of the site and increase the
number of units that a smaller area of
land can produce
no because the overall developable
remained about the same
well
the
initial
did include part of that safeguarded
land and then
yes and as i mentioned we reorganized
yeah
yep sorry
um
so when you lose part of that
safeguarded land for your housing
you could increase the density on other
parts of the site
we didn't increase density we changed
the design
well sorry excuse me on the logic but if
i fit 450 into
say
12 hectares i know it's not exactly and
then i'm expected to put 450 on 12
hectares minus 0.38
hectares that's an increase in density
isn't it
well no well it depends if your overall
developable area has changed
in this instance we reduced the size of
the pocket park
to offset the um for the um
safeguarded
land okay and the
uh ability to use some of what otherwise
would have been open space
remains doesn't it you
you have still got a um
sort of a generous provision of open
space don't you
only insofar as it responds to the
constraints there is open space within
that site that we cannot develop on
[Music]
okay i think it's
it's the stages the
um
the provision of open space as we see
here from the parameters plan is 6.3
hectares
yes although now that's um i think i
want to come on to
well let's take this hsn i think you're
about to say well you've now given a
figure of 5.22
itself is slightly odd because the
parameters plan hasn't been changed is
it
um the
it's a difference in terminology really
so the 6.3 is the same
but the 5.22 excludes the bird
mitigation area
and i think that and can i just pause
about this point because it it
it relates obviously to how one
approaches the the mitigation as well as
as you said it was question of
definition at the moment if someone
turns to the parameters plan
and the 6.3 hectares that encompasses
uh proposed public open space
vegetation
um remodeled land form archaeological
exclusion zone
all being seen as um
can i use the broad term open space
um i think a better term would be green
infrastructure
all right
and when it comes to
the reserve matters and and the phasing
plans
those areas um
are they well they still total 6.3
hectares let's start from that
um well obviously that's reserved masses
um
the i think the requirement of the
condition is broad accordance with
yeah
okay and so it could be and i suppose
this is why i say i'm just trying to
understand it the way
it is the mitigation area itself is not
fixed at the moment it's it's just you
know it will be determined as part of a
scheme um no our suggestion is it's
fixed because well
well sorry i suppose i need to check
because i think the figure 1.04 hectares
has been mentioned but it's not we don't
we don't find that figure in any
condition or any parameter plan do we
it's on the the updated uh framework
plan as part of my evidence
this is where i
need to check as i say um
but the parameters plan
doesn't cover it does it
it covers the same area
um i think what you may be trying to get
at is you could develop them on there
anyway but you can't
because that's the collusion zone well
no well i was going to
put a different point here
when we looked at this parameters plan
areas of public open space and the d we
could see the various walkways
including the archaeological zone
because there could be a bit of a
doubling up if you're not developing the
archaeological zone that's still
available for public open space that's
the way it was originally put forward
wasn't it
um yeah because you can't build on it
yeah
but it did mean the archaeological space
actually wasn't a constraint on the
development area for housing because it
could be used for open space so
you could release other if you were to
use this land for archaeological area
you could release other land for housing
and still get to the same minimum 4.4
hectares
no because that's um
as mentioned in evidence in chief uh and
i try to walk through this in in some
detail everything on the plan serves a
purpose
so the other areas of open space either
can't be developed on because they're
full within the surface waterflow
pathway or they're a heritage buffer for
the server mitigation purpose
um or the pocket park and they're there
to break up visual massing for urban
design purposes
the plan has been through a very
significant
um level of
interaction and detail by
um our consultants in consultation with
council officers
hmm
well
as you know one of the points is made is
that this isn't
the only way of developing this site
and one of the ways that it could also
be looked at is if the
open space figure 4.4 hectares is used
the benchmark not 6.3
and that would mean that other developer
areas are available
and yet whilst the point is made in mr
hester's evidence there is no plan
before this inquiry that demonstrates he
is right
the plan before this inquiry is the plan
that's been through a very detailed and
thorough investigation by ourselves in
consultation with the council that takes
into account all side constraints
with respect this is an outline
application that means there's a much
broader level of variation possible
isn't there
well the conditions seek to
for the parameters plan on landscape
strategy plan the development framework
plan broad accordance with
and as i mentioned yesterday and i think
you really do need to take this point
and
inspect the clip the
i walk through in detail in evidence in
chief because mr hester's evidence seems
to be implying
we did it wrong when the council did it
wrong and he could do it better
but the frank reality is the site has
quite a number of constraints that need
to be factored into on-site design and
master planning mm-hmm
foreign but you've already demonstrated
flexibility when it came to safeguarded
land and ability to thicken up surely
the same thing can apply to other areas
of your site
in regards to the safeguarded land it
was part of a negotiation with kent
county council
to secure their um
their strategic
routes
if you will yeah let's talk about the
consequence of that change you were able
to thicken up the development or the
rest of the site by reorganizing how it
worked at the southern section it wasn't
a thickening up it wasn't a increase in
density
it was a reorganization of the overall
master plan yeah
pretty quickly i just understand this
the
4.4 hectare figure which is in policy
it's based on 550 houses and the needs
of those people are 550 houses you've
only got 450 houses you've actually got
a lesser need for a public open space
haven't you
well there's two policy interactions
here
and
there is the the sp221 minimum
requirements and there's also a later
policy which requires which sets up the
standards of open space
and that would dictate what you need to
provide
but on this site you you have the
minimum requirements set up within the
allocation policy but it doesn't escape
from the point that the open space on
site serves its own purpose where it is
located
yeah but equally
to say that the point remains that the
minimum 4.4 hectares in policy
is based on you be providing 550
houses
but the calculation of what was
considered at the local plan
was on that equation wasn't it 550
houses what would it require as a
minimum
no
no because as i mentioned you've got two
policy interactions within the local
plan
the uh
so far as i understand from the
commentary within the local plant
inspectors report the the setting of the
minimum was to to ensure a high quality
design came forward
to ensure that people didn't push the
open space to provide more housing i
think it's picked up in my um
my rebuttal
maybe better if i go to the local
inspector's report there's essentially
there's a comment within the local give
us a moment to get the right the right
document sorry um can you give us the
reference
sure
uh it's um
tdc's core document 6.1
i'm having to refresh the page as well
um
[Music]
i think when i go to 6.1 i go through to
the local plan itself um
can i suggest for the personal answer
but i'm happy to if we take the
reference um sure
one two two
page
23.
uh and that's their point about it um
minimum being for high design quality if
i
paraphrase it yeah
yeah because i remember that and as i
say i think i've asked the question that
follows from that that
they're seeking to ensure that people
don't go below below the minimum when
providing the housing
no because of it we're still on up to
and the notion of maximums
okay to say well we've
um obviously covered
those points i don't
think there's anything else i need to
ask about
the way in which the sites come forward
but except i suppose to say
um at the time without plan it was
wasn't it envisaged that
uh a scheme for 50 uh was possible and
in the life of the plan that still
remains what the policy
would allow for
the local plan was based on the evidence
submitted before the plan and it was
based on the assessments of capacity
that was undertaken
and the point i make in my evidence is
that at that local planned stage you did
not know what we know now
effectively shortening the points and on
that basis the local plan refers to them
as up to amounts and notional capacities
well
obviously you know the point it's
pointless test has made that this isn't
the only way to develop the site and to
deliver the benefits that have been
um
identified i mean it's there's a broad
approach that's correct isn't it the
other scheme is possible when you're
looking compared to an outline
permission
well mr estimates the point but he
doesn't actually provide any plan
or any evidence
to back that up
come on he's
this point about topography is good
isn't it the fall in the land does allow
for different um heights of building to
not impact
well no because mr hester's
misunderstood that part of the site and
the engineering operation that entails
to build the roundabout and shorten lane
road
[Music]
so i'm not gonna it's as you say that's
not the specific scheme to compare it to
it's it's the broad point that i need to
raise
um
i think we can leave design access
statement can i
um
just about to
deal with the issue of how one
approaches um planning to pause comfort
break i'm sorry i should have spotted
this earlier we've been going for just
over the hour i know but
um as i sort of paused in terms of i'm
about to move to
that topic and i think it will be my
um
final one and hopefully we'll get
through it i'm guessing like 20 minutes
but i'm conscious that once i look in
documents i'm probably being optimistic
but it will be okay just have a brief
force yeah that is fine uh
should we break four
but effectively this will become until
what is it now 10 38 10 50.
if that's okay for everybody else sorry
to sort of break site early
um
thank you
okay we'll adjourn and we'll return at
10 50. thank you
hmm
okay everybody it's 10 50 and time to
resume
just wait until everybody
reappears
there you are and
over to you mister you may continue
thank you uh mr said um issues about
viability can i start um this is a side
point about the psalmist and grange site
now you will have heard of course um
mr hester's explanation as to why
there are the differences between the
site and i just
wanted to explore how far you still saw
it as um as a relevant consideration or
sort of comparable
um
the
site itself is much smaller isn't it at
250 and providing a major road uh it's
not a strategic site like this
um
no no i mean you are correct it's a
smaller site it provides an important
piece of road infrastructure but it's a
small site yeah and when it was
originally submitted it was to provide
30 i mean that's the way they initially
approached it
um i believe they did
and i believe when the planning
application was considered by members it
was deemed very dimly that they came
back in after applying for 30 percent
and then seeking to take that down to 18
well they still offered a choice didn't
they it was 30 with a particular with a
different type of tenure
um they offered 30 on shared ownership
which got no traction with members
obviously because of the need for
affordable rent
um there were also options in our case
to increase affordable housing
percentages by decreasing contributions
to kevin county council yeah but that
decreased contribution point wasn't what
samson grange looked at is it them
that's not something there's an issue
there
no the options were 30 percent
um yeah each case on the merit the
reason i raise it in my evidence is the
acceptance by the local authority at
that point in time to take on board
viability evidence submitted as part of
the planning application
but the viability evidence there
actually
followed policy didn't it was policy
compliant mix
um
potentially um
but i was made clear in mr hester's
evidence and as we've continued to
maintain our mix was market robust
mismix intended to optimize the
but the distinction isn't it that
in samsung grange they basically
followed what local pan was expecting in
your case as you say you talk about
market
driven market optimization
different approach
different approach yeah thank you um
i think that's all i need to ask about
samson grange then the
uh and since it's foreshadowed the point
about what was submitted in um 2021
isn't it that
as you described it was
driven by what um was considered to be
optimal for the market
now um
tyler for asking questions regarding to
your involvement um as the the planning
expert were you
were you involved in what went into the
viability assessment or was that a
discrete part of the project that you
then took the result from
um i was involved in so far as providing
instruction and liaising with jll the
jll
as an instruction for we need
a viability expert
to come on board
based on our findings and from looking
at the site the constraints the
abnormals
um and
the on-site provision of housing that we
felt could accommodate
yeah
and does i unders
what was put forward on the planning
side
is intending to meet the minimum space
requirements of qgo4 and intending to
when it gets reserved matters meet the
housing mix that would apply in terms of
policy
um
yeah would you be in the distinction
between a viability appraisal and at
reserve matter stage
that's anticipated man
it does mean doesn't it that the
financial viability appraisal submitted
was not a policy compliant it was didn't
con that way around didn't comply with
the local plan policies that would be
applied at the reserve matters station
um well obviously the policy is termed
as have regard to
so it would be for the council to
consider a reserve matter stage if that
mix came in
um whether they deemed that was
acceptable
uh let's decide you've answered what i
expected can i just follow that three
because
there's nothing being said as a in terms
of the evidence for the inspector that
the site would not meet the requirements
of local planned policies it's not being
suggested it it's going to come forward
in a different form
well at reserve matters stage that is
when the overall mix um would be set i
mean that's one of the conditions
yeah so in that sense from what you're
saying mr hester's right isn't he that
one needs to take into account the
scheme assessed as part of the
viability work to see whether it
complies with policy because that's what
what you're expecting inspectors take
into account
well i would expect the the inspector
to take into account the requirements of
sp 23 when he's looking at the viability
appraisal
yes but okay so i unpack that
he's obviously gonna take account of
viability work but if one looks at the
viability work and it's assessed
a scheme that doesn't comply with
local plan policies
um
you still consider that's
the correct viability assessment for him
to look at
yes because it's the most robust
assessment to generate the highest value
on the site
because you can see there's there's a
division isn't that
i'm probably all could persuade you of
it but
that
for viability assessments to give you an
accurate reflection of what is
deliverable on the site they should
reflect the local plan policy shouldn't
they
well i think the terming of the polit uh
the policy and the supporting text to sp
23 talks about maximizing on-site
delivery
so what we did was look at a mix
um that wouldn't try to undercut
affordable housing in any way it would
be the most valuable scheme
bearing in my constraints on site
right
but you didn't
when
advising
mr caldery
limit what he could do by saying that it
still has to meet policy qdo4 and sp22
um
as i mentioned it was designed to
maximize and optimize and you know qdo4
for example
that's in the statement of common ground
that would be picked up at reserve
matters
but mr paul
let's be clear that at the time of your
um consideration by the planning
committee and the commit and understand
the conditions which would restrict it
to the national space standards of qgo4
um
the assessment alongside that submission
was not restricted in that way
because that was a viability assessment
in line with sb23
not say supporting policy assessment in
line with sp 22 which makes no reference
to viability assessment
let me see
okay
that is hopefully any viability
assessment has to reflect what will be
delivered on the site and what you've
assessed will not be delivered if the
local plan is applied
what we have assessed is a value
optimized site
bearing in mind that this is an outline
proposal and the only thing set is
access but asking you as a planner
not the viability side just as a
planning
considerations
if the scheme comes forward in the way
assessed in the viability assessment it
would be contrary to sp 22 and qd04
wouldn't it
um qdo4 i accept that there was a
variation
um which was corrected by mr caldry
the
scheme the accommodation schedule didn't
include any one-bedroom flats
or one-bedroom units so that that part
of the the smart wouldn't have been
achieved
but
i mean i i go back to the point
that the purpose of the viability
appraisal was to present a robust mix
market robust mix to demonstrate the
best case viability scenario
okay now that's tough i think it avoids
line questions it
clearly is division between the approach
you've taken and what
we have well there's nothing within
guidance that backs that up
i think
you need to look at what the viability
appraisal does
what's informed it whether it's been
agreed for example by independent
experts appointed by the council which
this has
multiple times
and there is nothing before this inquiry
that demonstrates a more valuable scheme
that delivers a higher level of
affordable housing
in viability terms is before us okay but
first of all in terms of the weight to
be attached to any viability assessment
which is that's the question isn't it
the first
the mvpf and the ppg both direct
decision-maker to consider what way to
attach to any viability session isn't it
as a general point
yes yeah
and you're looking at the weight to
attach to it surely the relationship
that the velvety assessment has to the
actual scheme that will be delivered
is irrelevant to that weight point
well
it goes back to the
my last point it depends on how the
viability work has been undertaken
whether for example it's been open and
transparent which we have been from the
outset
the whether it's follow the standardized
inputs which it does whether it's been
independently verified which it has
whether across all stages
we have consistently demonstrated that
the viability evidence that supports the
application and appeal results in the
highest level of affordable housing that
the scheme can provide
thank you i'm
just
taking the consequence of it in terms of
what new inspectors then be asked to
consider he's obviously got the
the planning condition that's been
agreed that would have national space
standards applied he's also got the
unilateral undertaking suggesting that
there's a specific affordable housing
mix that will be applied
which is not the mix that was in the
june 2021
assessment that's correct
yeah just um i know we'll come to this
um but let me just go to the relevant
clause
so there's a um just for reference and
i'm sure we come to this later there is
a definition
um within the unilateral undertaking
it refers to that
um i'm grateful because as you said i'm
sure you say come to it as in the
planning obligation session yes sorry my
apologies i just wanted to ask the the
planning link i suppose um
because the other planning link from the
art i'm taking is this the way in which
the inspector is given uh i suppose the
way it's written is that it will take
account of what the inspector may
conclude
um that it could be 15
but it also in the wording says could be
as in the unilateral isn't it that that
could be a consequence
correct
yeah
um
and even somewhere in between if the
inspector
were to reach that conclusion is that
what's intended
yeah um i mean
some more interaction from tdc in the
build up to this would have been helpful
but
um that aside the reason that the the
clause is set in that way is when you
when you
when you strip back everything as part
of this inquiry it is effectively an
arbitration between
affordable housing percentage
so the way that the the clause has been
um drafted
is to allow the inspector to consider
the evidence that sits before this
inquiry along the basis of the evidence
before this inquiry to decide
uh the appropriate provision of
affordable housing based on evidence
yeah and just to understand the the high
30 would be
one conclusion
is is that where if the inspector is
not
satisfied that paul's esp-23
um
i supposed to be sorry the exception to
policy 23 the way in which you could
show something was not viable has been
satisfied it's not been demonstrated
that anything less than 30
would not be viable then that would be
why the unilateral would then lead to 30
as the conclusion
or in advance of this inquiry had the
council presented something to show that
30 percent could be accommodated on site
but what i'm saying i've heard mr hester
that if it's
if
if the financial viability work doesn't
satisfy
this point about demonstrating it's not
viable
then 30 would still follow as the
conclusion
yes
i'm just grateful to understand how you
see it fitting together in planning
terms because
um
then i don't need to ask further on that
can i then go to to the way the figures
as you said
um
represent the best case um
as i said this is
why i was thinking we might need to just
go to the
um
this is right the
june 2021
update the which was which had is called
document 2.22
okay
um and
i keep on opening it from the cool
document and see if i can avoid doing
that um so i get the right copy
one moment um
sorry to interrupt while you're looking
is this the jll letter june letter
yes uh to
a colleague of yours mr black isn't that
yeah
um
yeah i'm gonna have to go through the
website easiest thing
i have two neat documents open which is
a hazard
of this
um but miss black uh is i presume a
colleague wants a similar sort of level
to you it's part of the team isn't it
yeah project manager yeah yeah
um and in terms of
um
what this was assessing i suppose
mr caldwell was asked can i just check
before i go to specifically the letter
the scheme the accommodation scheme that
mr cordrey was given
he refers to it having been given by an
architect
but it sounds like you were actually
involved
in that combination schedule as well as
that i wanted to present uh well no we
out we out out instruct
we we have obviously being a major land
promoter of contacts within the house
building sector um
and we out instruct all work um that
includes
um in relation to proving layouts as a
reference yesterday
two architects who work with house
builders
right so yes it comes in please be
outside but
you do then review it from a planning
perspective or not you'd leave that to
them
we'd have a discussion with them about
contents how they've arrived
okay
thank you
and then one finds say this this letter
um
though it's written though isn't it to
see gladman is then put forward
on
i suppose gladman's behalf to the local
authorities sort of it's not this is not
um just james lam garcelle saying it
this is also um you as the
site promoter saying it yeah yeah i mean
it follows um just for your reference so
it followed the the planning committee
obviously it's made clear in the outset
um where officers were asked to go back
and renegotiate affordable housing
thank you um
can i then
go to
display the the way that i suppose the
conclusion isn't it uh just second page
um based upon the above we have
calculated the scheme would provide an
additional five percent which time one
gets to fifteen percent
um
and
it says dual spontaneous similar
residual land value which equates to
about 67 which we know is 68.
now
in terms of that point about the
residual
land value you obviously will heard me
ask mr culture about this but it's
obviously relevant to what um a
landowner or i suppose a site from
promoter or high school is prepared to
accept
um
not really
well that's why you want to check
because
let's explore it you're quite right i
mean i just i asked it in a broad sense
to see if it was that agreement but um
the
similar residual land value
means of course approximately
minus 1.7 million doesn't it in this
instance yes actual terms sure yeah
and
as you may have heard um
when dixon cell equated that into well
that would be a lower percentage on the
one way of accommodating that to make
the residual land value match the bench
online value is to reduce the profit
that would be expected and it comes in
at 15.2 percent developer profit which
would mean that then the figures match
um
i'm not sure that was mr caldery's
evidence no no see that's dickson sales
evidence that that's how it equates and
i asked mr quarterback um
and the but that therefore suggests that
if one's looking at the policy test
which i need to ask you about
about whether the residual land value
meets the benchmark land value
the the way in which that matches is
that a lower developer's profit is to be
expected on this site i mean that's
that's how the the maths works isn't it
well that's what dickson sale did in the
update note to mr hester's evidence i
believe
um we have taken the consistent view
throughout to apply a 17.5 developer
profit
now
that results in a negative rlv but as
noted by mr caldery yesterday that's not
unusual it's normal to be in deficit
well okay
that's from his viability perspective
and i presume
that's from you also's perspective of
gladman's that's how you experienced it
yeah
yeah and
does that when because when you've been
obviously
uh involved with the land owner and
that's been part of the discussion as
well is it as to what that
figure would be
well
i think this goes to my rebuttal point
three
which is um
from a viability perspective and from
the government's standardized inputs
perspective
um and mr cordrey's points are not
compliant
in how you undertake a viability
appraisal
where is gladman
in viability
and the fact is
that the negative rlv has has no real
bearing on gladman or the landowner the
landowner
gets
the euv plus value from the site
yeah because because i just explained it
because as you know at the moment um
there's an emphasis on i suppose
this process being as supposed to
transparent and to understand where
public subsidy goes and trying to be
open booked in the rest of it so
it's helpful to understand how glamour
fits into
um
the assessment
or government or someone in your
position
but
in terms of
um i suppose uh
i think you've explained from the point
of view of the landowner and claremonts
that the negative residual land value is
is not of concern here
so is that a fair summary the nega well
it's the outcome of the viability
appraisal
yeah i think we have to separate
what is a viability appraisal
but the
um
the way in which i think as you said the
what the landing receives are what you
receive
uh is not affected by this negative
theoretical residual land value
viability terms is the euv plus value
i think
yeah but sorry euv plus value is also
the benchmark lambda isn't it
yes i think so
sorry
ability expert well the benchmark line
value has to be arrived at some way and
one way of doing it is the euv plus to
get to that figure
um
because i think you can
you can see my dilemma
mr ball that
if it is as you say applicant blind
we do not have evidence before the
inquiry that for this site
the landowner is prepared to release it
at a lower figure
than um
the benchmark land value would otherwise
suggest
so as a matter of evidence you can
accept a lower residual land value and
know that this site will still be
delivered
i think the risk in going down that
route
is that you you're verging into hope
value
which was specifically
ppg guidance and viability and
standardized inputs was made so hope
never came into it
to make it the entire process
no sorry um
but can can we just take because i
understand this hope values is as you
say what people
might then hope for we're trying to find
a more objective measure aren't we
correct and that's the the current way
the
objective applicant blind
measure
if the residual land value is 1.7
million below the benchmark land value
this scheme's not going to be delivered
is it it's just an undeliverable
application
not necessarily sir
well on the viability it's just it's
just under water it's just not gonna
happen
i don't agree with that um it's
demonstration that on the basis of the
viability evidence
um that produces the rlv
and it's for a developer to decide
whether to take that forward or not
but
wearing your planning hat
if you had sort of somebody on next door
site
and they tell you that the residual land
valley is below the benchmark land
valley you're saying well
and we're at say a local planet you say
well that can't be taken into account as
a site it's not going to be delivered i
mean that's how the logic works
isn't it
again not necessarily
um i mean well i presume you've sat in
on local plans and
criticized other sites for not being
sound and not being deliverable because
they're below the benchmark land value
that's that's we hear a thousand times
well that's local plans
ultimate is the financial information
we have an undeliverable site don't we
if if it's given full weight
no what this demonstrates is a
comparison of the rlv blv
following guidance on viability
appraisals
it's it's not looking at scheme
deliverability
it's looking at
a viability appraisal and the outcome of
the viability approach which was to to
support
to support the 15 affordable housing
yeah but
if we take applicant blind and this is
the financial verbally assessment to be
more precise
the scheme for 450 homes in this way is
not going to be delivered it's it's not
a scheme that works i disagree
because i mean you're you're talking
about scheme delivery deliverability
versus an evidential document that's
intended to serve a purpose around
viability
i'm not going to label the point but
that's partly why isn't it but the
financial viability the local plan stage
looked at 550 homes and that's what can
deliver much greater value on this site
but unfortunately
based on all our work and the years that
we've spent working with officers and
the evidence that supports this planning
application
550 homes can't be accommodated on this
site there's no evidence before the
inquiry to demonstrate it can be
accommodated on site
and there's no viability appraisal that
demonstrates a greater
more valuable scheme can be presented
i'll certainly be attempting to tears
i'll not go back over those issues but
thank you mr paul and thank you so
that's what i wanted to ask
thank you very much
thank you mr upton thank you mr mr ball
um
so
can i ask one question there's a couple
of questions we should probably sort of
move across to the condition session but
on the
on the development uh
framework plan
in the design and access statement
this might lead into what we'll be
discussing later on about conditions but
i'll mention it now anyway
the area in the uh
[Music]
the bottom right of the site the open
area for the archaeological
zone and also i think i'm right saying
that's going to become the bird
protection area
that's correct yes
on the
development framework plan which i'm
assuming was sort of done as a sort of
earlier stage then the sort of the bird
mitigation area was developed but at the
moment it shows various sort of what
looked to be footpaths and
sort of clear access ways which it looks
to be an aerospace that would be open to
the to the public
but as i understood from discussions the
other day on ecology this area would be
fenced off so the public couldn't get
into it with pets and all the things
that we talked about the other the other
day i appreciate was in the ecology
discussion
is that because this plan was before
those
discussions and conclusions were arrived
at and
if it does does that have any
implications at all for the sort of
overall provision of open space public
open space that can be provided or not
um yeah i mean in two steps yes the the
development framework plan within the
design and access the statement predates
the latest framework plan that sits in
in the appendix of my evidence
um i mean in terms of overall on-site
open space provision um we're at 5.22
hectares
excluding the the mitigation area so so
we still achieve the policy requirements
on in sb 21 and also the the other
policy the
the reference evades me within the plan
that sets the standards for open space
on sites
because there's 5.2 excluding the bird
mitigation area that's correct
okay
and it is the intention and this is
probably best left when we discuss the
ecological conditions as in the
condition session but it is the
intention that there will be an area
that is set aside not as shown currently
on their
uh
development framework plan
yes yes um
i think for reference searches for later
it's the development framework
revision m
in my appendix which shows that area
right so that actually supersedes the
one in the design access statement which
i appreciate was the obviously submitted
with the application that's correct so
just i've got that now so i'll keep my
train of thought what which reference is
it's the one you just referred to that
later revision
um rev m
and that's my appendix to
my evidence sir
right
yeah we saw that yesterday i think
[Music]
okay i'll make sure i have that open
when we get to the conditions section
because i suspect this condition this
discussion can sort of be led on to uh
to that part of the discussion a bit
later on this morning so okay so thank
you for that clarification
um
are there any
uh questions for mr ball
from
uh
interested parties or rule six who are
opposing the development
no okay thank you
in that case it's mr williams it's over
to you to proceed with
uh is that a question no it's not um
with your examination thank you
thank you sir
quite brief i hope
mr paul will go back to the beginning
and
and work through
um
do you have the local plan
cd 5.1 still to hand please
um yes i do
and in particular you were asked
questions which began by a reference to
paragraph 3.18
yeah so that's cd 5.1 of the council's
documents page 48
yes
and
3.18 people wait do you have that sir
just difficult to see who's got what
open when you're on a screen
yes i will do i'm almost there 3.18 uh
yes thank you
and it was the point was about whether
or not
um
gradman had considered whether it could
meet
the 550 by taking less land
do you recall i do yes um and you
replied
that effectively this was about
efficiency of land use
and i just wanted to be clear has the
council raised any concern either in
discussions or in the reason for refusal
by reference to the proposals making an
inefficient use of land as that's
termed within the
nppf no
no
in terms of efficiency of land use can
we look at cs so sp
and
within the
first paragraph
there's a
the allocation
is to have an approximate average
density
of 35 dwellings per hectare net
can you
tell us what the
appeal scheme
provides by way of
average net
density
um we're slightly above we're at 38
dollars per hectare
thank you
and
what do you say
as to the prospect of being able to
achieve
um as per 3.18 with a lesser land take
um i don't think it would be achievable
unless you very very significantly
exceeded density
thank you
and
in terms of
the
consideration of this you explain the
iterative
process
um and this relates to the i think it
was termed the sort of thickening up
process
uh can you just explain
in real terms if this planning
permission is granted an outline
application for up to 450 units
by reference to the parameter plan and
the development plan you know what scape
in practice is there for thickening up
through this planning application or
through this planning permission if
granted
um
if granted the the overall
quantum of development would be might be
set by a planning condition which would
fix the 450
um
the there would be conditions
um that would refer to plans
but overall um
i don't i don't accept that there's a
thickening up
um scope based on the work that we've
done
in the lead-up to the submission of the
application
and can you take up please cd 5.2
which is the officers report
that's gladman cd 5.2
yes
and turn to pdf
page
one three
three
i'm there
the first new paragraph on that page
this is in the original offices report
is dealing with
the
numbers point
and it references the policy team's
response and then three quarters of the
way through the paragraph it says
specific factors
have been demonstrated by the applicant
to impact the capacity of the site due
to the nature and topography of the site
and the provision of the new road links
on this basis the reduction in the
number of proposed dwellings from the
allocation is considered appropriate etc
do you do you see that i do yes
i just wanted your
um explanation please since that time
what evidence is there
produced by either gladman or the
council
that in fact it's
those technical
constraints have been addressed or
resolved in such a way that would alter
that conclusion so as to enable a
greater quantity of development on the
side
um no evidence has been presented by the
council that a greater quantity can be
accommodated
and our evidence has remained clear that
um the proposals
um
are fully justified based on our
investigation into the site
i just wanted to pick up
hopefully the inspector
raises well i think it's worth looking
please at your appendices
um you were asked
questions about
the parameters plan
which is cd
2.08
and
the development framework plan
the most recent version of that is in
your appendix
uh two it's the first
plan in appendix two
and i just wanted you
to explain please firstly
in terms of the conditions and how the
permission will work how do those two
plans sit against one another what's
their respective roles
um well within the conditions there is a
requirement for reserve matters to
generally equip with the principles
of
thank you and if we look at the the most
recent development
framework plan please
let's just deal firstly with the
inspectors
question
to the south east of the site of joining
manson road
there's a
box
um that
is
that has some text in it
and can you just explain
this is the bird protection or the bird
breeding area can just explain
how the open the real question i want
you to explain is how the open space
operates across the site
because the questions in particular seem
to
be suggesting that there should only be
4.4 hectares of open of open space and
no more
um
as mentioned there all open space on
site serves a purpose so
in this area of the site
it was previously
prior to the mitigation being included
intended to serve as
archaeological exclusion zone
um the mitigation area would fence that
area off but that'd still be the ability
for
recreational footways and routes to to
bypass that
um adjacent to the development parcel
um
in the northern section of the site
um although land is is dedicated to
public open space to deal with the the
surface water flow pathway it still
serves a purpose
and providing a trim trail through the
site
thank you very much um
a very short point you were asking
questions about the shortfall
housing land supply shortfall that is
and there was reference to a 5 buffer
what's the role of the five percent
buffer in relation to the calculation of
the council's housing land supply
it's not relevant at this point it's 20
buffer
thank you
just on the viability questions you were
asked
at the
end um you were asked questions about
whether or not
an fva
had to comply with the schma
mix do you recall that yes
and um as a result of mr cordrey's work
the appellant has assessed the
both the 2016 mix put forward
and the 2021
lhn consultation draft mix
um
in terms of the sp 23 point the
viability point
what's the consequence of having regard
to those
viability appraisals in relation to
whether or not greater than 15
affordable housing can be demonstrated
they don't support the greater than 15
affordable housing can be accommodated
the um
both the 2016 and 2021
results demonstrate that the residual
land value of the site would go down
i.e become less valuable
you would then ask the question about
the weight that can be given to
fvas
um
and whether or not the scheme assessed
is policy compliant i think this way it
was put do you recall i do yes
if therefore
greater weight
were to be given
to the financial viability appraisals
based on smart mixes rather than the
applicants mixed
what consequence would that have for fp
and the appendance case
if greater weight was given to the 2021
and 2016 shma mix
less affordable housing would be
provided
our mix demonstrates the optimal level
of affordable housing that can be
provided
but in terms of
scp-23 the overall requirement has been
met in the exception this has been
demonstrated by evidence
um but the scheme is unviable
thank you and finally you were asked
some questions about
points going to benchmark land value
versus
um residual land value and
obviously
the viability evidence as such is was
addressed with mr cordrey i and you
might not be able to deal with this but
i just want to understand in terms of
the way that the ppg operates
um
is
benchmark land value
intended to reflect the particular price
but an individual landowner will accept
or through a contract or obligation or
option might accept
um
on commercial terms
yes
to dispose on the site yes
thank you very much they're all the
points i wanted to address thank you
very much sir
thank you
and thank you mr paul for your evidence
thank you very much sir
right um
that takes us
to
item 12 on the program which is the
discussion of the suggested
conditions
and
let's just have a
not really a proper break but a little
short time out just so i can get my
relevant documents out so i'm just going
to disappear for literally
two or three minutes and then we can
commence on the suggested conditions
right if everybody
is
excuse me is ready um
who is going to be taking part
it's going to be effectively a round
table discussion and as i i said in my
opening on
tuesday it's about prejudice to
the decision that i will make so
discussing conditions does not mean to
say that i've made my mind on the appeal
and also
for representations from the council in
the interested party you know please
feel free to take part and make your
comments it doesn't indicate that you
agree that family commission should be
granted so it's purely without prejudice
uh so
who is
going to be taking part is it all those
people that i can see in front of me
so
obviously from our point of view um mr
livingston is going to take the lead and
yeah i don't think i'll hopefully we
need so much but
okay is that the same for you mr
williams or mr ball or
that's certainly the same for me
okay excellent and mr dickman uh got you
as well which is useful
uh because i've got your
i've got your uh
submission that you made
um a while ago now
with your suggestions on surface water
flooding biodiversity and green
infrastructure now just check mr ball
and mr livingston got that as well
it's a two-page submission
i have got it i just need to find it
bear with me
mr dickman what was it provided with was
it with your position statement you did
just before christmas or was it with
your statement of case i can't remember
either now
i've got it but uh
you're on mute mr dickman i think
i believe it's with the position
statement having said that i can check
with mr hand to clarify that it was just
a helpless ball located um
sorry as is always the case at inquiry
i've got about 3 000 emails
since the event began
and mr hand has got his hand up
he may be able to clarify yes mr hamdan
yes so it was sent separately not with
any other statement um i'm just trying
to find the date that right um
that i emailed it to um to holly i don't
know with mr livingstone you've got a
copy that you can email mr paul perhaps
i don't know i can yes thank you sir
i've just located it myself and i'll
just email it straight across uh thanks
yeah i've just found it as well okay
there we go thank you for thanking your
patients
okay
so mr boy hopefully you'll have that
shortly i i do yes sir
good okay so the documents that i'm
working from
i still got the original
uh
committee report list of conditions only
because that's the sort of document that
i've scribbled notes on but i've also
now got the
updated list of conditions which was
emailed
yesterday or perhaps the day before
which as i understand it is the
agreed
conditions certainly between the
council and the appellant
perhaps not so for mr dickman i'm not
sure how they've incorporated your
amendments or not
um
uh not as such not as yet
okay well we'll come on to those as we
go through the discussion
okay are those all the documents that i
need
and
what i'm supposed to do i just go i'm
presuming the list the suggested list of
conditions are in the same
order so i'll go if i go through
and i'll as we go we need to go through
it's a fair cancer because there's
44 actually it's grown now it's 46
hasn't it yeah so
it may be
slightly less when we finish we'll see
but uh
yes so i will go through and i'll raise
any comments that i've got but feel free
to obviously some people chip in
if you have any sort of particular
concerns or anything you want to
to say about them
uh
okay so
condition
one fairly standard outline condition
um
my only comment on this is does it need
i mean what i will do is i just explain
my approach to this that if the appeal
was to be allowed obviously i have to
impose conditions
and it will be for me to sort of decide
what the most appropriate condition is
bearing in mind the actual
test the relevant tests and there are
some things that i will prob i may well
make very small changes to without even
referring back to the parties now with
their very small
changes to sort of wording but anything
of substance i will raise with you uh
now
um okay so the first the first one is
the uh
approval of details condition
i think the standard condition that i'm
used to has has a clause in somewhere
which does say
before any development takes place it's
probably quite a small point but
it just makes it clear that those
details need to be submitted before any
developments probably makes it probably
sort of seems to make sort of sense but
technically i suspect it should have a
little clause in
[Music]
to say to say
to say that
um
well from from the appellant side we
wouldn't have any concerns with that
clause being included
no okay
nor from the local authority side thanks
no okay i mean it's a fairly sort of
called special points away everybody i
think it just tightens it up okay uh
point two and condition two
if you can just briefly i've got no
particularly comments on this but if you
could just briefly explain like i've
seen it in writing somewhere but briefly
explain the rationale for the the three
year and the five year periods in this
case
um i think it was down to the phasing
and the size of the scheme
um
to allow sufficient time for for the
phases to come forward
okay i think that's referred to in your
written evidence somewhere as well isn't
it so i can refer back to that as well
if i need any further detail
uh condition three i've got no comments
on that
and let me know as i go along if one of
these conditions has been changed in
your updated
list
because it might not be absolutely
selfish to me as i go through
so condition four
is
phasing condition
which i understand i just wanted to
check is the phasing parameter plan
number two is that is that the correct
parameter plan
revision a or does that need to be
changed
i think it is correct but let me just
double check some okay
yes
that's correct
okay so it's revision a mr livingston
are you happy with that as well
i just want to make sure i get these
correct revisions because we do have a
few
yes i believe so this one that was
checked for the for the phasing yes okay
okay
good the final sentence of the condition
says this condition does not prevent the
construction periods of any phase
running concurrently with other phases
what's the reasons for that and i was on
first reading it sounds almost like
contradictory to the condition itself
which says the phasing has to be set out
with in accordance with the actual
phasing plan
but then that
clause seems to allow
the whole thing to be built at once
potentially
could you explain
um i think it was
along the basis that where you look at
the phasing plan and the natural split
in the site is shot undone road
and there's part of the infrastructure
delivery
taking the the distributed road up to
the roundabout and then the roundabout
up to manston road and in theory it
would allow uh two house builders one to
take forward one a and one to take
forward one
b okay
mr livingston presumably you're happy
with that
there's not necessarily more than that
though does not potentially allow sort
of
more to happen than that
and would that be an issue
i think it potentially could um
but i don't think when you look at the
the other phasing schedules i mean
obviously we'd be guessing but
the way that phase 1a interacts with two
and three
um if it was taken forward by multiple
house builders i don't think it would be
likely that um two and three would be a
separate um flat house builder um
because of the interaction between the
two and the requirements for access
through
okay
i've got
some hands up as well mr
mr hester have you got your hand up did
you want to say anything about this or
is it something else
no thank you sir i mean at last i agreed
with mr ball on something um i
for a second of 450
a house builder is more likely to just
keep going
and not they won't see it in terms of
stopping for phases they'll see it
probably as one
hit
and unless you mix the two exceptions
are because of their two sides they may
well be true
so i just wanted to agree
with mr ball that it's more likely to be
developed in one hit
right so we will see the phases as
planners but the developers will more
likely just crack on
thank you
okay thank you mr hand your hands still
up from before which might have been
just
your previous hand still being up i'm
not sure
okay thank you
okay okay i see
and what's the uh
in terms of the reason for the condition
or the ground as it's used in this
document to secure the programming and
phasing of an orderly pattern to the
development in accordance with the
phasing arrangements that have been
assessed is there any particularly more
explanation of why that is needed is it
because of i don't know potential
highway impact or
what
i if i may come in there it it does
relate to
the highway impact as you say there's
when we come onto planning obligations
there's particular
reasons behind that in terms of how the
higher infrastructure is expected to
come on board at different times
throughout the development
okay
about laboring the point on the previous
issue i raised is there anything in the
phasing plan which actually sort of
talks about the fact that phases can be
done concurrently
so i can't see any particular reference
to it on the plan no no it's just colour
schemes which designate the phase areas
do you think mr livingstone that any
sort of further clause is needed even i
mean just sort of thinking aloud even
something to say unless
we had to becoming a tailpiece would
unless
any
revised phasing is agreed
by the local planning authority just to
prevent any risk maybe there's not a
risk as mr balls and the tesla have
indicated
maybe thinking too much of it but
i i think actually i might even i might
even defer to mr ball on this one
because i think yes uh he would it would
as you say would tighten it up and allow
or allow some flex some minimal flex i
think we obviously would be careful not
to depart from the principles of that
plan that the condition is trying to
secure but
i suppose it's really maybe a question
for
um well mr hester's going to come in as
well on behalf of the local authority so
i'll probably just go to him
the phasing plans are there
in terms of the triggers for 106's and
everything else so
now the numbers are important because
the
triggers relate to those so
um
yeah so that that that's my response but
um sure mr paul wants to add something
to that okay mr ball i have a final say
on this no no i'm i was going to agree
with mr hester actually
the phasing plan does refer to the
numbers so
and they do have
consequential impacts on the
legal agreement
okay
we'll move on to the next one
so condition five this is reserved
master's condition uh reserve might have
submitted a course condition one in
respect of each phase shall include the
following details there's quite a long
list of details i don't want to go
through each one but i think my a
general point about this is that
quite a few of these then seem to be
repeated by separate conditions
and i've got a bit of an overriding
thing about repetition it seems requires
a lot of repetition which might result
in a need for slightly less conditions
or certainly more precise conditions so
my general point is that in this is that
where something's referred to clearly as
a separate condition does it also have
to be included in this long
list of requirements
you thirsty
thank you um
i think with this condition obviously
this this is uh i suppose it's been
worked up from a standardized condition
which relates to applications of this
scale i as the local authorities
perspective i wouldn't have any i
wouldn't have any issue with anything
that is duplicated being removed because
i think obviously as you point out so
it's you know we're over 45 conditions
in the application so if there are
particular things that you feel are
duplicated in this particular condition
in regards to the reserve matters then
i've got no objection for them to be to
be removed
okay
mr bloody with that i presume yeah yeah
the less conditions are better okay uh
yeah i'm still waiting for the the line
of condition seems to be still going up
in terms of you did a graph from about
20 years ago so anyway maybe that's you
some of the other factors i don't know
but anyway on scale interference
scale form and appearance of the
architecture within each phase and it
says including frontage design
and i think i know what that means i
think i think it's meant to mean
the sort of the front four quarter of a
dwelling i think rather than the actual
front elevation but as you first read it
it's not exactly obvious
what does it what does it mean it sorry
sir it is it is as you interpret because
obviously you're going to get the front
elevations of
a scheme at a reserve management stage
okay so it's actually for the sort of
the
four-port driveway yeah it's an element
of a
detail indeed that gives you more of a
feel for the development rather than the
sort of
very standardized sort of different
front elevations
okay is there another way that that
could be drafted in that case
um
seeing as it's relating to detail of
architecture do you need it could you
end it at the
moment
all these things are within the power of
the local satisfactorily that is debated
at that point i suppose in some
instances these the conditions are
obviously when it comes to
matters are trying to be informative as
opposed to restrictive so i appreciate
it's an informative point um it is
something that obviously we are we will
be concerned with at the reserve matter
stage so it's not necessarily precisely
needing to be necessarily put in okay i
can take away what's being said and
yeah come to a view on that okay
thank you and then condition six is
uh
so
right these
i'm not sure these references are quite
correct the pro
[Music]
or maybe they are the parameter plan is
that the correct does that need a
revision in it
um i think this is where we have the
the
core document title references b but
yeah
actual
yes
right so revision c
is that agreed because it's
what i
don't want to do is get any references
wrong so revision c and then
the landscape strategy plan
is that it refers to one received on the
13th of november
is that still the correct one
no the the landscape strategy referred
to in 6 is
from my
evidence appendix 2.
so
[Music]
what's the correct uh
what's the correct revision reference is
that correct then is it f is correct
for landscape strategy sorry
no landscape strategies
okay
is that miscellaneously are you
happy with that that's that's the plan
that was was submitted yeah with mr
bull's proof
right so it shows this that it's the the
plan that includes the bird mitigation
area
yeah that's what i was thinking about in
terms of so it's
so it's definitely i and not f agreed
does that agree
okay yes
good uh
okay moving on to seven
so these are the plans that relate to
the uh highway works
and again can we just do a double check
to make sure that these are the correct
versions
foreign
revision e
12th of march 2021
that seems to match what's in the
statement of common ground
[Music]
as does that make a revision 10 revision
a
an sk11 presumably sk11 is just the
original plan without a revision
yeah that's correct
okay so everyone's happy that those are
the correct references
good
and there's a
final clause in it that says development
hereby approve should be carried out in
accordance with those plans
obviously i understand that it says
subject to final design and highway
authority adoption requirements
what might these be and could they
change the
approved plans materially
or shouldn't the condition just say it
should the development carried out
because this is a detailed matter should
be carried out in accordance with those
plans
in any
amendments would just have to be dealt
with like any amendments to any
any outline permission
yes sorry sir if i could come in
we're looking at condition seven
i fear that i'm looking at the
list that was sent through from
uh from gladman yesterday
uh which which doesn't have that clause
in it
oh right oh well good in that case good
okay
it's just this i'm still my notes are
from the uh from the from there during
the week so that's
that's good we're thinking on the same
line so okay sorry because i've got my
two versions here as i say any
conditions that's been updated from the
original list
in this in the word document sent
through the other day then let me
let me know
and just to confirm that mr livingston
the the seven that i'm looking at
doesn't have that end clause
yeah
okay
i see and also condition six has been in
addition to the original one in terms of
development framework plan revision n
being added to it
that's correct yes which is m is what
we've referred to earlier so that's
that's correct
okay
uh
moving down to eight
so eight's been revised
on the one i originally had
and this requires the master plan to be
submitted to an approved and right by
the local planning authority
[Applause]
and given that there's already a master
plan
which has been referred to quite a lot
in evidence what's envisaged by having
actually
a revised master plus so the master plan
is not actually fixed according to this
condition there is some
movement which could be
expected through this condition
what's the reasoning behind that
i was going to say i think this was
included by mr hester um
thank you
thank you chris um the
this condition and the following answer
is to do the design code as well i mean
the master plan isn't fixed and
therefore
the design code
should actually be a positive planning
element to actually coordinate
development across both sites
um and so the master plan will cover
particular features if you like but the
design code will cover things like
community safety
max levels for external lighting because
of the obviously because it's
countryside location etcetera so
it's it's more about digging into the
deep
now so the two run together and i think
that's a fairly common approach these
days to run design code with masterplan
the master plan has been submitted but
they're going to see restrictions so
your authority will need to see
a fully worked up
in accordance with principles
so
yeah that is thank you and it's
interesting that this condition has got
this
sentence that says the master plan
should demonstrate how the development
would reduce energy demand promote
energy efficiency and be designed to
address climate change and
uh climate change so it seems to almost
be sort of particularly addressing
climate change energy points
in terms of those specific things it
asks for
and the reason
is to achieve good design and
placemaking
i'm not sure the reason quite ties up
with that sentence that i've just read
out
um
sorry
sorry carry on you you go ahead
i think this is trying to future proof
where it's all going because obviously
we don't have a timetable for what we do
but
issues like energy
climate change etc will need to be
addressed at the time of the the
submission
um
and
it's just to cover that
uh future proof and obviously the studs
have been worked out on the basis of
climate change as well so
um it was really to cover the
the time lag between
the points that have been undertaken and
what's actually going to be submitted
okay
at those times
sorry chris
now all i was going to say um
was i mean obviously acknowledging that
we are moving forward in
planning policy terms in terms of good
design and energy efficiency um if it is
a concern so there are later conditions
that refer to high energy efficiency
that's 45 46
primarily
yeah
yeah i've read those yeah
okay i think i understand that it might
be this just is the reason expanding on
it a little bit i
i see the reasons for it in principle
uh okay
so condition nine
on the amended list is gonna cause
confusions because the numbers are going
to be out from my list but anyway
condition 9 on the
updated list
is this a new condition as well from the
original set
design mode
yes i believe it will be sir um i'm
obviously building from the design and
access statement yeah okay
okay i've got no comments on
on that
okay condition 10
open space specification for the face
shall be submitted to increasing writing
by the local plane or authority uh
to record the principle shown in plan
number
that's revision i that's correct isn't
it that's correct yes
[Music]
is this a new condition as well or do do
we go back now to the previous list
i believe this is in the previous list
so oh i see it is yeah
okay
just reading my comments on this
does this
first of all one small point there's a
sentence where it says outline any local
plan space to be provided and then
there's another the final sentence such
planned space shuttle provided following
the criteria stated in fallout local
plan 2020
uh
et cetera et cetera
i also think that policy the need to
comply with policy is taken as read when
reserve matters all these condition
submissions come in rather than having
to repeat them in a in a condition and
maybe out of preciseness that's the sort
of sentence that might be
might be deleted i know it goes back to
mrs livingston's point about conditions
prior to burning information as well but
i suspect that's why conditions are
getting a lot longer now because i think
local authorities are just putting in a
long list of requirements which is very
helpful but anyway it's probably not a
discussion for today but in terms of
preciseness i just wonder if saying it
shall comply with a local plan policy is
needed when i thought that would have
been given as red
so no i i take the point sir
i'll leave it at i'll leave it at that i
don't think taking it out would remove
the sort of substance or essence of the
condition in any way or dilute it in any
way
okay and does this need to
as mentioned things like the trim trail
that was referred to earlier on does
this need to
also include
the bird protection area or is that
covered elsewhere
that's covered elsewhere right there's a
separate ecological condition okay we'll
move on to that then okay
that must be one of the points that's
been updated
later on okay that's
so
condition 11
i don't think this one's been changed
okay
i've got no comments on that
condition 12.
fencing around the area identified as
the archaeological exclusion
zone
is this just for construction
so so if i if i may there are two
elements this condition actually one is
the construction part and the last
sentence uh is is a sort of
you know it does does sort of span the
development a little bit now obviously
this is one which
i wouldn't say necessarily conflicts
with the update in terms of the bird
protection area but obviously there's
there's going to be the need to
coordinate as i think was stated in um
evidence and discussion of biodiversity
about how much planting occurs uh in the
particular area and when it's necessary
because obviously if they're doubling up
between
the uh the exclusion zone and the bird
mitigation area
um the pro you know primary point of the
condition is to ensure that the
archaeological exclusion zone isn't
affected by construction at all through
protective fencing um
as the first point and then there's the
the second point which has a has a a
minor consent regime if there is the
necessity to do anything in that area
particularly
okay
is the archaeological
exclusion zone
are its boundaries the same as the
boundaries of the bird
uh protection zone or do they slightly
differ do they just slightly differ
the exclusion zone's a bit smaller
right
i'm just wondering if the the intention
of the
the second limb of the policy relates to
groundworks and to avoid
the lack of coordination with the
planting if it is no groundworks
amounting to development
or some way shape or form
i mean um
just for background sir the
conversations with the county council
about the the bird mitigation area the
county archaeological advisor wasn't
concerned about planting
um
so
he has no concern about planting in that
area hence and steve's to the mitigation
area
no presumably subject to sort of the
correct species being put in which
attract particular birds perhaps
you could read it i think this is the
final scheme for fencing around the
exclusionary stroke bird mitigation area
as i understand in this point it's a
temporary
measure
to construction period so i i think
probably the first line needs to make it
clear that this is a temporary means of
fencing the site during the construction
phases etc etc otherwise it may be
construed as the fencing
to be erected and that's that's
defensive
uh and i think that's a matter for
detail for the reserved matter stage
rather than
if we could have to mean
if this policy is aimed at
construction etcetera and safeguarding
the land and i think
the reference to fencing needs to be a
bit clearer or what what is it for
and for how long is it for
so
so i'm writing saying that the condition
the entirety of the condition is really
meant just for construction works
i think it gets very complicated so i i
think it makes sense that actually it's
restricted to that
and the other elements of the
requirements are actually picked up as
as we've stated through sort of the
consent regime of reserve matters and
other condition submissions
okay
okay i could probably sort of
deal with that without really changing
the essence of the condition just a
small point where end of the first
sentence it says in a manner to be
agreed with the local planning authority
i think where it says that i would
probably change the wording to be a
little bit more sort of precise in terms
of to be submitted to ingredient writing
by the local planning authority that
sort of thing
i think there's a few cases where this
little wording comes up
i presume you'd have no objection to
that rather than it's just ambiguous in
a manner to be agreed to a local
planning authority no no i i actually i
i'm i'm sorry that that wording slipped
through because that's not the wording i
would use either
i i didn't think you would
anyway those sort of things i could
probably tighten up where i see those
without any uh
further sort of reference so
okay um
okay
moving on uh
okay archaeological condition
uh
securing implementation of a program of
archaeological work
okay i understand the need for that
seems quite a brief condition for uh
what it's trying to do but
it's going against what i normally say
anyway if i need to sort of let me add
anything to make it
i'll consider that but i think the
essence of that it seems to be
uncontentious
14.
right this isn't is this archaeological
interpretation is it say so in the
reason
that's correct yeah
okay
very small thing but i'll probably say
the interpretation board shall be rather
than will be i think shell's probably
the right terminology
okay now
13.
so this is requiring surface water
drainage scheme
as obviously an important requirement
and this is for
on a phase by phase basis i think
i asked a question about that didn't i
during the
drainage discussion so i think that
point about does it need to be
phase wide or does it need to be sort of
done before any development in order to
have a strategic approach across the
site
was
until i can give some consideration
to that uh
but yeah obviously a necessary condition
um
this is one where i'd say that the
earlier reserve matters condition where
it refers to surface water drainage this
is this would this would do that so it's
an example of where maybe there is a bit
of repetition but this clearly is the
more detailed condition that
uh
i'm sure would be
required okay any more comments on that
no no
okay 14.
sorry so mr dickman's looking to come in
sorry mr dickman
no bro it's my fault i was a bit slow on
the button um
would it be necessary or is it implicit
that um certainly the suds
there will need to be
monitoring not only initially but right
through um annually and biannually for a
quite a long period of time
does that need to be built in because
the problem with subs
is if they're left it causes
major issues
yes i completely agree with you it is
important i think it's just looking at
the condition
the last sentence says
the scheme should be constructed in full
accordance with the approved details and
shall be managed maintained in
accordance with the approved maintenance
and management details for the lifetime
of the development
i'm assuming that those management and
maintenance details would be
need to be submitted as part of the
the package itself
it may be that actually the word
management needs to be added into the
second bullet point
right
okay
right infiltration where does this
condition what number is this in the uh
on the
um revised list it's 16 so okay have i
got out of sync here
oh no i see okay
okay 16
seems to be
fine there's an approved in writing
point and i suspect the first sentence
is for a better saying
other than with the prior written
consent rather than just the written
consent but that's a small point which
seems
uncontentious
yes sir um
could i just looking at no infiltration
of surface water drainage into the
ground is permitted
um other than the written consent local
planning authority given the nature of
the land is that actually feasible
uh to to make that statement because
we know it does strain him from a number
of areas and i'm not sure how you can
not permit that
in any sense if that if that that's
clear sir
yeah i know what you mean uh didn't
happen
i don't know mr ball or mr livingston
um i think well
the link is is really the second
sentence um which reference where
implementation is to be used as part of
the surface water flow from the
development
and i think it just stems from the fact
that the entire drainage scheme from the
site is based on infiltration
thank you sir okay okay no thank you for
the
the comments so
no dwelling should be occupied until the
verification report pertains to safe
sorts of training systems has been
submitted to the report shall
demonstrate the suitably modeled
operation of the drainage system such
that flood risk is appropriately managed
okay so that's to make sure that it
is going to do what it's meant to do in
time condition
and this has been changed actually from
my uh the earlier
yeah has it been changed
in the revised version number 17 it says
the dwelling shall be no dwelling shall
be occupied no dwelling shall be
occupied until the verification report
pertains to surface water drainage
systems
if it's done on a phase by phase basis
is that going to be slightly
contradictory to
to uh
interestingly in the previous version it
was done on a phase by it was it said no
building on any phase
i was just about to say so does it
require that same caveat
prior to the commencement of the phase
or
a link to phase
yes i'd agree i i must i don't i don't
know how that bit has come out as such
as to what the committee report is i
think it's probably just the the number
but yes indeed the phase basis is more
appropriate
so what should it say uh
no dwelling within the relevant phase
any
that's wording that i've used before if
for that sort of thing
mr ball these are sort of things that
can go wrong if they're not
completely drafted um
i mean presumably if um if mr
livingston's used it before and incurred
no problems with condition
discharge
or stalling sites or whatnot
it may just need sorry to jump it may
just need a
another link to the phasing after
pertaining to surface water drainage
systems in that phase or something
similar to that so it's very clear it's
respective phase and the surface range
in that phase
yeah okay
okay
yeah so that link is agreed
[Music]
and a small little thing i presume that
really the the end which says that the
flood risk is properly managed and has
been approved by the lead local flood
authority i presume this sort of needs
to be agreed by the local
planning authority who will consult with
the local
the lead local flood authority
yes i think it's it's
you're correct it's i suppose as a
procedural point it's approved by the
local authority uh again i think this is
probably one where we're elaborating on
to make it so transparent about what
we're going to be doing which is to make
sure that the local lead flood authority
which is kcc are happy with this
particular point because of their
intrinsic involvement with the the
generation of the the drainage solution
okay
thank you
so you could use the word agreed with
the legal flood of foreign
um
i think
usually
i'm sort of content with the local
playing authority because i just assume
the local authority and its duties will
consult with and get agreement from the
relevant people
and then give the agreement uh
you have that in the second line
i was just trying to make it clear
we have an approval to be undertaken by
the local panel authority
but the point is that that then needs to
be shown
yeah yeah um
[Music]
yeah arguably the second sentence could
be left out uh overall if i was being uh
sort of driving the precise of this
thing home because it's a matter which
would have to be considered by the local
public authority in dealing with it okay
i think i can
yeah i think i get what's been said
and i can make any necessary adjustments
without
changing the essence of what's been
required
okay
no development so 18
um
this is for
sewerage fall water discharge
i've got nothing to say about that
okay
and 19 is all about
contamination i think um
so
fairly standard
contamination
condition i'm assuming
which i've got no detailed comments on
other than perhaps minor drafting which
i don't really need to raise now because
it has no real
overall significance
uh
18 is about contamination
found to be present
during development
i've got nothing to add to that
other than what we talked about before
about the you know specific approval in
writing by the
local planning authority
okay
19 is so 21 is structured environmental
management plan
nothing from me on that
highways work phasing plan
i've got nothing to add on that
and then 23
specifically requires full final details
of proposed highway works
does this not contradict a little bit
with the earlier condition which says
that the development should be carried
out with those approved plans
i think it links to the um
the extent of engineering operations for
the for the roundabout um as you've
probably seen from your
site visit your your first unaccompanied
site because
you've got quite a level
yeah yeah i noted that yeah
um
all right it says also to detail so
substantially according to the
geometrical letter layout as those
submitted in the plans
um substantially called uh he was going
to be the judge of that okay
okay
this goes back a bit to what i said
about the earlier condition in the 100
conditions saying that it just has to be
submitted in accordance with those plans
but then there seems to be a little bit
of a get out clause which will allow
further changes and there's no real that
early condition there's no real way of
knowing
what those actual changes might amount
to i suspect i know where it's coming
from because they're probably about more
technical matters that don't actually
change the fundamental sort of location
of these things but
they might as written they might allow
for a little bit more than that and you
know it are such clauses needed because
it's in accordance with the plans or not
and as it's a detailed matter
shouldn't any amendments to a detailed
matter be dealt with through a
you know
the right sort of process
rather than as a potential tail piece to
a condition
if i made the the the geometrical layout
point linked to the the plans that have
been cited there it is as you suggested
it's
very clear that it's not meant
sorry it's not meant to uh to allow for
as you say sort of a change to the
layout or indeed the form of of of road
layout that that kcc highways have
actually obviously agreed uh effectively
through this um it is that inevitably
when the development is actually built
out there is some element of um through
other regimes be it through the highway
act
some small technical elements which will
which will change be it you know
lines ever so slightly changing in
location or those elements of things um
as you say if it was to substantially
deviate from those plans
then it's subject to other regimes of
need to come back in
um
but um yeah it's
it's an attempt to future proof but
obviously i appreciate what you're
saying sir that you know we can't we
can't deviate from those plans in in any
you know detail really at all um other
than it's just these little technical
bits and pieces it's just trying to
avoid that conflict you know a few years
down the line yeah i understand i
understand that yeah i understand that
i um it would still be in the you know
the local planning authority has to make
a decision on whether or not to accept
it or not so
from my point of view i would be you
know in a situation where
thinking i'm sure the local
foreign right thing at that time but
okay okay i'm
any more comments on
on that
right this is specifically for the
link road
okay
isn't that in some ways just a
continuation of the previous condition
in terms of asking for the specific
detail
um
because 23 requires full details of the
link local distributor standard link
road
i think that so it's the the
trigger is different in the sense of
it's it's requiring details to come in
as part of the phase one
so that detail sort of within each phase
of the actual road bit rather than the
connection onto the existing network
where the roundabouts are etcetera so
that those bits are looked at through
the reserve matters it's just that
you know as you see the way that they've
been with all of the conditions is all
of the highways things are dealt with in
a block rather than splitting out into
these bits uh you know triggers before
you can do anything these are the
triggers for what what happens at
reserve matters uh or needs to come in
matters
okay
okay i understand anything else for
anybody on that
not for me sir
uh
twenty
five
oh
this is presumably just sort of saying
what matters need to be included as part
of layout effectively
yes
it's the it's i suppose the instructive
part again
yeah
okay
i mean as of all these things i have to
decide whether or not some of these
things are absolutely necessary or
whether or not they can just be sort of
taken as being necessary to come in and
then the local planning authority can
decide if to approve them more you know
negotiate whatever when it comes in with
the reserve matters application but
i see the
rationale behind it
and are these meant to be where it says
access for pedestrians and cycles
cyclists for each phase this is not
actually sort of cycle facilities or
access facilities for each dwelling this
is for the
on a more on a wider basis presumably
per phase
yes that's correct
okay
okay um
and then
requiring safe emergency access okay
again i'll consider that
and then 27 again is a list of other
things that need to be included in the
uh
master application
right the numbering is not completely
out with my numbering here sorry let's
just get to where
right okay
mr dickman johnson
thank you sir just to clarify um when it
says surface water does that include the
subs as well
in 27
somebody wants to come back to that
i only ask because it could potentially
be a large area of water that doesn't
need to be identified
sorry mr dickman um is that the
reference to surface water outfall
yes
sir think that's the following through
because um we've got suds basin but
we've also got plot soak aways and
swales and things like that
thank you
thank you sir
okay
so 28
provision of adequate secure covered
cycle parking facilities within that
phase
okay is that meant to be for each
dwelling or there was a sort of a
building contained flats for that
particular building then this is more
sort of as a detailed
point for each unit or
block of flats
yes so it's it's it's trying to pick up
so that the point about if you if you do
have flats in this development then
obviously making sure there's provision
made again this is uh some part of the
list of conditions that the highway
authority requested um they are again
this one is is again instructed because
obviously we would within the reserve
matters application we're considering
layout
consider the issues of alternative means
of transportation in particular with
regards to our cycle parking policy
yeah okay
right um
so 29
prior to first occupation of each
respective dwelling the completion of
the following works between the dwelling
the adopted highway should have occurred
in accordance with details subject to
submitted pursuant to condition one
footways and footpaths with the
exception of the wearing caused
carriageways
with the exception of the wearing course
but including a turning facility
highway drainage visibility displays is
all this
this it just seems to me that this is
almost
quite a lot of detail that would have to
be no doubt it's important but as a
outline condition
if it says turning facilities
i don't quite know what a turning
facility would be
if there was a
on individual dwellings other than a
presumably something might have don't
know do it but someone have a driveway
or not i just don't know but
is it being a bit over prescriptive at
this stage um um
yes i i i again i i take the point we
have you know we have had issues in the
past with developments where um you know
all the work done hasn't hasn't quite
been finalized and dwellings have
started to be occupied and the trigger
of a condition in terms of making sure
that those elements are finished before
people occupy them
has knock on impact on other things be
it you know council services like you
know
waste and recycling trucks and things
like that going through and
you know and so it's just to ensure that
there's safe access again this is a
condition that the highways authority
looks put on as a pretty much standard
element however i do appreciate given
that the trigger is prior to the
occupation
and it results in something to do with
arguably with how the layout is
constructed
it could move to the reserve matters
sort of stage which would make it maybe
a bit more precise in terms of each
phase could then have a bit more
information in it about what's required
before anyone occupies any development
yeah there's a general point that there
is a line that needs to be drawn
somewhere between the conditions
required that you'd have an outline
permission like this and the conditions
which actually would still be able to go
on a reserve because reserve matters
permissions
could still have conditions on them uh
so there is a line isn't there in terms
of what actually you know is a principal
point which needs to be dealt with
outlines in the full planning permission
and what is actually just uh something
which needs to be sorted out as part of
a reserve matters i'm not saying they're
not important but uh is is this the
appropriate time for them to be
put on ah
okay i'll have to give consideration to
that and these matches so but it's
useful to get your your thoughts ah so
thank you
okay 30 is electric vehicle charging
points
okay
thirty-one
quality
stills without quality
[Music]
if it helps sir i think
the condition also links to the air
quality assessment that was undertaken
by wardell armstrong okay
let's see
yes sir sorry not to jump in and
interrupt as such but i just wanted to
check obviously in that condition 31
we've referred to the
uh district council's uh air quality
technical planning guidance that's
obviously discussed in the committee
reports which went to members which you
do have
um i'm not i'm not sure
off the top of my head within the
questionnaire uh submission that we put
to you with all the policies and
relevant policies et cetera whether or
not that has made its way to you
um if it hasn't we can obviously supply
it it's not a matter of dispute about
these particular conditions though so i
i
i don't know whether or not
it would benefit you to have that when
reviewing these
um it might do
is there any uh
it might do there's always an issue
about conditions that uh
on reasons for conditions people have
policies and there's the policies you
never get as an inspector and sort of
it's like
it happens quite a lot on conditions
that you don't actually sort of see some
of these documents
uh i mean as they're agreed between the
council and the appellants you tend to
sort of think when it's being agreed so
you know is it really for me to be sort
of worrying too much about but sometimes
the detail is is relevant um
well if you want to send a copy of it by
i don't have a problem with that i don't
want to start it
it's agreed between you and the
appellant so okay frankly
is there a date is there actually a
it almost seems like it needs a date on
it to be absolutely clear which document
that is
uh maybe that's all that's needed at
this stage
is it 2016. it's the 2016 one here yeah
i think that will probably suffice
because i can assume that you know
between you and uh mr ball you you know
you're happy with this condition and
that's been looked at so
uh i'm not sure i'll need to look into
the manuscript the detail of that uh
so if you need if you need assistance
sorry sir the um the local plan um
probably overkill but it's included in
my 6.01
um
it is in the in the documents so okay
okay i see thank you
okay i'm just putting i put a line under
something i'm trying to work out what i
meant by it when i was doing this uh
just bear with me a second
something
okay it's just a drafting point i don't
think it needs to be raised at this
juncture so that's okay
yeah so 30
this is for an air quality admissions
statement
so how does this relate to 29
i'm just going to double check the
wardell armstrong air quality report
sorry just just to confirm is it
in the most recent draft is it how it
relates to 31 the condition before sorry
yeah you're right it's around yeah no
sorry you're right yeah
so
the first the first condition
is to get the assessment in which
accords with both the guidance and also
with the
the emissions factor toolkit
which gives you the damage cost which
comes in before the submission of any
reserve matters the second one is prior
to the occupation of the development the
statements provided showing how those
that cost that amount of money
where that has been spent
uh
to deal with the emissions
and then that has to be cleared before
any dwelling is occupied
okay
okay i see thank you for
finding that okay
so moving on then to
right so this is the ecological design
strategy
and
does this now include the uh
the bird protection
area i know it's not called that i'm
trying to think of what it's actually
called but you know the area i mean
um it doesn't actually say no
um where does that where does that come
in then
um i suppose it should be here
and it's an oversight
just
on one point it is
it is partially covered
by reference to section seven of the es
which is obviously the new submission
that's come in
um
but it should be explicit
i think given the amount of explicit
things that are in even though i don't
like too much
it's sort of explicitness in terms of
the details given the fundamental
importance of this it probably is
something that should be should be
included in that list
uh
what's it what's the actual correct term
for it remind me somebody
just check that out is it the uh
it's his bird mitigation area it is
right so it is the bird mitigation area
so
[Music]
because this condition would actually
include
the detailed design of it effectively or
certainly the design strategy for it so
it's quite fundamental to its
correct implementation i assume
i don't know i agree so yeah
mr dickman
yes um
as we make clear in our our conditions
we do feel that an off-site mitigation
area should be
negotiated and set up should that be
built into this just to highlight that
well that was discussed wasn't it in the
ecology session mr
ball you're probably best to respond to
that rather than
um well obviously we can only control
what falls within the red edge and
there's no off-site land available
but i've i heard what was said mrs
obviously in that discussion where that
was discussed so obviously that's one of
the matters i've got to go away and uh
consider but that's as i say it's not
actually proposed within the the size i
think that might have been a question
asked at the time but i
understand your point but no it's not
covered by this
condition as i understand it i won't
expect it to be given what the proposal
as mr paul says includes so
okay but we do need to include that in
there
and is is there anywhere maybe it's
going to come on to it that would
ensure that the
that area remains
or
used for its intended purpose in the
same way that the sort of a classic
carriage condition says it shall remain
used as a garage for its intended
purpose not that anybody seems to do
that anymore but
uh
does it need is there somewhere where
there needs to be some
clause that says that actually such
details need to be
maintained in perpetuity whatever the
words are
i mean it would benefit as part of the
condition
it's obviously included in the es
and its facts in
mitigating
the impacts i mean the overall
management i think is set out in the
legal agreement
which talks about open space management
and
how that's maintained
actually it does say actually that all
features shall be retained in that
manner thereafter actually so
probably sort of got
uh it has got that clause in actually
and i presume that the ecological design
strategy one of the things will be need
to be in it is how it is maintained
going forward and all those management
details to uh let's say coupled with the
with the planning obligation but that
would be an expected expectation of that
i would assume yeah yeah because
obviously it will control the planting
type things like the beetle bank and
whatnot yeah
okay
okay um
condition 32
details pursuant sorry condition 34
going off my list again details pursuant
to condition one shall a birth shall
demonstrate compliance and alignment
with the
agreed ecological design strategy
of course it does but i'd expect that to
be done anyway so i'm not quite sure
what conditions needed to spell that out
uh
thinking aloud
34 you've got in your list
the grid list goes from 34 to 36.
is there any uh
is that just a typo
i think it could be a typo i think it
probably is because my list goes to 30
the next one on my list is the next one
on that list so it confuses my numbering
a bit more but uh
it doesn't look as though the one's been
missed out so
uh
okay that's
for uh outdoor lighting scheme etc okay
i will consider that i've got nothing to
comment on this at this time
and then secure by design
what's the views on the parties as to
whether or not something like secure by
design needs to be included now as a
conditional it can be dealt with as a
condition of a reserve matter
i mean
it could easily go to reserve matter
yes sir i think
i feel i'm repeating repeating exactly
the same point so um
about about what's instructive in terms
of what expectations are with regards to
local authority um mr hester's going to
come in i think yeah
it's one of those issues that get caught
up with the design code in my experience
um
so
it can go into that or be considered
under that heading if necessary
okay okay i'll give some consideration
to that and i think yeah it's probably a
point that yeah i've made aware you're
able already that i'll have to consider
which of these are absolutely necessary
at this stage i mean things like
obviously
contamination conditions things like
that obviously sort of are but some of
the more sort of detailed things what's
not underplaying their importance are
they necessary at this stage
okay um
so where were we so light
uh
we've done light um
yeah the next one
yeah 38 details and samples and
materials to be used
i'm
not sure about that one at this stage
because that's just a matter which will
be the external appearance won't it so
okay
um
where are we now 39
just catching up for my list
details pursuant to condition one shall
show no development on land identified
as safeguarded lands for the potential
future road
okay
and that's already in the
master plan
that's correct yeah and presumably the
position has to be carried out in
accordance with the master plan so is it
again a necessary duplication or is
there a
specific need to have this in
i think um
the highway authority would say it is
required
just checking the wording of condition
six in regards to the parameter plan
just to make it absolutely clear and i
think i think yes it it
it's it's firm enough with the reference
in condition six
i mean it is absolutely understand the
importance of it uh
but just trying to avoid any unnecessary
repetition
[Music]
okay
uh
where are we now
all dwellings hit by committee shall be
provided with the ability for connection
to superf okay uh super fast fiber optic
broadband
where there is adequate
capacity
okay uh
any comments on that one no
thirty
eight
this is a parking restriction strategy
detailing the full extent of the
proposed traffic regulation order
the double yellow lines on hearthstone
road
and the internal link road
infrastructure shall be submitted to an
approved and writing by the local
planning authority in consultation with
the highway authority
the strategy suddenly progressed through
the applicant's best endeavors
i'm not sure about that last bit uh
i i think so this is this is the again
it comes down to that conflict between
the process under the highway act yes
and the process of the planning act
so it's almost requiring some off-site
works here
which will require traffic regulation
order but it also includes i think some
from reading is some
the internal road link road
infrastructure as well in terms of
whether or not any uh
presumably parking restrictions are
required for that as well
i think the link that the uh the link to
hearts
download football club
and to avoid parking near the football
club right
okay
um i understand um
42 travel plan
details pursuant to condition one
the relevant phase adjacent to
designated footpath tm14
shall
show the footpath retained
the footpath's outside of the
application inside or is it not is the
football is the footpath is t is tm14
is this the one that goes up sort of
north west from the dwellings which i
think sort of called as the 20s or at
least on
one map i've seen
or is it the other footpath
no that's tm14 yeah and it's outside the
site
so is this outside the site
a first part of the condition could be
removed it's the the access points is
the key the key element in terms of the
the the tests of the policy that are
referred to in the ground okay so the
idea is that the reserve matters showing
layout show
pedestrian access points from the
development itself to the footpath which
i completely understand again it's a
obviously a layout matter
okay
uh it's just dealing with a very
specific clause within the policy
yeah
is there a separate obligation to
actually make improvements to the
footpath
um it is included
within the obligation
that the county council could
make improvements
yeah
okay
is the
homo homeowner information pack which we
in connection with
biodiversity
okay
the development hereby permitted shall
be constructed to a high standard of
energy efficiency to the equivalent of
level four of the code sustainable homes
unless otherwise agreed in writing with
the local planning authority
er
i'm not sure about this sort of high
standard because it seems quite vague as
to what the high standard is but
presumably what he's meant is equivalent
to level four of the code for
sustainable homes
unless otherwise agreed in writing with
a local planning authority
yeah the
piece to it either sorry yes that i
appreciate that the tail piece here that
this relates to the fact that the the
local the policy itself qdo
one which related which was obviously
found sound examination but with the
inspector i believe making a main
modification to ensure that it relates
to an equivalent level of right
equivalent to level four because level
four strictly speaking isn't or isn't
the standard that people use anymore
yeah um
so
there is a requirement under the policy
to ensure those the standards uh meet
that um that previous level
uh which was on a base of uh units of of
effectively energy efficiency
you know
so
the
tailpiece element i suppose that indeed
that could come out and it could be a
variation um
obviously
this is again to mr hester's point early
some flexibility both how the standards
are assessed with regards to different
measures of say insulation
um but also to acknowledge that actually
there may be a subsequent um
subsequent standard that would be
applicable or should be applicable
is it is it because sometimes these
conditions i see them as sort of termed
you know actual details have to be
submitted for approval in writing if
it's not absolutely clear as to
i mean i've been thinking about this
little time scales for this scheme
that i certainly don't like to the high
standards i just don't know what who
obviously judge the high standard that's
sort of not even that's precise at all i
get a bit about equivalent to level four
the code for sustainable homes although
even that is slightly
uh
unclear given that that doesn't
exist so to speak
a suggestion then sir
is it worth having
actually so i was going to suggest
referring to the policy when looking at
the condition the very the condition
towards the top of things was it
condition five where we listed what we
expect in a reserve matters application
um
whether or not there's a potential
provision to go in there
which includes therefore the submission
definitively sort of comes in which
outlines
energy efficiency i appreciate it's in
the master plan condition but it's not
the precision that you get
with regards to reserve matters of
what's actually happening to these
particular dwellings
um
whether or not it comes in at the
reserve matter state and therefore it's
assessed then on that basis against the
policy framework
is the policy still
going to be in existence necessarily at
that time well it it's
i think maybe that's why it might be
prudent to move into there because i
think obviously we have a local
as you as you know we have a local plan
review yeah consultation on that and
there are going to be updates to issues
to do with energy efficiency so i think
it's probably appropriate to maybe not
fix it at this stage
um okay
um
mr ball any comments on no sorry i was
just trying to check the policy um
i mean ian's suggestion seems perfectly
logical to me
to put the actual policy reference in
um
is that what you were sorry don't
misunderstand
too
sorry to to jump in whilst mr paul's
looking
i was i was thinking more about
obviously
you know
the details where you for example in
scale and appearance or or you know or
one of those sort of sections it refers
specifically to
these the element of um
you know energy efficiency measures um
using the wording pretty much of the
condition um inserts you know at that
point
um
again this is a condition which we do
you know we do put it on new development
to ensure it records of this
um and you know it does go on as
standard um given that the nature of i
do accept though that given that the the
course of this development
you know that when reserve matters come
in
you know stuff may well have superseded
which may mean that reserve matters we
are looking at those things you know
anyway and it's that as you say said
that conflict between outline and
reserve matters yeah and the uh
conflicts let's say the conflict with
the links with the building regulations
well i was just about to raise that so i
mean it is it's one of those conditions
that i know why it's there um i fully
appreciate why it's there but there is
also a separate um
regulation system that is in any event
going to govern but that doesn't
distract from why it needs to be there
yeah
yeah and it is a matter which has to be
dealt with under the planning policies
as well
it's one of those areas where there
seems to be a bit of
a uh
doubling up of
[Music]
requirements er
so mr livingston your suggestion was
to put the actual reference to the
policy in it
my suggestion would be that
if if it was felt that it it
it would be sort of
difficult at this stage
given the sort of as you said the
wording elements of i think the point
about equivalence for for codes of
sustainable homes is that is the bit for
new development it's constructed in a
you know to be equivalent to that
if that part of this condition
was moved into either
the uh condition five which required
details of it in the reserve matters
or
if it's felt like it was uh potentially
possible to get and i suppose in earlier
stages whether or not it could
you know it could go to the design code
condition um but i suppose the phase
condition may be the better because it
actually relates then to the
the realities of
knowledge of what's going to be
constructed at that given point um when
you get to that phase plan
sorry um that present matter stage i see
yeah
okay
and the design code will obviously feed
through to that as well yeah
yeah just sort of have the best way the
most precise way to get it
to get it picked up
okay i will give consideration to that
that that suggestion in that discussion
thank you okay
uh
right so
we're now at
46.
okay water efficiency condition
presumably this links into policy you
know qd
zero four
liters per person per day
okay
another link with the building
regulations
okay
and then
is refers to the
previously discussed nationally
described space standards um
okay
and accessible adaptable accommodation
provided in accordance with qd05
i presume that's just going to be a
matter which will be again considered as
part of the layout anyway when the
council considers layout it will have
all the floor plans of the development
and that could be considered at that
stage
again is it need to be does it need to
be absolutely specified here maybe it
does i don't know it's an
open question
um
i mean it makes clear that you have to
meet the standards you know
it
it's rather hinging on the test of
conditions being very precise about what
has to happen but i accept the point
again it's the same argument
yeah okay
right all right that's the end of the
that's the end of that list um
there's no actual dwelling mix condition
suggested in
again going back to previous
evidence given
is that because it's simply a matter
that will be picked up at reserve
matters stage
i mean yes you would have to meet sp22
and this permission wouldn't actually
set any
presume it's not actually details on the
application form the other part of the
application form where you tick or you
put the numbers of dwellings in each uh
in each category
as it's an outline application i don't
think that section is in the application
form off the top of my head
okay
yeah i think there is something
it's got it down as unknown
so in the application form
so you're correct it is that it's got
the table yeah
so what are the figures under unknown in
the table under um no there's three six
one twenty four
there seems to be
there is actually figures that do amount
to four hundred and fifty
although the actual let's say i see the
actual that's just the number of houses
flats
and maisonettes
but not an indication of actually the
actual dwelling mix in terms of number
of bedrooms
so is that what is the view on is there
a need for such a condition on the
housing mix
well obviously when when the reserve
matters come in we're not fixed at this
point and the reserve matters
application would have to meet sp 22.
so
is it strictly necessary
so it's not
in your opinion of
one of those matters like for example
like contamination where if it's not
picked up at the outline stage
it's too late at the reserve matters
stage
no
no because obviously we're not fixed at
this point um
do you agree with me listerine stay with
that
i i agree that it's not fixed at this
stage it's something that you know
elements
certainly well certainly the
consideration of the policy can be
picked up out at reserve master stage
yeah i've seen it put on outline
permissions before i'm just thinking
through
actually when the reserve matters come
in when you have the details of the
layout and the whole dwelling mix
you will know then what the actual
dwelling mix is
and then that the local authority can
just test that against its relevant
policies and whatever else at that time
because it's not fixed at this point
okay well i've heard your views and
obviously it's something i'll have to
come to a view
on
okay but it's not one of the suggested
conditions as proposed by the
parties so i i i appreciate that okay
um
mr dickman have you covered off your
points that you've raised in your note
was there anything else you want to
because you've raised points about
surface water drainage
yeah
yes uh i mean i which i think was picked
up in the uh discussion wasn't it um
it it was and of course um
it's that notion of identifying uh
ownership of the book um
and
if that isn't done it's uh should it a
specific request that a contribution of
kent county councils believe flood
authority is required
we are still very concerned about
um
the water runoff there
and who is responsible for that and the
possible knock-on effect that could have
not only to community but any new
residents moved in on site so
that is still
very pertinent to us
the other areas all we would ask um
certainly in terms of look at the
uh the lighting
um
the home ownership packs those smaller
issues
if i should call them small issues that
they are very important to us and we
would just really like to reinforce that
um we would hope they would be carried
out in a timely manner in due diligence
and and and that
as as mr livingston will probably
testify
uh suarez are a very active residence
association and not only will we if it
does go ahead we'll be working with the
residents
the new residents we will be ensuring
that all those issues
have been looked at
okay
thank you um okay i understand
thank you for that
it's the mission
uh let me just quickly
okay
okay take the points that you've raised
into account in my considerations of the
conditions
as well obviously i've got to decide you
know as of any condition what meets the
relevant tests and i will
i will do so
uh
at the relevant point depending on my
decision of course
okay um okay
thank you i think that's everything in
connection with conditions is there
anything else anybody else wishes to
raise on
conditions before we break for lunch
not for me
not from mesa
okay
thank you everybody
uh so it's quarter past one
so if we break till uh
two o'clock
if that is okay 45 minutes is okay for
everybody
and then we'll come back and consider
the
planning obligation uh or plan playing
obligations
and i've got all the relevant
information
in that regard i've got a few questions
that i want to ask and i think it was
the intention i saw a submission whereby
i think it was proposed that one of the
appellants representatives i don't know
who's going to be mr williams but sort
of like talks through some of the
obligations or provisions and the
obligations but i've got a note sort of
setting out that so that sounds a
sensible way forward uh because there's
a few questions i'll probably want to
ask along the way and others might do as
well thank you very much
okay
good uh i think it's high time for lunch
for everybody so if we adjourn now
and return at
two o'clock
thank you thank you sir
[Music]
okay it's two o'clock so time to
recommence the inquiry uh
welcome back everybody so we've got now
to the stage of considering the
draft planning obligation
of which i've received
copies yesterday
before we do so
any uh
other matters that anybody
wishes to raise at this point in
housekeeping matters
just on timetabling just in terms of
potential costs application
are we
expecting
i know that there's been a cost
application foreshadowed by the
appellant oh are we still expecting that
mr williams that's right say yes
okay
and are we expecting any further of the
cost simplifications from any other
party
just so i can think about timing
okay so we'll
we'll do the planning obligation session
which will take
half an hour three quarters of an hour
we'll see and then we'll move on to
uh closing submissions
and just in terms of the
two advocates mr
uh up to how long approximately for your
closing submissions
i think i'm looking at about 40 minutes
then um
okay and mr up to mr williams rather
about an hour
maybe just over an hour
okay
and mr dickman have you yo yeah you are
new experience for me we um i i shall
give it my best i suspect probably i
would hope uh 30 to 40 minutes
okay
and if you have uh
electronic copies available
yet i know some of you might still be
i've literally just been in contact with
mr hanson he's just finishing it off and
i'm sure he'll get it out to everybody
as soon as possible
okay
and the same for mr williams i've
disrupted i'm aware you might still be
sort of working on
on them but it was some fine tuning yes
and obviously live this morning so
yeah
that's fine
i mean if we're in the situation where
i'm thinking about an email not coming
through to me because the case officer
might not be at a desk or whatever but
i'm i'll still be happy to to listen i
don't necessarily need the notes in
front of me in fact some respects it's
actually some respect it's actually just
easier to listen rather than follow on a
note
to a certain degree so
it wouldn't be the end of the world of
those don't come through to me i'm just
thinking about possible
email issues getting them through to
holly and then to me okay let's continue
on then with discussion of the planning
obligation
uh so who is going to be part of this
discussion
sir can i introduce rachel goddard who
is the solicitor who's been
preparing and dealing with the 186 on
behalf of the appellate
good afternoon so good afternoon because
how should i refer to you mrs goddard
okay
thank you
and
mr ball we have here and
for the
council mr livingstone i'm assuming
uh yes it'll be probably myself and mr
hester may be coming in as well okay
that's necessary thanks
okay thank you
and mrs goddard do you want to sort of
kick off by sort of introducing
where you got to as the appellant in
terms of the
yes please sir agreements and i have got
your
planning obligation summary
yes no
that was intended sir as a speaking note
for me um to take you through the draft
yeah and what i do need to check is
whether you've got the plans that go
with the agreement draft on the uu draft
so you should have a site plan a phasing
plan and a link road plan
and the road plan only relates
go through what i've got i've got 106
agreement i've got 106 uh unilateral
undertaking
i've got indicative phasing plan
yes
and then i've got your notes and then
location plan yes that's the site plan
yeah yeah
and then there's a further document
which is the uh section 106 highways
corridor
version yes and that's that's what we've
described as a link road plan yeah in
the drafting oh i see right okay
um yeah so just by way of background
this um the drafting started off life as
a precedent that was sent to us by the
local planning authority which related
to a westwood village
site
and then laterally we've separated out
the affordable housing and viability
provisions that the local planning
authorities request
and but i've done the summary on the
basis of both because they're all
planning obligations
um so shall i go through the the summary
for you now sir
okay if you can go through fairly
briefly and then i can if i have any
particular
points i can interject with any
questions so which
is it the unilateral first or the uh the
106 agreement first um well as i say in
the in this summary sir i've dealt with
both together i see um
because they are all obligations so i've
distinguished um whether it's a
paragraph and a schedule in the uu or or
in or in the agreement
by simply referring to it as if it's in
the uu right
and all the
expressions that i've used that have
capital letters they are defined terms
in either either one of those drafts
um so i suppose it's just a flag up to
you so the um
what obligations there are to be
performed before commencement of
development so that's at the foot of the
first page of the summary
and i think the only um
point that i've made that isn't
completely clear is that the notice to
both councils of commencement and um
commencement of each phase that does
appear in both the uu and in the draft
agreement so that's the first point of
them
and then the contributions are dealt
with over the over the page
and the first
part deals with contributions to the
council these are all on a per-phase
basis
the additional off-site contribution
that is only payable if a surplus is
identified in a circle in a further
appraisal in the uu
um the sam
contribution
and the health center contribution are
also contributions that go to the lpa
[Music]
and i think you'd raised a query earlier
on in the inquiry sir about the sam
contribution and there is a covenant by
the council
um to spend that in accordance with the
sam
so you will find that in in the um in
the agreement if i can just
yes interrupt at that point because that
was one of my
questions so let's just deal with that
now this is in the section 106 agreement
isn't it yes
because what i was looking for
which bit of it because i've seen the
bit about the
the payment etcetera and the
obligation on the appellant can make the
payment
yeah
um the council's covenants in schedule
seven
right has this been added in from the
draft i saw earlier in the week no no
this this has always been and so
um
it's just in a a non-specific way i
suppose that's why you might not have um
picked it up okay i'm just flicking
through perhaps yeah and so it's the use
of contributions and it's paragraph 1.1
so
not to use any um some other than for
the purpose for which it's being paid as
specified in this deed and of course the
specification is in the definition of
the sum contribution
okay let me just read this myself
okay it probably wasn't quite as
specifically
framed as
i was expecting it to be
that's why it required an explanation so
um
okay i mean i've always i've already
asked mrs livingston the question and
then we had a separate session i'm not
sure you were you were listening earlier
in the week on the on the sam's issue
and i asked about the question of what
certainty can i have that the actual
council will spend the money on the
required
uh
mitigation at the required time to
mitigate this development so i've
already got that answer from mr
livingstone
i don't know if you want to add anything
slivers down at this stage but
i'm not not really mr cleveland in
comparison to where we where we were
i'm gonna say two days ago two days ago
um with regards to how we spend it uh
indeed the covenant in the agreement for
this part of things with you know happy
to sign up to that covenant that it's
spent on the purposes to which it's been
provided
yeah
okay
okay okay
thank you and that does have reference
to the strategic access and monitoring
plan in the definition so yeah if that
helps
yeah yes i've seen that yeah
shall i continue to continue on please
um yes so the the county council
contributions at the request of the lpa
are all paid to the council um and they
they're on a per-phase basis and they
will form a contribution part
and that the counts the county council
can draw from
in agreement with the council
and then there is a maximum fixed for
each of those county council
contributions that the parties regard as
self-compliant
and the county council can prioritize
highways and education
and i've i've noted the schedules and
the paragraph numbers there for you to
check those
cross-references
and i've got separately and i can take
it as being read the county council's
appeal statement where they give their
qualifications for
their relevant contributions so i've got
that and read that
okay
and so the county council contributions
are calculated at 10
338 pounds 12
per residential unit
um
which is a house um and then
a lower amount for flats but those
figures vary if there is the county top
up contribution payable so if the county
council gets their
funding for their link road and that
frees up the developer from building the
link road and further payments can be
made and that's described as the county
top up contribution
right okay
i see
and
general question
so i've got details of all the
relevant
payments that will be applicable per
residential unit
where is the reference to in terms of
making sure that
it meets the test in terms of being
fairly reasonably related to the scale
and kind which is there a sort of
document that sort of sets out that you
like the formulae first
the calculations that results in those
figures
where does that where do the figures
come from
i would have to defer to others um i've
been instructed on as regards the
self-compliance statement i'm afraid
is there a is there a
spd or the like that i have
i should be referred to in this regard
sorry i was on mute um so
in
terms so is it just to confirm is it the
the individual figures related to the
individual's elements so for example
primary school contribution is it the
individual
figures and how they've been generated
or is it the
total amount that's been
stated on her dwelling basis which
relate to the kcc contributions you see
what i mean
uh i think i do i think it's both just
in terms of me being able to be sure
that that figure
has been obviously that figure has been
presumably has been sort of calculated
and the rationale behind that but the
justification for that so i can be sure
that it's you know it it's fair and
reasonable for the dealers guests
so um
the
the all of the projects that have been
listed um which are the if we take the
county council contributions relate to
the specific requests that were put
forward during the application stage by
the county which is the statement which
you have
um which was sent through um both the
representation during the application
but then the county have separately sent
a statement in which you've got hold
that within it has appendices
unfortunately my cell compliance
statement refers to the county statement
and provides that statement but it
doesn't actually provide the appendices
the appendices of that kcc statement
has the justification as to how the
calculations been
been worked out including on a which it
varies depending on which which one
we're looking at
um
in terms of how that's been factored in
the planning committee report from
april which you'll
have within all various documents
um goes through the approach that the
council and the county had taken
with regards to the amount of money that
the the african from their submission
were putting forward for the
contributions for this uh this sort of a
lot of
which related to how we were working
this idea of having a a pot which linked
to the the clear priorities that both
councils have um specifically with
regards to education and highways and
that is the particular regard to the
policy which you'll be more than
familiar which is
with regards to the off-site highways
contribution and also sp 41 which is the
community and utility infrastructure
uh policy um so in terms of how we get
to the figures is
they're the ones that generated by kcc
and are provided on that on that basis
um that then
basically was worked into this method of
of having a submission that comes into
the the district council on a
per-dwelling basis and to which in the
obligation obviously this
it goes back to the point where we talk
about the god's conditions and it's
about the the time frame that we're
talking about with regards to this
development
will extend with projects um that have
been whilst they've been identified
they're in flux in terms of when they're
coming on board and that obviously links
in part to
how things are progressing with regards
to the highway network and you'll see in
the sil compliance statement
um there's an appendix which talks about
the most recent sort of advances in the
major road network bid and how that is
factoring into may factor into different
timings which both relate to the top-up
that
mrs goddard stated but also obviously
there's an element of that contribution
which is for off-site works could be
used to match fund for a bid that kcc
are doing for the major road network um
so
it's to give that clear flexibility but
that is very clearly and distinctly
within the remit
of the seal regulations by virtue of
identifying these projects and ensuring
that the mitigation therefore goes
towards only these projects with an
upper cap on
where you know how much could go to each
each element
okay and the
the ken county council appendix to its
uh
statement
which appendix is i'm just trying to uh
is it a core document
no it's not so this isn't this is
unfortunately this is
my error in the sill statement silk
implant statement uh i depended
uh i depended the actual comment of kcc
yeah but the appendices to that comment
which i have referred to in the sill
statement
are not appended to my source statement
but they are with you
right
yeah that explains because i think i
just probably printed off what you sent
me and i've got yes
page 20 and i've not got the i do
apologize about that
the um i can give you the references for
for future use if that helps but they
are the appendices stated i think it's
appendix
2 2 a 3
and i think there is a fourth one as
well
to the kcc submission because there's a
kcc on
on here today
but they have this admission that they
put in
as their statement
in the november submission
includes these appendices
they're listed on the back actually kcc
economic development letter education
assessment
so
they'll have sent this in with the did
they send this in separately to
i presume they submitted this separately
or do they submit it by you
no they submitted it separately to you
sir
right
okay i think
on that if i've not got those for any
reason
i think i will have to
make an additional request for them but
i think i had got them somewhere amongst
the many documents
i think it was all part of the kcc
statement case
yeah so yeah
just bear with me a second
okay i'm not going to spend time digging
them out now but if there is any sort of
issue there the
three of any reason then i'll have to
make a separate request
for those as a sort of post inquiry sort
of document so to speak but
i'll do so if that's the case
okay okay
and
are there any
contributions
that
i think there might be for example
health that wouldn't be covered by the
county council where there is separate
justification provided
over and above what's in your
compliance statement
so
so it's the um the health care
contribution is so there are two
contributions which aren't county
contributions one of which is the sams
which we talked about the other one is
as you say is the is the sort of health
care contribution
um so the letter that was received with
uh the planning application
has been submitted to you as the
appendix in the seal compliance
statement that i sent in which is the
letter requesting
you're requesting
the the contribution
okay
thank you
uh mrs goddard sorry for that
interruption but i just wanted to get
that clarified yeah thank you sir um
i don't know whether you want to go back
to look at the pot the contribution pot
drafting but that is um schedule 7 for
the council's covenants paragraph 1.2
and schedule 8 for the county councils
covenants paragraphs one point one and
one code two
and then
in addition the county council
contributions are payable again on a per
phase basis and in installments so
there's 35 percent prior to commencement
35 prior to 25 occupation and 30 prior
to 50
occupation
and then i think my next point um goes
to something mr ball was mentioning in
relation to phases and that the county
council contributions for phases two and
three
are payable along with um those four
phase one a
okay
and then in case those phases ie two and
three haven't yet got reserved matters
um then there is a formula to address
that position which involves giving some
money and then possibly having it paid
back if it turned out to be too much
okay
and next part of the um summary
just is a list of those
contributions that the parties regard
are still compliant which are the county
council contributions and they're all
calculated on a per residential unit
basis
um and the county top-up contribution is
payable only if the county council
constructs the link road
which obviously frees up the developer
with more funds to enable that to be
paid
um
the and you sir you have the blue pencil
clause which is 7.28 where you can
strike out any contributions that you
don't consider still complying
yeah
okay
let me just
[Music]
that's 7.28 of the uh of the agreement
yeah of the unilateral isn't it no no of
the agreement so
okay
let me get that back open sorry too many
screens
so i've resorted to paper i'm afraid so
yeah
i'm a hybrid uh so
so that's in seven let me just turn to
that
page 15.
right yes 7.28 yep yes
and then we go on to affordable housing
obligations and these are in the uu
rather than in the agreement
um
operative part
schedule three
okay
yeah um so the percentage which there
has been a lot of discussion about in in
the inquiry that i've heard um is
according to viability and user can can
decide that if and the sum of the
percentage than the 15
and it is offered and that figure can be
imposed so it could be 30 or it could be
something between 15 and thirty percent
okay let me just get a bit of the
agreement which uh paragraph
this is in the uu and it's schedule
three part one
and paragraph two point one
right affordable housing schedule three
okay
right
so
a question or two on this i understand
what that's
what that does
and there was a little bit of discussion
on this earlier on
but effectively it allows me to if i was
to
be in a position to allow the appeal to
say 15 30 percent or any figure in
between
the zionists
if you say nothing sir it would end up
at 15 by default
yeah
um well what i'm not quite sure about is
what on what basis would i wish to do so
based on all the figures all the
evidence before me on what basis might i
might i do that
if you'd had any evidence during the
course of the inquiry that led you to a
different percentage so
obviously this has been drafted up
slightly before and during the course of
um
because if i was to do so i mean i've
got a number of i do have a number of
concerns about it but first if i was to
do so i
need very say for example i was to
picking a figure out of out of thin air
i was to say oh i think this should be
where would i get the evidence and the
figures for that given all the variables
and there's different obviously inputs
and
i might agree on one thing i might not
agree on other things but where would i
be led to to come categorize
categorically to a situation where i
could say
yes i think there could be x amount of
affordable housing
it just seems to me that you know the
information before me there isn't any
there's not as there's an alternative
assessment that's been sort of
agreed as far as possible which would
lead me to sort of to that conclusion it
seems as though i'd be sort of coming to
a figure but without really this sort of
empirical evidence before me
sort of leading
to that i know there's some predictions
of things from various parties but even
the
the the dsp
uh submission that's obviously at a high
level so you know i just find it so
difficult to think what how i've been a
situation where i'd be able to
comfortably
do that and the other point is
it's not the scheme that's before me and
it's not a scheme that would be before
residents in terms of another figure and
other people wouldn't have had a chance
to other parties wouldn't have a chance
to comment on it so
i've got some i've got some concerns
about how how that's meant to sort of
operate within the sort of the
within the context of the information
that i've got
yeah well that that's absolutely the
point sir it is it is down to the
information that you have got or you
haven't gotten i suppose it's a question
that um
where i in your position i would have
directed to the um to the council
yeah miss williams your hand reserves or
anything do you understand my sort of
like slight concern about it in terms of
i mean i can choose to
you know go along that route or not i i
appreciate that but
i think that's exactly the point
to be frank i mean
some of this overlaps with the closing
submissions obviously and
i'm not quite sure the friend's going to
be submitting but
we came into the case um
with our
position being
that
you should
um grant permission
subject to a requirement for 15
affordable housing and from our
perspective
that's why
that's why that figure is obviously in
the 106.
and if you don't say
anything about an alternative figure
that's the
the way the 106 operates is that 15
would be the default position
um the
drafting
allows for the fact that you disagree
with that case for whatever reason i
don't want to get into the wise and rare
cause of that now
but if you felt that
um it should be 30 then that is open to
you and from what mr hester said that
appeared to be
his position
um
the
middle ground if you like is is there so
that if
an entirely matter for you
if you found the evidence disclosed a
percentage that was greater than 15
but less than 30
and that was what was required to make
the development acceptable
then you could specify that figure it's
not something that on the evidence i'm
going to be
asking you to do
but in terms of the operation of the 106
it's there so that if having been
through this whole exercise
you decide that there is an alternative
figure between 15 and 30 then that
option is available to you
i mean i totally understand your
concerns but i think they're sort of
evidential concerns that you like rather
than
points of
legality in terms of how the 106 would
operate
yeah yeah no okay thank you that's
that's helpful um
mr up so you've appeared on my screen
have you got something else you wanted
to add
facebook
i just wanted to just pick it up because
obviously
as i believe the last point mr williams
made was that
um what you have before you is obviously
a legal um
contract in the way that is trying to
cover off various issues and
clearly it was offered at this and
drafted a stage
it probably wasn't predictable where the
evidence was going to go so i was trying
to cover lots of different options and
i certainly have my concerns about this
sort of middle range that somehow you
can pick a figure out of the
out of the uh evidence um
as to whether that's really a
satisfaction i suppose it may be two
things here that it may work legally but
it may not be a wise thing to do in
policy terms
when it comes to what planning
obligations are seeking to do and how
certain they should be but
just to be clear in our approach you
heard mr hester is that if it's not
being shown that
um 30 is not achievable then that's the
figure that
should be used
um and
at the moment obviously the appellant is
very much promoting 15
um so i wasn't going to propose some
sort of intermediate for you because
you're quite right as it's been
mentioned dsp's work was high level so
you know you wouldn't
form a
span basis upon which for you to then
pick a figure um i think mr eyes just
certainly putting a figure to you and
that's certainly one alternative
um but
um i do have a concern about the way
this is trying to do everything
um
and trying to say whatever the results
of your conclusions we can still get our
permission there's a limit to what the
unilateral can really cover
um and so that's really my concern i
was slightly worried about what he was
seeking to achieve but
i think i would agree with mr williams
that in terms of its its drafting
um it would cover these different
eventualities
it's whether that's um
a proper approach in terms of planning
policy i think a separate question
okay and just
one more
question from me probably to beau from
structure mr williams
if i was to fight if i was to have
concerns about the 15 proposal
for whatever reason
uh
[Music]
are you both saying that rather than
actually
dismissing the obviously the other
considerations take into account so
obviously ecology drainage and all the
other things we've talked about
but if if viability was to be the only
uh issue outstanding issue remaining in
my mind
this is hypothetical
that you'd
both propose that i would
allow the appeal but on the basis of a
thirty percent affordable housing
or obviously the intermediary figure but
let's you know i'll put that aside for a
moment but is that what you're
you'd both be suggesting maybe this is
something you're gonna address in your
closing solutions anyway i don't know
but you're like should i just start off
because i think it's obvious really
supposed to give you a more detailed
answer
um from our perspective
it's really what is it that the opponent
is offering that's what the unilateral
essentially does so
what are they putting on the table
before you um
may well determine the answer to that
question
um
whether it
works whether it works in policy terms i
i have my reservation but obviously we
had sought 30 percent if that's actually
what's being offered
um then there's a matter of logic that
would seem to follow that that
could satisfy you um as long as you're
satisfied with the planning obligation
that
uh the particular policy requirement or
expectation is met so
that's that's my initial reaction guys
but i i've had a hesitation because i
haven't been involved with the natural
um discussions and obviously as to what
has been put forward it's been a matter
for the opponent to decide
um
but certainly i
i haven't quite come across this
situation before i can't say well this
is something that's been done before
with this sort of one or the other but
as i said that's that's where i'm coming
from is that
um i think it needs further
consideration
um but it does partly depend on what the
appellant is prepared for you to to
consider
yeah okay
thank you
mr williams
well sir the 30 percent is there
so that if you disagreed with the
appellant's viability case you would
grant permission
the subject to that percentage
and
you ask the question in relation to the
viability issue just isolate the
viability issue and the a
106 of 30
overcomes any any viability issue and
say
logically there would be compliance with
sp
23 anyway
and permission would be granted
and it's not quite right to say that
unilateral is simply there in terms of
what the developers offering the role of
a unilateral
is it's an obligation that would run
with the land
and the relevant question for the
decision maker is whether or not that
obligation is necessary
um in the it renders the development
acceptable
so the logic is if you think it's
necessary for there to be a 30
affordable housing provision in order to
make the development acceptable it would
make the regulation one two two tests
and permission would be granted on that
on that basis
i mean the logic's the same if you like
whether it's 15 or 30
it's what's required following the
evidence to render the development
acceptable
and i
i don't take this discussion much
further but if
there was like some concern over one
part of the viability assessment
which resulted in concern that it
couldn't do
15 but it might do a figure that's
slightly slightly more
because if i was to go to sort of 30
percent there's probably
uh you would probably say
that you know on the basis of the
evidence that the balance obviously
feels that 30
is far from being viable and i don't
know how it would sort of sit in terms
of making any decision
based on 30 which is not
you know there's no evidence to say that
that is actually viable
in terms of allowing such a scheme that
would that wouldn't that sort of sit
slightly sort of uncomfortable with me
as well in terms of that approach
well i
i don't want to get drawn too much into
discussing the evidence because you know
i recognized the
concern um but without anticipating the
closings
too much even though we're just about to
hear them i suppose
um
in my
submission if that's the appropriate
word that's the product of the evidence
that's been presented
rather than
the effect or justification
for
the provision within the 106.
i'm choosing my words quite carefully
because i'm trying to be
neutral as to whose evidence shows shows
what
but you know the 106 would operate in
the same way for example if the
council had produced a financial
viability appraisal of the scheme that
showed that it could sustain 30
affordable housing
you would just then have to choose
between
the two legally the operation would be
the same the regulation one two two
tests would be the same and
in my
my submission is that the difficulties
that are perhaps running through your
mind are more evidential difficulties
than than legal difficulties
okay
thank you both that's that's helpful uh
clarification i think it's worth sort of
uh
raising the point uh
in terms of how that would all work
going forward but uh yeah the next stage
is for me to actually consider all the
evidence in detail after the inquiry so
uh okay thank you both for that
and that's where we can't help you i'm
afraid
well you've both been very helpful so
far
that's all i can expect of you thank you
okay mrs goddard thank you sir um we've
got as far as ten years split in the eu
section of the
summary and that's 80 affordable rented
and 20
shared ownership
and there's an affordable housing target
mix that is defined with ranges of
percentages for one bed two bed three
bed and four plus bed
and that mix also includes nine
wheelchair accessible units
and the affordable housing schedule has
to be submitted and approved before
commencement
and it may be revised under paragraph
two of that same schedule
the housing has to meet nationally
described space standards
an offer has to be submitted
to a registered provider before
commencement
and the transfer of the land or units
has to be
made to a registered provider or the
council at 25 occupation of market units
and there's a restriction of market unit
occupation to 40
until 50 percent of the affordable units
have been practically completed
and a restriction of market occupation
to 75
until all the affordable housing units
have been practically completed
and there's a requirement for the
affordable housing to be used as such
and the council have the opportunity to
nominate
under a nominations agreement which is a
requirement
and there's a viability review which is
part two of that third schedule
and an additional off-site contribution
would be payable in the event that the
surplus is identified in the viability
review further appraisal
and moving on to open space and play
area
that is schedule form we're back to the
agreement now sir
um right okay let me uh
you're popping about a bit
yeah
okay which parts are we in now we're in
schedule four
yeah okay
um so the time for approval of the
scheme is before commencement
the trigger for its delivery is 60
occupation of market units and that's on
a per phase basis
and
can be transferred to a management
company after the issue of the final
certificate and it includes leaps and
laps in accordance with the planning
permission
and then what i've
described as other obligations
and firstly the link road and this may
be provided by the county council and
this is where we had to be
flexible in in terms of the drafting so
the county council would provide it if
they get the highway external funding
and if they do the county top-up
contribution will be paid
and then the details for the provision
of the link road are in the
infrastructure delivery plan that's
quite a detailed um definition which
shows how matters are going to be
addressed in that plan
and then the various obligations of
county council council and owner are
covered by those paragraphs that i've
identified in the various schedules
then there is the schottendame road
safeguarded land
and that's identified on a plan um
and it's to be safeguarded for 15 years
or until the county council say they
don't need it if that's if that happens
to be earlier
and then
the plan is the time we were talking
about earlier on
um it's the link road plan which which
serves two purposes
so
it um it assists with the
link road
and it also assists with the shot and
down road safeguarded land
yeah so it's the blue sort of triangular
area at the bottom which is hatched red
which is the safeguarded land
area
yeah
i see
okay just on the plans one question that
just struck me looking at the plan
against the site location plan so
location plan
has got the red edge around the two
compartments for the size and it's not
actually
as one it's two separate compartments
and the red edge
obviously the road is not within the red
edge site
that's to reflect ownership so yes
because
the revised
road scheme sort of obviously sort of
curves just sort of to the north
west of the
how in terms of how it all fits in with
the master plan are there any issues
with the fact that the red edge doesn't
include the road but on that road where
that road is
will be presumably
some development showing under the
uh well in accordance with the master
plan albeit you know albeit we're an
outline
outline stage with detailed matters to
to come
can i defer to mr ball yeah i was going
to say
rather than yourself in that regard but
you see my point is that you've got this
yes the red edge doesn't cover the
middle side but middle of the side
because the road changes its alignment
what it is at the moment it means it
will be something in in a couple of
areas where the king could be like
but that's not the red edge how does
that actually work out
so i think it
it links back to the point that um
in simple terms you can apply for
planning permission on anyone's land
providing you have their permission to
do so that's highways land that runs
through the centre of the site
um
so
you would have to serve notice on the
highway authority
um
[Music]
and the realigned road then be brought
forward in adoptable standards in
accordance with conversation with the
highway authority
i was also thinking about the bit where
which is
it's shown it's shown actually on the
link road plan
the bit where
which is no longer going to be
uh shot and dane road it's going to be
because the road's going to be curved
away a little bit to the to the north in
that area on the master plan there's
sort of dwelling show confronting that
or certainly sort of the frontages of
dwellings
but that's not actually within the red
edge of the application site
the well the red edge of the application
site i think covers all
all
for the for the planning application the
location plan covers the entire
um area
oh does it okay sorry i've been this is
maybe a red herring then because i'm
looking at the
location plan submitted with the 106 and
the two red edges
so the actual location plan of the
application
is different is it
yes include shot and main road
right
okay i'm just trying to
find the relevant core document
reference
cd102 yep cd102
ah i see yeah sorry i was just looking
at that plan thinking that was the
actual
yeah
the same as the uh the site location
plan with the application
okay
and the green and yellow section of the
plan that would apply if calcium doing
the work
and there's no implications for the in
terms of the 106 agreement
that the red edges
as it's shown
on the plan accompanying the 106
agreement
well um we are binding
the ownership and the gap in between is
highway land um i would say that the
infrastructure delivery plan is most
likely where that would
be mocked up because parties have to
work together to produce that
to say who's building what and when
okay
thank you
so yeah i interrupted so again i forget
where you're now
um i just spoken about the shot and dane
road safeguarded land um so i think i
think that matters being dealt with and
then there's a comment in the summary um
to explain that there's flexibility for
the county council to agree
changes to the footprint of the link
road and shot and down road safeguarded
land and i've had identified the
paragraphs where that flexibility comes
in
and
highway works the owner has to enter
into section 38 agreements that's in
relation to other estate roads
other than the link road
and there's the usual
release clause which is 7.3
payment of lpa and county council costs
and
my clients give an indemnity to the
owner which is standard
thank you
and
as i understand it from the emails i've
seen this morning
kent county council have confirmed
that they are
happy with everything that's being
drafted
yes sir they've they've seen the clean
copy that you have and nagla stevens who
is the principal solicitor for invicta
law who are the up the legal arm of ken
county council she has confirmed that
she's happy with that draft
okay and similarly mr livingstone from
on behalf of the council the council is
now in is everything effectively being
agreed obviously it's not been the 106
agreements will be signed as yet but is
it is there anything are there any
loose ends
between the parties
at all with regards to the 106 uh know
that as as stated mrs gotta start that
the the draft of our previous
agreement's been used to start then
we've
we've gone through all the different
clauses on that
for the 106 yeah thank you
okay
um right let me just check my is that
everything you have to say mrs
yes thank you sir okay thank you that
was a helpful uh run through
the
obligations thank you
okay one
question that i
had probably for you mr got mrs goddard
uh on the 106
uh infrastructure delivery
plan
i think it's the definition
of it
yes that's page
six
thank you
yes the infrastructure delivery plan
definition a b c d
and e and the bit which follows says and
for the avoidance of doubt where any
provisions of the approved
infrastructure delivery plan conflict
with conditions of the planning
commission
the approved infrastructure delivery
plan
shall prevail
how does that work in terms of the
actual
planning conditions because
it almost sounds as though that would
actually override
planning
so this one this was something that i i
queried with um
the
council solicited to the lpa solicitor
because
this was a suggestion made by kent
county council because obviously you'll
identified that they are looking for
maximum flexibility
and to suit their funding and link road
arrangements
um and there was concern that
some conditions might conflict and so i
understand that mr livingstone has um
approved this particular for the
avoidance of doubt provision by his
solicitor and so that's why
it's remained in the in the draft
okay
mr livingstone johnson
thank you um
so this is where the
the highway authority wanted the sort of
inclusion of the the plan to come in via
a plan to come in via the legal
agreement
obviously one of the things that we were
doing within the discussions about the
planning application and we've gone
through the condition submission already
was working with the highway authority
on the highway works plan which we
talked about uh and and
effectively the idea is that they are
supposed to be one and the same they are
supposed to be the same thing obviously
we wouldn't agree something with the
highway authority in the whole authority
wouldn't sign off if it's something
subsequently that's going to be
different
um so
in the instance of
you know wanting i think this is a
clause that was put forward um because i
think the county awarded it to be very
clear about the potential for any
dispute at all but from the local
authorities perspective it will simply
not be a dispute because we are working
with
kcc
in every way
to make sure that what they want for the
highway as the highway authority is
delivered
yeah okay
so in a way it's not something that i
need to particularly worry about it's
more about the implementation which
between you and the highway authority uh
i'm sure can be sorted out yes okay
okay thank
you those were my
questions and queries that
i had which i think we've now yeah we've
gone through all those now as we've been
going along so thank you for
for that
so is there anything well obviously the
matter of uh
when
i can expect the final
obligations to be
signed wants to be provided
um well in terms of our landowner um we
have one single land owner
um
i might need some input from um mr
livingston on on
council procedure in terms of
uh and time frames
for the legal agreements
uh
thank you sir for the for the council
this is something that you know within a
on a technical on a procedural note this
is done on a wednesday um intense
ceiling um of the 106. um so you know it
can be arranged within a a certain time
frame it depends obviously it's got to
go to kcc i you know they aren't they
aren't here
um
so
you know our time frame is sort of
within a week of receipt we would have
it back turned around
um maybe even earlier if it came on a
monday and we can arrange it for when
win
yes sir um you may have noticed that
there is provision that's been left in
the agreement
for counterparts
ceiling and signing
i'm taking it that the both the county
council and the lpa are happy to deal
with counterparts because that that
provision has been left in so it could
shorten the time um
to to have
you know if you have counterparts it's
only one signature
per document um but you would have a
whole pile of documents at the end of
the day that will form the agreement um
but it it might help if we were very
short of time
it's funny because counterparts didn't
used to be sort of generally encouraged
but counterparts have become a thing of
the last couple of years haven't they
yeah so it seems
well it's helped with the coronavirus
issue hasn't it
uh
so
if it wasn't for counterparts when would
a one of when would agreements be able
to be provided to me
the quickest they could be provided in
terms of me setting a deadline
i think so we're looking at a fortnight
okay
um
and it def everything could definitely
be done i mean the fortnight is probably
the far end of my sort of
expectations i was going to say a week
but if it's going to take that long to
get them then
as a
so you'd be saying two weeks today
yes sir
okay
um
okay that seems that seems fine i think
that probably works within my overall
timetable for decision writing um
that's on the basis that there's what
we've what i've got in front of me now
is there's no
further changes of any significance
whatsoever because obviously it will
work and that's when the sort of
problems start
if i can sort of work with what i've got
here in terms of decision writing etc my
considerations and that that's helpful
to me to know that there's not going to
be any significant sort of changes to
that
okay okay so we'll say
two weeks today whatever that today
whatever that date is the 28th
okay
good any
final comments that anyone has to make
on the plumbing obligations
no
good okay thank you mrs gonna that's
helpful thank you
right
uh
we're now at the
closing submissions
stage uh what time are we on three
o'clock um
so in terms of order
it's going to be uh
council first
rule six
followed by the
appellant
uh mr upton are you ready to do it now
or do you want to have a
actually give me some short five minute
break anyway from my perspective what am
i getting another
yes i was gonna
i've seen mr
has a comment as well i was gonna ask
for a little bit longer okay
i embarked on reordering some paragraphs
which is right well that that's
that's okay i can accommodate that just
so we're gonna be
we're going to be going till
about
inevitably we're going to be sort of
five five past five
i think which is as absolutely as late
as i want to go but i think what it does
mean is that i'm increasingly getting
attracted to your suggestion mr ups and
about on the costs that
if we can deal with that for the most
part
in writing
mr williams is in agreement
yeah obviously depending what he wants
to say but i would certainly mean that
you would have a
considered response i think this really
is intended to do something in writing
and therefore we could give you a
considerable response and heal so you
can reply to that
um rather than
meeting instructions or otherwise or
having just two
pause we can i think i've certainly had
it work we have a fairly tight timetable
it would need to be a tight timetable i
think for costs definitely mr williams
what's your view on
so yes i do i certainly don't
want my friend or yourself to be in a
position where
at half five on a
friday people are scrambling around
trying to get a response together um
that's fine i've prepared
my submission i can submit it this
afternoon anyway um
the reason i raised and i'll leave that
with you the reason i raised my hand um
and i don't want any sense to be
crying um but i would quite like to
submit i would quite like you to have my
closing in writing
um
when i read it out and
because i know that has to go through
mrs dutton
um if miss doesn't what i normally do is
i sit and i tinker with it while
um the other advocates are
[Music]
making their closings but i'd be happy
not to do that and send it in and make
oral additions if that meant that you'd
definitely have it
yeah
i understand um
let me just do a bit of uh
like i'm not trying to pry perhaps you
can just let me know
later this afternoon exactly the
deadline and i'll make sure i've emailed
it in by then yeah i'm just gonna
well let's have a break now because in
that break i can find out the
information that i need to find out in
terms of how long my email uh link's
gonna be either with mr
uh yeah and uh
yeah obviously yeah if we can't then we
can't but let me do that during the
break so how long do you send it
immediately and and i'll make all
editions great okay yeah okay well i
know that she's uh sort of here now in
terms of the little green dots that we
now get showing who's working and who's
not so
so that's looking promising okay so
leave that with me during the break and
i'll let i'll know to expect that so
that can be sent as soon as possible
then yeah that's good
mr upton so how long
will quarter past three so 13 minutes
break is that going to be sufficient or
um i was going to say if perhaps we're
starting to look at two emails in about
10 minutes time i'll then have something
that sees
not too much of a rough draft um and uh
so maybe we should have a slightly
longer break just so that allows that
leeway but
um
so if you're sort of talking about 18
minutes sort of things
okay so we will
okay that's that's fine so i want to
make sure obviously i've said before the
closing submission is obviously the
important documents so
uh and you obviously need time to
consider and get them all into the right
sort of shape i appreciate that the way
this sort of time is gone today so we'll
adjourn and we'll come back at 20 past
three
thank you thank you so much thank you
[Music]
bye
right it is
20 past three so time to
reconvene
uh
in terms of emailing
dutton informs me that she's in the
office
until about 4 4 30.
so
we've got her till 4 o'clock
uh in order to send
yeah things between us
that's great thank you very much
thank you what's one of the hindrances
of virtual work
so
mr upton there's nothing come through
yet via email from yourself i suspect
that's because you're not
you're on news mr upset
did quite well but there we are day four
your first time i think yeah so yes um i
hope it's got through mr williams is one
way of checking that it's gone out
and i was gonna ask mr in livingston to
forward it to um mr hand as well because
i don't think i had the immediate email
so
i can go through
that you can have a copy
um
just
[Music]
so i yeah i'd get a rough feel it's a
it's about 17 pages which hopefully
means that my time estimate is going to
be about right but
um i'm hoping it'll get through because
obviously i've got some uh references in
it or some quotes that i could almost
take as read if you've got a copy of it
yeah
um whereas otherwise i'd probably have
to read it out um
but that was that was my ambition but um
uh i'm as i said i'm hoping it's got
through
to mr han now as well but um
i can but hope um
[Music]
did you send
repetition and things um let me just uh
send her a very quick email
um
but we are talking about sort of five
minutes ago so i'm sorry that it's
right i'll just wait for her response
and hopefully that will come straight
back
while we do i think we've actually
talked about the site visit so to avoid
having to talk about the site visit
again at the end i've just received i
think in the last half an hour ago the
plan that's been referred to
and
uh thank you for that so i'm happy to
work on the basis of that
on tuesday obviously there's any other
things i feel i want to see having
thought about all the evidence and
what's been discussed then i can add
that in as well but thank you for that
and in terms of the parties
uh is it is it clear enough it's fine
yeah it's fine it's probably similar to
the one similar to my dream myself two
weeks ago i think so i'm working very
well at the moment so
i'll try and scan something a bit better
when i'm back in the office on monday
morning yeah that'll be fine and send it
forward i think something better with me
for the walk on there
on tuesday
and we'll meet at 11 30 where shall we
meet what's the uh starting point well
the starting point was going to go by
one of the uh the cemetery gates right
that's been picked up as one of the
heritage assets on there so it's a good
it's a good place as any to start the
war
and to do the circuit to the site and
then picking the other points that
we're all six parties have asked to be
included as well so thank you
it's a central point as any okay
excellent and
mr dickman you'll have had a copy of
that i assume
and i have sir i know the area very well
it may or may not be me but we'll ensure
that we have a representative there to
go around with you excellent i think
councillor farron's i can't see her on
the screen in front of me but maybe
no but she has expressed an interest um
and certainly to the local residents
either of all are happy to do it so
you'll say okay
uh council of france there you are are
you okay with 11 30 at the cemetery
gates on tuesday for
yes our
am yes that's fine thank you very much
excellent thank you for confirming that
right uh so that is the site as far as
i'm concerned description of the site
visit
out of the way and that served a purpose
because i've now received an email from
the office which is
excellent yes it's come through i've got
the i've got the closest missions in
front of me so
i'm glad um
um
to say i there are certain bits where i
think i can literally say
this is what's set out with actually
having to sort of read it act
uh which obviously will help but
i'm
pleasingly happy to start so that um
so i have to some introductory points
that
obviously the appeal site is a strategic
housing allocation in a recently adopted
local plan
uh that should make an important
contribution to meeting local housing
needs in the district
it is of course that is a
straightforward statement to make but
it's successful achievement indeed a
matter of planning judgment
and you've had a fair representation of
the planning committee's decision which
was supported by mr hester from his
perspective as an experienced and
independent planning consultant
essentially why that's not been achieved
you will need to clearly consider the
other objections that have been strongly
made regarding matters such as flooding
and drainage and biodiversity but from
our perspective we have concentrated on
three reasons for refusal
and just dealing with two of them we've
been able to deal with two
that deal with the legal agreement and
so we can now say
that there is a legal agreement awaiting
signature that will secure the delivery
of the necessary infrastructure required
to support the development if one leaves
aside this issue about affordable
housing
and
also that there is mitigation that can
be secured in that agreement against the
likely impact of any increased
recreational pressures pressures on the
protected habitats on the fanuc coast
uh stpa and ramsar's site
um this course then leaves the issue
between the council and the opponent
about the inadequate provision of
forward housing as part of the dwelling
mix which would not meet the identified
need for affordable housing in the
district and that remains a very
important planning consideration
so then i just wanted to touch on this
offer over 30
in the unilateral um
we obviously have had a discussion at
the session already but what i just
wanted to note in closing it's clearly
now a provision of the planning
obligation on offer in the unilateral
that it could require 30 provision
you will need to consider its
effectiveness and check it for
reasonableness and ambiguity as as and
also as a policy
on the appellants case of course there
is not evidence to support that of 30
or mr hester's approach as you heard it
should be recorded that 30 is still
expected on the site
and that there has been a failure to
demonstrate that a lower provision
should be allowed and that would be a
basis by which 30 could be uh justified
but of course the submissions i now need
to make deal with how uh
that
point about affordable housing
uh should be dealt with with regard to
reasons one and two
um
can i then deal first of all with the
development plan uh because there is
this point about the mppf and i did
foreshadow this with um
mr ball but
i have to say there's a bit of an
element of a classic encounter when the
questioning was of mr hester uh by my
land friends
of the classic encounter between the
lawyer and the planner and i say i hope
we can get some clarity
um questions were asked of ms tesla
about why he'd not address section 386
and his proof and of course as he
explained his proof has been written in
the context of the statements of common
ground and he adopted what was said in
them and is then focused in his written
proof on the areas of contention he
didn't seek to repeat what was in them
and of course that's a recommended way
of keeping proof shorter
and of course still remains the case
that section 386 remains the starting
point and that's set out in the general
statement of common ground i've just
quoted there where it refers to it and i
didn't need to read that out
therefore we get to the situation where
the mppf is one of the material
considerations to take into account
which may indicate that decisions are
made otherwise in accordance with the
development plan
and we know that of course the policy
provisions regarding housing have had a
significant effect on how one considers
those policies because as again set out
to the general statement of common
ground uh this is a situation uh where
there is no five years land supply that
we can point to
and where the housing delivery test is
not met
which means that the relevant local plan
policies for the supply of housing and
indeed others important are out of date
and in those circumstances agreed that
paragraph 11d applies that's the point
about the tilted balance i'm not going
to read out the whole paragraph
but in effect the local policies for the
supply of housing and the other policies
which are most important for determining
application are out of date
for the purposes of mppf
and of course there is apparently a
linguistic conundrum in which we um
sorry to say
there's some excess wordy in there
um
so you i think you just put a line
through which we mean and what i want to
say is apparently linguistic conundrum
when we say a development policy is out
of date
the answer lies in treating the mppf as
a special policy point
and
the
situation arises that policies can be
out of date for the purposes of footnote
8 and paragraph 11 of the mppf
but also not out of date in the sense
used in common and ordinary language
of course in terms therefore the mppf
itself
the way in which it it
approaches this
is clear
if those policies are out of date for
the purposes of the mpvf they cannot
then be up to date
we can no longer apply the policy's
development plan in the way envisaged by
paragraph 11c of the mppf and approved
development proposals quote unquote that
are called with an up-to-date
development plan without delay
the reference to all in paragraph 11
between paragraphs subparagraph c and d
is clear
and so in my submission you cannot apply
both paragraph 11c and paragraph 11d at
the same time
what has become known as the tilted
balance set out in paragraph 11d applies
to this case as a whole
uh it's also just worth in noting a
point about um the mppf because the
latest version we have is july 2001
which is after the date of the
decision so it is once again it hasn't
really been a matter of contention that
there hasn't been anything in the later
versions that's material to the policies
that you need to consider that might
change their relevance
um indeed
in terms of those policies it's a matter
of their substance not the timing
and there's a point that the mppf has
been careful to address about this that
none of any relevant existing policies
should be considered out of date simply
because they were adopted or made prior
to the publication of the framework due
weights should still be given to them
according to degree of consistency so
simply the point about date isn't
determinative and again it's not an
issue here
but the council i would say has been
consistent in the way it's approached
the planning framework
in the light of paragraph 11d and of
course it's the way the officers
themselves approached it as well and
that's remained the case since
so actually whilst we take issue with
the way mr bald has advanced the first
part of his case about 11c
we are agreed with the second part of
his case that this is a matter that will
be determined in the light of the tilted
balance which is the 11d point
uh and of course the narcissistic
crosses examination mr hester was keen
to refer to the way in which their open
plan policies were still not out of date
in terms of their substance of course
they've been recently found to be sound
and in the light of the mppf and all the
policies and that was the case when the
plan was adopted in july of 2020
so in terms of their recent vintage and
their conformity with the national
planning policy framework they're still
up to date in that substance and should
carry considerable weight in the
planning balance and essentially matter
that mr ball accepted and it isn't
really in dispute
now of course the other point is that
we can
read and see that the officer's view was
the application was in in accordance in
their view of the development plan even
given the point that the most important
policies have to be treated as being out
of date
the planning committee did not agree
with that point when it came to
affordable housing and of course the
reason for refusal refers to the
strategy policy for housing and to the
nppf
and that has other consequences as
explained by mr hester when it comes to
considering the degree to which this
appeals scheme would comply with
policies such as sb 21 22 and 23.
and i know the word questions often
about how the reasons for refusal are
framed but clearly there is no doubt
that throughout this inquiry what the
issues are have been uh regarding
affordable housing that need to be
considered
so having established the
decision-making framework needs to be
used that has turned to the substance
which causes what all the planners
especially spending their time on
can i deal firstly with the affordable
housing
policy uh
did just want to note
that
though it's one of the ones that is out
of date of course it is one that was
adopted in the light of the policies in
the mppf
uh which haven't materially changed and
i just wanted to pick out some points
sort of mentioned earlier
that are still important
that strategic policy should set our
street an overall strategy for the
patent scale and design equality of
places and make sufficient provision for
housing including affordable housing
the plans themselves should set out the
country isn't expected from development
and that should include setting other
levels of types of full housing
provision required along of course with
other infrastructure
and shouldn't undermine the
deliverability of the plan of course
that's something that's been assessed
and where a need for affordable housing
is identified playing boss you should
specify the type of folder housing
required and expect it to be met on site
remains an important point and again our
plan
covers that
of course one matter that's not relied
upon as we heard is the reference to
major development providing 10
and so i don't need to say any more on
that because in a sense we're beyond
that even on the figures we're looking
at here
but i do want to just mention that at
the local planned stage it was accepted
that the 30
policy requirement was a proportionate
one
but his application would still lead to
a shortfall on the identified need of
the district and that's something the
local plan inspectors state in their
report
it's always going to be the case that
remains important to make full use of
the sites such as this one that's shot
and day
and again as a slightly separate point
is worth noting that the case has been
advanced on the basis that the under
provision has been justified by the
viability evidence
we're not faced with a case that's been
advanced on the basis that the provision
is itself outweighed by other factors so
we don't need to look at that point
there is also a review clause in section
but that doesn't absolve us at this
stage of the decision-making presence in
determining what level of that provision
uh should be
um
and in a way there is a specific
justification for the review clause
which is that there may be funding
coming forward for the major road
so that money does need to be provided
for um
and wouldn't need to be provided by the
developer
and it could be put to other users so
that's really why the review clause is
in there and though there is i know a
further review clause that deals with
later stages of development no one's
really placed much weight upon that i
think that's right
um
because that review course of course was
it's helpful
it does lead to off-site provision
um in a sense he's only trying to
correct things after the event and we're
all focusing on
what should be approved now
um
that's all i need to say on the on that
policy point
can i then deal with the site allocation
policy um
of course the starting point
is the site is it's agreed that the site
is capable of being developed for
housing
and that's reflected in the state of
common ground that residential
development on the site is acceptable in
principle
because of the local plan
but there are a series of consequences
if the appeal scheme fails to satisfy
the housing strategy to provide
sufficient affordable housing
as one of the relevant questions is
whether this is the only reasonable way
to deliver housing on the site and of
course this is where the issue
of whether there are other possible
schemes arises and whether this scheme
we say
um i suppose the question whether it
does or does not optimize development
opportunity on the site
there's a crossover of course there's a
viability point but there's also a
planning point
and
it appears that
we've heard the opponent does not accept
that there are other schemes that could
come forward on the site during the
planned period
i just want to address that because it
cannot be said
but i'm sure it will be said that the
scheme delivers the site allocation set
out in the policy
on the logic that we heard the wording
of the policy about up to certain number
of houses and the minimum amount of open
space
would mean that a scheme of 700 houses
and 15 hectares of open space would meet
the policy as well though
policy wedding should be read in the
light of the development plan as a whole
and the way in which the policy sp21 and
the sporting policies expect the site to
be developed
and it comes back to that the reason
that this greenfield site was released
for
development was the subject of
discussion the recent local plan and it
was originally promoted for 550 up to
under 550 units
and it was the provision of that number
and a significant um sorry it should say
contribution
not alteration um
to the transfer infrastructure which led
to the release of the greenfield land
being justified
this site this sorry this scheme i
should say
falls short
of that
and it is not there for an accordance
with the policy now that doesn't prevent
its
approval but it does reduce the support
it has from policy sb21
and because we have accepted that
development in the form outlined the
parameter plan can be allowed
but it's worth acknowledging the scope
that this allocated site does offer
more land in this scheme is being used
for open space that was anticipated in
sb21
this particular scheme provides a
greater level of publication space for
only 450 houses
than what the policy advise for the 550
houses that's what the 4x4 hectares was
relevant and there's a matter of mass
obviously would be less and i put it in
the footnate pure as a matter of mass
would be 3.6 hectares if it's 450 houses
like for like
of course we've been offered i think
it's now 5.22 or probably you want to
consider it 6.1 in terms of the
flexibility
um
we heard that
as we said in the local plan um
that this need to look at the egg how
much grief of land is to be used
um
wasn't really considered
and i say that does lessen support given
by the plan to the impact of developing
a 450 unit proposal on on the
countryside using the full site
and as we heard the local plan
inspectors supported the inclusion of
the minimum amount of open space as
being necessary to achieve a high
quality development and
um
the reason for including that and the
reason to say it is that the pressure
would otherwise be if it hadn't had that
wording that people would provide less
open space on the site and if that's the
way it is phrased in the ways that it
is it's also possible just a short point
uh to change the densities involved and
it's noticeable the playing officers
identified that what we have before us
has a density of 23 drillings per
hectare
and that's in the report now um as for
changing the density
we know that's actually happened here
when the safeguarded land for the road
was identified of 0.38 hectares we
didn't lose
um housing
didn't lead to reduction numbers instead
of which
it was moved around the site so that was
a very obvious demonstration that what
was referred to as thickening up
is possible
and reasonable to expect on a site such
as this and as mrs hester also mentioned
there is scope within a site such as
this and its topography to allow for
greater use of two and three-story
buildings
so that effects be is there
we say therefore we don't have an
optimum scheme before us or the only
scheme
but what do we have can i just make this
point and i'm sure it's been flagged but
how we should compare the outline
permission
and the scheme assessed by the viability
assessment
um because
as you've heard we have a situation
where the scheme assessed by the
viability work is not the scheme that
could be properly considered at the
reserve matter stage
indeed we now have an agreed condition
covering minimum standards the qdo4
point and we have a reference to an
affordable housing mix to be considered
in the unilateral
which isn't what was in the viability
work
and so this divide between the planning
commission and the viability work is
important to identify i would say the
point could be put fairly simply even
though we obviously spent a little bit
longer on it at the inquiry
this is an application for 450 houses or
up to 450 where almost all matters are
left open to be approved at the reserve
matters stage
and indeed those approvals may be done
in phases
as a result the
mix and size and topology of the houses
and characters even the number of
characters is still to be determined
and any apparent errors at this stage
can be cured at that stage so the
resulting scheme can still be considered
so that it complies with the terms the
development plan policies
and there are no material considerations
that suggest that those policies will
not be applied in that way at that stage
now in comparison
the link between what can happen on the
outline permission and the viability
scheme is weak
now we heard where it came from i would
say the weakness
in the viability lies in the assumptions
that were given to the
valuers team
because i would say that uh
a proper
viability assessment should look for the
optimal value especially when dealing
with the nightline permission
and yet the sequence of events is clear
that the accommodation schedule we have
as an appendix to the report was given
to mr cordrey
even though
this was time when the parameter plan
was available
he relied on the schedule he wasn't
looking at the parameter plan
he made no moves to check the difference
between what he'd been given and and
what might be permissible
and so we don't have any buildings in
his schedule above two and a half
stories
and those that are even at two and a
half stories a limited number to 76 and
the rest are two three
and indeed there's no distinction
between what's private or affordable in
this mix
um
we also heard that mr ball saw that
accommodation schedule but didn't seek
to make it comply with planning policy
i'd say
one could say that the schedule is
indeed planner blind
and but
it does mean that that's what they were
looking at
um and when it comes to what dixon
searle looked at it's worth noting when
they were looking at that work they were
looking at the um
the values and the figures and the costs
and not of these planning assumptions
and furthermore they weren't asked to
comment further on the 2021 work
by which states council rely upon the
work from james lange myself for that
uh and again
when mr hester asked dixon cell to do a
further work um it's fair for them to
start with uh looking at the glabin mix
as a reasonable comparison point but of
course that was the first thing they
looked at before going on to look at the
other scenarios
um
the other point just to mention about
the comparison between the outline
permission and the scheme that was
assessed in terms of viability
is about
the housing mix and the minimum sizes
policy sp 22 and qdo4
because of course any yields regarding
the proposed mix or sizes can be cured
as a matter of planning at the reserve
matter stage
but what has been assessed in the form
of financial viability assessment
doesn't pay respect to this um i should
say these policies plural
it has assessed what i would call an
undeliverable mix and that clearly gets
the weight to be attached to the
assessment that's been done
but if
it was to be said that the policy
compliance scheme was assessed or
was assessed enough
we would say there's still been a
failure to meet uh these policies
uh and we can see that
that the planning condition that we are
now discussing and has been agreed would
require compliance with the minimum
described space standards
and that has different dwelling sizes
between number of people
uh and what might come forward in terms
of what a
formal housing provider would want to
look for would expect to meet those
standards in any event as mr hester
mentioned
um so i just wanted to add one further
comment about this part about the
housing mix and how it was approached in
the viability assessment
uh that
we have some limited evidence mr
cordrey's alternative mixer he set out
in his proof
where he did look at the analysis of
changing the mix of affordable housing
and that gave a greater net income for
that mix
and his unit numbers it turns out uh
slightly greater in terms of two bedroom
terraces as well for the market housing
sort of in 67 it becomes 88 and of
course that can increase some of the
value as well
but that's as far as it goes um
if we'd had a proper mix of housing that
would have included some one-bedroom
houses on the market housing side as
well
mr caldery has not done that
i have to say of course it did get a
little confused when i was asking
questions of him but it's a simple way
that one can check what he had done in
table eight is to see whether it
includes any one bedroom dwellings of
course it doesn't
uh whereas of course they are
part of the mix that would be expected
for market housing as identified in the
local plan
and actually when you read his text that
supports the work he's done in his proof
more closely
he's actually describing a different
exercise he did he was enlarging the
sizes the two three and four bedroom
houses only
so it's still the case
that there is um
not before the inquiry an assessment by
him of the mix or type of market housing
that would be expected
uh under the policy
um
in his proof
can't turn to the viability evidence
um firstly some policy points that
if one looks to ppg we are slightly
handicapped because the the way it's
written
very much deals with viability being
done at the plan making level and we're
slightly in that transition in this case
um but the focus of course of national
policy when you read it is very much
of what should happen when looking at
plan making viability
and it seems that decision making itself
will also be done in that context
but some general points arise that
viability is a tool to ensure that
planning policies are realistic and do
not undermine the deliverability of a
plan
and they should not compromise
sustainable development and the
proposals for development assessed at
the plan making stage are intended to be
policy compliant
and that in those considerations well in
my submission fully through to what's
expected at the decision making stage
and i've picked out some other points in
the ppg about the expectations about uh
costs that you would make
about the landowner selling land for
development will allow sufficient
contribution that's built in hopefully
to the um benchmark land value
and that all of this should be based on
evidence
which where developments are fully
compliant with emerging or up-to-date
planning policies
um
we
also know that we're looking for an
applicant blind test was the phrase used
quite useful one
a in policy
in
that normally the residual land value
should match the benchmark land value
when identifying the level of possible
contributions or affordable housing
and one way of assessing benchmark land
value is to use existing use value plus
and that's what's happened here
but i do say that that's not the end of
the matter um account can also be taken
of site specific evidence about what a
reasonable landowner would do
we of course know that gladman's are
experienced planners and site promoters
and we have landon here who has had
access to professional advice both from
them and from others
so what they accept is good evidence of
what a reasonable landowner is prepared
to accept and that becomes relevant to a
later point
but can i then deal with this point by
the wait
um because we did have it confirmed and
i just want to deal with the way the
policy looks at it but we had to confirm
mr ball that
he's not looking at a financial
assessment that's policy compliant but
he'd say one that was given driven by
market considerations but
how should we consider a viability
assessment that's not policy compliant
and not looking at a scheme that is
policy can plan
and as the national policy says the way
to be given to viability assessment is a
matter for the decision maker having
regard to all circumstances in the case
and those will include
i would say whether the plan and the
viability evidence underpinning it is up
to date
and the guidance itself refers back to
the vibrancy assessment that informs the
local plan so it links back to that and
the expectation that a policy compliance
scheme was promoted in the plan and
assessed at the decision-making stage
and i would say that is further
discussed both in the ppg
uh and in the um our ics guidance that
uh discusses this point that's in just
taking the point in paragraph 10
of the playing practice guidance that
it defines the divided process as
looking at whether the value generated
by development is more than the cost of
developing it
and that includes looking at key
elements across value costs
land value landowner premium developer
return
and when one looks at the rocs guidance
and its general discussion one of the
points it does make before going on to
talk about potential variations
is that a financial viability assessment
should determine whether developments
are capable of providing levels of
developer contributions that comply with
policy unless that's the point i'm
seeking to emphasize
uh and that's that's really the starting
point and what's the expectation is and
as he goes on to say more specifically
a financial viability assessment
estimates whether planned developments
with policy compliant levels development
contributions are able to provide a
minimal reasonable return to the
landowner and the chm returned to the
developer
so it is tied in
um
now as i understand it it's still being
said by mr bull that what's been
assessed here should have full weight
whereas if that's the case as mr
disappointed that then
that weight needs to actually be judged
in light of the fact that it's contrary
to the policies and we say clearly
diminishes its weight
and one can see how i was described in
the report committee i just quoted there
from that july report which talks about
this issue about um
uh i'm halfway through see what's the
proposal will not be contrary to
positively taken as a whole
if members consider there is substantial
harm created by not providing 30
affordable housing on this site
due to the specific housing need and
acute affordability issues
then this may outweigh
both the variety evidence and clear
benefits from the scheme
um and in that consideration was also
the point about the way to attach to the
viability evidence
so a very important thing that needs to
be identified and this is one of those
cases well that's really been an issue
because i do
i set out in the description
that will be further refined at the
reserve matter stage
and at that stage there'll be no reason
to depart from the policy requirements
and that will they'll also be well
that's aged input from a
housing provider for affordable housing
reference on sizes
and um to any developer will be able to
make optimum use of the parameters plan
[Music]
but we don't have
a financial viability assessment
of that situation
and we shouldn't have to wait for any
review or
further work for that to be done
we need a financial viability assessment
that's fit for purpose
to satisfy the policy requirement sp 23
for the ease for any applicant to
demonstrate why the provision of 30
would make a scheme unviable
and that as it says the requirements
will only be reduced if meeting them
would demonstrably make the proposed
development unviable
now as we've said
the viable assessment does not test or
take into account alternative
assumptions around the number mixer
sizes ten-year-old types of homes that
could provide on-site
and it doesn't test a performancy
compliant proposal it's only looked at
the viability of the 450 homes put
forward with mix and type set
in that schedule set by the appellate
um try and deal with i suppose power
then looks at this residual land value
point that's arisen because
we
had
slightly somewhat unexplained by mr ball
uh policy position regarding the lower
residual land value being put forward in
june 2020 and repeated in june 2021
and as one sees from that 2021 letter
that
was the update
that they calculated as 15
being offered um could be done so whilst
maintaining a similar residual landfill
and that's how the 68 units is provided
now using that similar residual land
value i understand it was a matter of
some criticism we heard it from mr
calderon mr ball
who seem to be accepting that the
residual land value should equal the
benchmark land value uh in the sort of
applicant blind assessment promoted by
policy um sorry that became blind not
bind by the way
um
but of course mr ball was almost enough
in answering questions to say that that
was irrelevant to
his
own firm and to the landowner
but there is a relevance to it
the logical conclusion is that a lower
developer's profit is anticipated
and as dixon cell have shown
doing that still means it remains within
the 15 to 20 range and i'd say that's
how the matter should continue to be
assessed because we're not saying
that we should move away from the advice
in the ppg to look at the comparison
between the residual land value and
benchmark land view that's other than
something that equates to each other
and we can look at the site specifics
and this site has been promoted on a
lower part of that range
and the evidence is that the promoter is
prepared to accept a lower premium or
incentive to bring the site forward
notwithstanding the identification of
the applicant blind benchmark landvae
it's also a reason for
not looking at the samsung grange
situation the nearby permission because
it isn't comparable not only because of
this residual land value point but but
also that it had a policy compliant
viability assessment
and offered a choice between 30
and 18
uh on a much smaller site of 250
units and
since we i don't think we need to spend
time on it further than say it is
different situations specific to its
site well when we look at this site of
course
we have this point about the residual
land value
um so i would say that there is weak
evidence to demonstrate fifteen percent
is the appropriate level to fix for
affordable housing
and the work double dixon cell indeed as
we we can read from mr is to pathfinder
on behalf of the residents association
that shows that it is reasonable to
expect greater levels of affordable
housing than have been proposed and
missed is pathfinder is correct
then on
simply updating the original scheme that
was assessed then one could get to a 27
provision and that's what should have
been offered
and as i understand it the residence
association drawing on his work
supports the council's refusal on the
grounds that the proposed level of full
housing would not meet the identified
need and that the higher proportion is
both required and feasible
and they agree that logically the
starting position should be to propose a
policy compliance scheme and then to
assess its viability and we're agreed on
that with them
uh there is a point about the updated
figures i just wanted to cover that
moving from june 21
to now or as near as we can we're using
november figures
one can see that the revenue
increase has been agreed uh by experts
but it's the cost increases that are in
dispute um
and of course the opponent's right those
cost increases would cancel out much of
any increased value
and we would say in updating the
viability work um dixon service
are correct to look at the geographical
location to identify the relevant figure
the increase in value as well as for the
increase in building costs and that is a
reasonable approach to take
and it is not appropriate to seek to
impose the costs from other parts of
kent which are nearer to london and its
influence on property and they'll use
sort of values that those parts of the
country afford as well
if we are ready to compare like for like
and to seek to update the revenue and
cost assumptions to bring them up to
date which is of course the whole point
of the exercise
then the consistent approach is to look
obviously the geographical location
the
viability work should reflect the latest
available
most locally relevant information and
also be consistent with the earlier
strategic work
the
sample size for than it is just
statistically significant it's like it's
big enough
and uses data from schemes within the
district
and unlike the ken's sample which
includes schemes from all over kent um
including characteristics of other areas
such as 7x um than it doesn't have that
in its data set
so just
bringing some of the threads together on
what we have before you
they're of course a number of sets of
figures
uh and
unsurprisingly dicks and cell were right
to say that um as they did back in their
an earlier review
that the size of the scheme means that
the viability outcome is very sensitive
to relatively small changes in the
assumptions that are used
um
because we do say the starting point
should be the successful proposal should
provide an appropriate number mix and
size and types of homes
complying with policy but
um it does mean that what we have at the
moment is
the financial viability assessment that
was submitted which is fine only as far
as it goes
but it only
assessed one version of the development
it would be that would be permitted by
the parameters of this permission
and it doesn't even make full use of
them
it also says the version that
isn't policy compliant
so whilst it's part of the application
it has several shortcomings in terms of
what can be said
and what it can be said to prove
and any assessment any good is the
assumptions on which it is based
and of course we can see the high-level
work as described of dixon's cell that's
appended in the test as proof
puts the numbers on the potential
movements of viability for adjustments
that one makes to the scheme and
assumptions that should be made
and that i do say limits the way it can
be attached to the viability evidence
and then i sort of did a brief summary
and i've
realized that we ended up with you know
six or seven if not slightly more
different versions
um and i've just summarized the figures
that they gave but i suppose just
running through it june 2020 i don't
think we need to spend too much time on
because it's been overtaken by events
and june 2021
uh is the one that really set out the 15
offer on this residual land value point
though interestingly it does look back
to 2020 and say well now that
equals um roughly the benchmark landlord
the update's been done to june 2021 um
figures you know of course you have what
mr cordray did still producing a deficit
but not as big as it would otherwise
have been
uh you have the work done by dixon cell
independent spear mr hester's
proof
which shows a surplus
um and a bigger surplus if one accepts
that this is likely to have a lower
developers profit
and then of course their figures must
oust
not seeing a different profit but
other assumptions showing that it would
lead to 27
affordable housing
and then of course on top of that you
have the point that if we were to look
at the policy compliance scheme
uh whereas the 2016 mix would give us a
potentially bigger deficit the more
up-to-date
situation um with 2021
mix would not and would allow for um
greater
than the benchmark land value
uh and then the figures from mr cordray
and his proof again slightly different
scenarios but again less than this um
comparable residual land value deficit
of 1.7 1.8 million uh clearly well
within that figure and providing more
and that's just on his updates
now we heard from mr ball that he looks
at what i've called version b initially
the june 2021 figure
as being the best case in terms of
viability now
the problem with that of course is that
others have shown that it does have more
value in it
um but the other problem is that it
is actually undeliverable when judged in
the light of the local plan
and i've gone through that obviously and
importantly we also then have a planning
condition that times unilateral which
look at something else other than what
was assessed
now if that's right
then i would say it's not fair to judge
this scheme against that mix
um
and we really should be looking at what
the policy compliant mixes would produce
and that's why we have the higher level
scenarios that have been done but
for all the criticisms levied against
the lower evaluation that might be
produced by the 2006 um makes it clear
that the mix would at least
if it was one that reflected the 2020
assessment would produce greater value
and would allow for greater affordable
housing
uh and
i suppose just add a sense of course
then is therefore not demonstrated that
15 is the correct figure
and
in that situation one's left with the
policy
of 30 percent
can then look at the planning balance uh
overall in terms of sort of concluding
comments the
i do draw mr hester's review in talking
about this that um
one of the points in the balance is
about the housing land supply uh and the
shortfall and what the what
weight one attaches to that we have some
agreed figures to how large the
shortfall is somewhere between four
point 4.23 and 4.34 years applying the
much larger buffer
and as he said the shortfall is not
significant and significant more
importantly of course significant steps
are being taken to address it there is a
housing action plan in place there is a
local plan that has significant sites in
it
and of course it is a situation here
where the local plan anticipates there
will be a lower provision in the earlier
years of planned period
um and
that's explained further in the annual
monitoring report as discussed so
it's that context one is then say well
how significant is the shortfall we say
not very significant not much weight to
be attached to it
but some way
because it's also recognized the appeal
proposals bring a number of benefits
obvious but it is worth acknowledging
and should be acknowledged that it is
providing for up to 450 homes of which
68 would be affordable homes and that
would go some way to meeting local needs
in the district
the fuel proposal would also help to
deliver a key piece of infrastructure
to help meet a highway need and reduce
the pressure on network capacity
and the additional haze will have a
positive impact upon the local economy
um but i don't want to note the
environmental benefits are not as great
as they at first seem
most of them are actually mitigation in
order to address the harms that would
otherwise arise for instance as you know
here this newly proposed bird mitigation
area
and there is only therefore limited
creation some additional new public open
space and ecological benefits in what is
proposed
however even with those benefits less
weight should be attached to them
because they're the thought of benefits
that could be equally provided by an
alternative scheme in particular for
instance the key piece of highways
infrastructure provided
could be covered by another scheme
whilst retaining
the provision of means of access to and
from the site and
i do make the point
and the scheme for 550 homes would also
go further in meeting the economic
objectives behind the allocation
and so
when it looks on the elements of the
harm i just need to touch on the point
that because the consideration of the
adverse impact um
we say of the under provision of
affordable housing comes on top of the
balance uh about the other harms um
which have been already identified in in
the state of the common ground we
haven't therefore discussed them in
detail
uh they haven't taken time up at the
inquiry but it's correct to recall that
they would occur
and also record
our view that in their own separate
terms they would be overcome
in the playing balance by the appeal
proposal if that was the only issue and
that's of course the points that relate
to
the less than substantial harm
to the change in the settings listed
buildings the loss of
agricultural land and the impact upon
the countryside and the landscape
character of this area
um obviously ones that go into the
balance there are harms they need to be
taken into account
but
um if that was all i was looking at um
they would be outweighed
this then leaves the important issue of
full housing provision
in the way it's been
presented and
obviously with the caveat about what the
intellectual seems to be offering the
offer is 15
the failure to provide 30 full housing
on the site has not we'd say been
appropriately justified by the work
that's been done in the five financial
viability assessment
so that failure means that the reason
for refusal identified by the council
would remain
with this harm to the strategic and
sustainable objectives of the local plan
it would mean that the scheme
would not meet the identified need for
affordable housing in the district and
not provide the required homes to create
a balanced and mixed community
and it's that important consideration
that means that in applying planning
balance
that the adverse impacts of granting the
scheme to use the classic words
uh would significantly and drastically
outweigh the benefits of actually
granting it so
that's
why we say that if all housing remains
such an important issue
but so that's what i want to say in
closing um
as you would have seen there's a
couple of
minor typos but if you want me to
correct it or you're happy for to have
it in the form that's
you've now got
i saw the liberty of making a quick note
on it so i'm happy with that and with
those couple of notes i've made to
correct those
thank you sir thank you mr upton for
those closing submissions on behalf
of the council
all right let me just
sort my screens out and make sure that
that is
saved
right um
now it's the turn of mr dickman on
behalf of the
rule six party
i'm just looking at my emails
i've not as have you sent anything
through mr dickman
so mr hand uh when he sent this through
to me he said he was also sending it
through to uh holly dustin
right i've not received anything through
michael's uh mr hans just put his hand
up
okay
yes sir so i sent it through to holly
about
20 minutes ago i think it was
okay uh it's not come through let me
just uh
see if this works again um
i know she's on the telephone because
there's now a red mark by her name so
let me just send her a quick email
because if i can get it through it'll be
helpful miss williams have you set yours
through yet as well
yes i sent mine through about eight
minutes ago right let me just send a
quick email sorry about this but i
haven't received anything from mr han
okay
[Music]
right i'm just gonna wait a couple of
moments to see if anything comes back
from the uh
email i've just sent
did you send your costs application
through as well mr williams
i didn't so i'm happy to i just didn't
know how you wanted to deal with it i
thought i'd wait until we've talked
about the timings of it
okay
um
i'm happy to
why didn't i do it anyway you can do it
anyway and then because i'm just getting
where i know that mister sort of at the
point between four o'clock and half or
where she may no longer be oh no i'm
sorry when i said i didn't send it
through i was thinking
she wouldn't get it today because i
didn't know whether you might say look
you know if we're doing it in writing
why don't you have till monday or
something i just didn't want to preempt
it i see i see well let's see where we
where we are because it we are now on
we're quarter past four so
i mean if
i think given the times the times that
we've got to go it probably would be i
think
advantageous it would seem to me that
if all the cost submissions are dealt
with in writing
just because of the time
where we are
i think that's where you were heading
and if you were going to do that i was
just going to take 10 minutes to make
sure i got my references right and
things right okay let's uh let's proceed
on that basis i think that's the uh most
reasonable at this fairly late hour uh
okay thank you so
right i've still not know i've not
received anything through um
i presume you've not either mr williams
or mr upton nothing from mr dickman
i mean i'm happy
just in terms of rather than sort of
waiting around
i'm happy to sort of
just listen to your
closing submissions mr dickman
and then obviously the copy will come
through to me which of course will be
very useful when i come to my uh
consideration
i won't be deviating from it so um
uh and i suspect it will only take me
about 20 minutes so
okay
okay is everyone happy to proceed on
that basis of doing it i suppose it's
the old-fashioned way where we didn't
used to have lots of copies before as i
suppose so
if everyone's happy to proceed on that
basis i am i'm not going to make a note
there mr dickman said so i will uh and
also looking at a separate screen which
is probably uh somewhat distracting
sometimes when i do that so
uh i'll listen to what you say then i'll
get the actual copy and write anything
so
yeah please commence
thank you
okay so uh this closing submission
summarizes the views of the rule six
party
at the end of the inquiry and focuses
particularly
on two of the three key matters
addressed in earlier statements
that is
loss of biodiversity without mitigation
and flood risk
in terms of the third matter viability
the appellant's expert witness
acknowledged the complex nature of the
site and the direct impact that that has
on cost risk layout and financial
viability
development thereby results in a level
of affordable housing which fails to
accord with the local planned policy
and does not reflect the high level of
need in such a deprived part of care
fundamentally therefore it's suitably as
suitability as the strategic housing
side remains questionable
and this application should have been
subject to greater scrutiny
at the examination stage at the local
plan
the local plan's general housing policy
sp14
clearly states that the proposals for
residential development on sites
allocated in the plan must
provide affordable housing to meet the
requirements of policy sp 23
given the specialist and technical
nature of fbas additional comments on
the matter without furthering input from
the expert is difficult
however
the rule six party relate
reiterate mr all's point that the fba
assumptions highlighted in his appraisal
are regularly agreed by the parties in
viability assessment negotiations
that the appellant's expert witness
takes issue with each of mr roy's
observations on the inflated nature of
certain assumptions
in the fba
which were not challenged in the dixon
cell review
is a clear indication of the fluidity of
the process
2.
breeding bird survey
the lack of breeding bird survey report
was referred to and discussed at all
three planning committees
dealing with the application
the apparent psychology witness
confirmed that this report was finally
produced in december 2021
despite the surveys being conducted
between april and june 2020
the reason given as to why it was not
made available earlier was that the tdc
had not requested it
the conclusion from this is that neither
natural england
nor the county council have considered
and accepted the report
it is believed there is a requirement
for kcc to sign off report but there is
no confirmation
whether the county council has seen the
results of the survey or the rationale
for signing it off
no species of wildlife will remain
present on a building site
and are not likely to return to a tiny
patch of leftover land designated for
them
and thinking about this lancer
we're situated by the very busy road
mansion road which gets uh extremely
busy during the summer months because of
the tip and and and holiday traffic
and given that uh the other road
coming through the estate will run very
close to it what you basically have is
an island between two busy roads and and
houses
[Music]
the inspector asked mr caldwell that
given the limitations of the small
proposed area on the site mitigation
whether off-site provision would be more
meaningful
the answer given was that tdc had not
asked for this and there is no agreed
mitigation planning than it for farmland
birds wildlife
the rspp
website clearly indicates that farmland
birds
even if they nest in hedges
only survive with the access to open
land
in discussion the appellant's witness
appeared to rebut this notion
despite reference in her proof to the
importance of
surrounding farmland to provide
mitigation
ms coldwell confirmed that the
appellants had not approached any third
party
owners regarding off-site mitigation for
farmland birds
on adjacent land under no survey of the
suitability of jason hand have been
undertaken
suira therefore remains concerned about
the matter of breeding birds
particularly in the context of
compliance with local plant policy sp
30.
sams
to uh success 106 payments towards that
sams provides a warden scheme minimizing
the recreational disturbance for the
winter months
on the 24 mile coastline
the legal requirement to protect the spa
and its qualifying features
includes the golden plover which uses
inland farmland or functional land
the inquiry confirmed that there is no
provision for minimising the
recreational disturbance on functional
land
all of which is third party farmland
the appellant survey did not identify
them but recent records show the golden
cover present on central planet farmland
this varies annually depending on
factors such as cropping
regime and openness
including fallow land
please excuse me sir
policy svp 14
of the local plan
includes a requirement to include an
assessment of the development's effect
on functional land
that may be used as a roosting
or feeding habitat
by wintering or breeding birds
identified by the sba
and provides mitigation where necessary
mr ball stressed the need for each site
to be assessed on its individual merits
on a case-by-case basis
however the cumulative impact of this
together with the other proposal central
uh planet developments will lead to all
central functions stroke farmland being
affected by recreational disturbance
by virtue of proximity and close walking
distance
[Music]
red-listed birds
only a few red flag species
are considered in the breeding bird
survey report in comparison to those
that were identified in both the ecsa
and suarez surveys
in order to survive the corn bunting and
other redlisted species require a whole
farm landscape
once a habitat is removed it cannot be
replaced with the same
trying to replicate a habitat will not
guarantee
that disturbed species will return
as they will not recognize a habitat and
food sources will have been vastly
displaced
the notion that disturbance to the
on-site habitat
actually that should be
depleted
the notion that disturbance to the
on-site habitat of red listed species
has been categorized as having only
local level impact
underplays the cumulative impact of
sight by sight loss of habitat which
will affect much of the central planet
and i would have to say so that um
i i really couldn't understand the
notion that um
loss of uh breakfasted birds locally
is acceptable
for me
if a bird is on a red list it's um
it's endangered and every bird it should
be looked at in those terms
if as it's pointed out here if you lose
enough birds have enough areas you lose
a whole species
um and i couldn't quite understand the
notion of local localized
loss and that being acceptable
roost in bats
despite miss caldwell's low evaluation
of the site in terms of potential bat
roosting tip features
suira remains concerned about the
proposed tree removal along shot and
dane road
and the fact that new tree planting on
site may take 30 years to mature
additionally the impact of foraging and
roosting disturbance
during
construction cannot be quantified
blood risk
flood events
mr travis mentioned that both the 1973
and the 21 21 historic flood events
referred to by various parties are well
documented and to be expected given the
topography of the area
the flood event in 1973
was particularly severe
and reported
nationally
some 23 millimeters of rainfall were
recorded in 15 minutes
in fact i do know that over 100
over 12 hours 172 millimeters
at its peak in the shot and dane area
sawaria had contacted
the beacon shotgun area
so i have contacted kcc asking why
there's no mention of the 1973 flooding
in their flood events records or than it
the response indicates that the county
council had only been flood risk
management authority since 2010
although the council have records that
predate the event the records are
reliant on floods being reported and
they may not be comprehensive
figure one in the flood resistance
risk assessment of dependencies maps
environmental agency historic flood
extents
in the vanity area but shows no
indication of any historic event in the
vicinity of the appeals site
flat modelling should surely take into
account the serious flood event in 1973
when there was threat to life in fact a
life was lost
however if neither the lead local flood
authority nor the environment agency
have a record of this event then we
question the efficacy and the
reliability of the flood model used
tivoli brook
appeals site is located in the catchment
area of tivoli brook
mr travis explained the distinction
between the ephemeral water course and
the occasional flows overland through
lower water part of the site
and the carpeted off-site drain which
can be located on the opposite side of
hartsdown road
in spite of the proposals to separate
the flower and surf fowl and surface
water in the development
soiree remained concerned that in
periods of
exceptional rainfall
the on-site infiltration system
and the foul drainage may be overwhelmed
thereby resulting in a natural and
historic flow path to the culverted
brook
which discharges onto margate premier
beach
bring other matters
briefly suara would also like to reflect
a couple of other matters highlighted by
local residents during the inquiry
loss and damage of farmland
there is a genuine fear that the
development of the appeal site will
cause a domino effect leading to
combined loss of 30 to 40 percent of the
landscape character area c2
the central undulating short farm
recreational disturbance resulting from
this and other planned developments will
affect the whole character of the area
along with the loss of farmland its
functionality will change
due
to as farmland viability is impacted
this is contrary to strategic priority
for the thanet local plan
which aims to safeguard local
distinctiveness and promote the
protection and enhancement of than its
environment
including the landscape and by
biodiversity
in addition
policy sp26
pertinent as it's saying to
conserve conserving than its landscape
landscape character and local
distinctiveness
including that of central parts of the
district with a sense of openness and
big skies
in accordance with this policy we do not
see any evidence that proposed
development demonstrates how we can
serve and enhance than its local
distinctiveness
gp services
the dire situation with existing high
ratio patients
and proportionate gps
registered at the time that the lines
practice in margaret was raised by
several interested parties
mr ball confirmed that consultation with
the ccg has resulted in a great
contribution to a planning obligation
however this payment is restricted
facilities uh facility provision will
not address the underlying issue of the
pressing need associated with the
recruitment and retention of health
service personnel in planet
in conclusion
the site was a late addition to the
local plan as an allocated strategic
housing site
its suitability remains questionable
given the significant constraints
posed by the topography hydrology
geology and archaeology on the
development
the potential adverse impact of the
proposals on biodiversity in the area is
substantial
and the proposed mitigation measures
appear to be inadequate to compensate
for this
despite assurances about the efficacy of
the proposed suds in increased risk from
surface water flooding posed by the
development and other large-scale
housing sites on the adjacent land
remained a major concern
the role of tivoli brookie in drainage
of the area
together with the question of disputed
ownership remains inadequately addressed
and we do have just a footnote on that
sir we continue to have major concerns
about the um
the disputed ownership
uh
neither kcc tdc or
worryingly southern water uh will
um admit to ownership or even take on
ownership
so
that really leaves any future residents
in a very difficult situation
it puts
thanet
coastline which is of of international
importance
in a very fragile situation
and thirdly it does mean that many
businesses many small businesses uh
reliance on the terrorist trade
again in a very precarious position if
this can't be sorted out because they
may indeed be looking for some support
or indeed at future defense compensation
for these reasons and in consideration
of the planning balance swara affirms
its conclusion that the appeal should be
dismissed
thank you sir
thank you mr dickman uh you'd be pleased
to hear the email came through halfway
through as well so i was able to get up
your uh
submission in written form as well and
follow it in writing so
thank you
thanks
thank you for that submission
uh i've also got through
yours i think as well uh mr williams
let's just see
what it is opening up the email um
yes appellant's final submission so that
has come through
as well he'd be pleased to hear um
okay uh mr williams uh the appellants
closing submissions
thank you very much so i'm glad you've
got it in writing because i won't
i won't in that case read out
every word where i've got some quotes
um
paragraphs one and two
i won't read out
turning to paragraph three the
background and context of this
issue that's issue a on affordable
housing provision is extremely important
firstly the appellant worked openly and
cooperatively with the council to agree
the highest percentage of affordable
housing provision that the site could
support
given its site-specific constraints and
its strategic role in delivering the
on-sites highways infrastructure of the
link road and making other contributions
mr board explained that the scheme was
arrived at following a number of
pre-application meetings with the
district and county councils over the
course of a year
prior to application pursuant to a
planning performance agreement
the progress made through that
and the total acceptability of the
scheme is made clear through the
committee reports
and i set out some
references here
to the three committee reports that i
took mr hester to in cross examination
and i won't read all of these out but i
will draw attention to the position
in 4a
off the policy department
that the housing numbers in the plan
allocations were estimates
and that inevitably sites would deliver
more or less than anticipated but
balance out
over the planned period and drawing
attention to the primary role
of this site um in providing
the inner
circuit ring road and that there would
be no objection to housing numbers
um if no more housing could be provided
on the side and then
b in the same report planning officers
confirmed
that the applicant had demonstrated
specific factors
impacting on capacity
due to the nature and topography of the
site so that the proposed number of
dwellings was appropriate and there was
no objection to the number of dwellings
proposed
i can move quickly over
paragraph c and d you'll read them again
in due course no doubt
and note the conclusion that the scheme
was policy compliant and brought a
number of benefits which i've there
referred to
paragraph five
the second committee report in june
21 considered an enhanced provision of
15 affordable housing in light of the
improved market circumstances by that
time and then
officers advised that the benefits
of the scheme demonstrably outweighed
any harm
and advanced the council's objectives of
ensuring residents have access to good
quality housing
the report endorsed what it described as
the agreed assumptions
within the financial viability appraisal
and that the methodology was suitable
and based on verifiable evidence and
recognized indexes
in members were specifically advised as
to the relevant costs test
and advised that the
assessment of officers and the council's
appointed consultants
was that the submitted evidence has
shown that the development would be
unviable if the affordable housing on
site was increased above 15
and without any evidence to the country
refusal on grounds of insufficient
affordable housing would be untenable at
appeal as policy sp 23 outlines that the
30 requirement will only be reduced if
meeting them would demonstrably make the
proposed development unviable an officer
said that therefore the reduced amount
in this instance taking into account the
other contributions provided and the
review mechanism to capture any uplifts
would accord with local plan policy and
any refusal on this ground would be at
high risk of being overturned at appeal
with costs awarded
against the council and
members were born specifically against
turning the site down based on the
target affordable housing amount
um paragraph six
refers to when the report was taken to
committee for the third time
and the deferral had only related to the
issue of affordable housing provision
which as we know became
reason for refusal won
no other concerns were raised for
example relating to the parameter plan
or whether inefficient use was being
made of land and that's set out in
paragraph 2.2 of the third report
officer's advice is very clear
it refers to sp 23
it refers to the previous
reports
and the fact that the council had
accepted that the scheme would be
unviable if more than 15 affordable
housing
was provided on site and then this is
important following the previous
planning committee the viability
information provided
has been reviewed
to assess whether a lower percentage
amount for different costs
could reasonably be identified which
would increase provision to 30 percent
so specifically looking at the cost
this has looked at base build costs
that's the bcis point
external works professional fees
disposal cost private revenue and
developers return that's obviously
developers profit
whilst a lower development profit figure
at 50 could be adopted this would not
result in a sufficient increase to allow
for 30 affordable housing with the
approach of a 17 and a half
figure consistent with the position of
the council on other viability
appraisals within the identified
government range
the other assumptions reviewed in the
viability appraisal do not clearly show
any reasonable limits of deviation
which would increase the viability of
the scheme on the basis of the evidence
provided by the applicant and
independently
assessed therefore it's concluded that
the development would be in accordance
with sp 23
members were also advised that it was
necessary to identify substantial harm
in order to justify refusal on the
tilted balance
it was reiterated that there was
compliance with sp 23 and the reason for
refusal offered was on the basis that sp
23 was complied with but that strategic
priority 3 was not
that was the reason for refusal put
forward by members
it clearly does not assert any breach of
sp23
or any other plan policy
members were again advised that on
appeal significant weight is likely to
be given to the viability evidence
independently assessed by the council
and substantial weight to the delivery
of housing on an allocated site where
the council can't demonstrate either a
five-year housing land supply or meet
the housing delivery test it was again
reiterated that sp 2083 was complied
with and there was no policy conflict
so against this background it's clear
that firstly the only concerns
raised by members related specifically
to the amount of affordable housing
provided
secondly members were repeatedly advised
that the financial viability appraisal
had been independently verified and was
suitable and demonstrated an inability
to provide more than 15 affordable
housing and that the local planned
policies were complied with by the
scheme
thirdly that to depart from this
position on viability without evidence
would be unreasonable
fourthly that following deferral
officers could present no evidence to
support taking a different position on
viability indeed there were no
reasonable limits of deviation from the
assumptions made by james lange
that as mr hester agreed
as a matter of fact
members have before them no evidence
that supported taking a different
position on viability
than that assessed
therefore the reason for refusal that
the council must substantiate is not
based on any breach of an identified
development policy and none is referred
to in the reason for refusal
it requires the council to demonstrate
substantial harm relating to the scheme
that significantly and demonstrably
outweighs the very substantial benefits
of the scheme
i described the identification of the
harm as a will of the whispering opening
because it is something that perhaps
members thought they saw
but cannot be tracked down as anything
of substance
at the end of the inquiry that point is
made good the council has been unable
as officers advised it would be to
identify any substantial harm through
the provision
of up to 450 homes including 68 or up to
68 affordable homes on a site allocated
in the local plan and the provision of
the relevant part of the inner link road
all this in circumstances where all of
the viability work was independently
verified endorsed by council officers
through an iterative process
and where there was no contradictory
viability evidence before members at the
time of the decision
and where no contradictory viability
evidence is called now
there's a further important point of
context
during oral evidence it was apparent
that mr hester's concerns
appeared to relate to what had not been
assessed rather than what had been
on receipt of the council statement of
case
and in advance of the case management
conference without your recall sir the
appellant wrote to the council drawing
attention to annex j of the procedural
guidance and seeking confirmation of any
scenarios the council contended should
be addressed in any viability appraisal
in support of the appeal proposal and
seeking further information as to what
assumptions and inputs it suggested
should be
addressed within a viability appraisal
and the council has not at any time
during the appeal process
identified any alternative scenarios
other than those referred to in the dsp
note i'll address those below but this
information those scenarios were
provided for the first time
through the exchange of proofs
it's accordingly plainly unreasonable to
seek to criticize the scheme for not
considering any alternative scenarios
when despite specific requests the
council has not identified any
alternative scenario it says should be
considered
indeed the council does not present any
evidence whatsoever
of any alternative scheme
it says could generate higher numbers or
higher value and does not present a
single viability appraisal of any scheme
including the mix assessed in the
financial viability appraisal
thirdly the
dependent has at all times
indicated its willingness to include a
review mechanism within the planning
obligation so that if viability
materially improves then an additional
contribution will be made
and this gives the council the security
that if the market improves then
additional affordable housing within the
district will be provided
given the need for affordable housing
the provision of 68 units is a very
significant benefit and if additional
units can be provided then that's an
additional benefit
by the end of his evidence mr hester
appeared to be suggesting that an
outline scheme could only ever carry a
30 percent affordable housing percentage
this point's never been raised by the
council before and is plainly
unreasonable it simply shuts its eyes to
all of the evidence presented
turning to the viability of the scheme
i suggest that the viability issue can
following hearing all the evidence
be cut through quite clearly
it's common ground that all issues
of the appropriate cost and valuation
inputs
and our and assumptions
are matters of specialist evidence from
surveyors and or quantity surveillance
as referred to above
all of these assumptions were made using
the professional judgment of mr cooldrey
and were considered appropriate and
endorsed by dsp and ermc
they are the cost consultants
as set out above officers concluded that
there were no reasonable deviations from
those assumptions in the circumstances
of the site and the application
the council calls no such specialist
evidence
mr hester acknowledges that all
valuation and cost assumptions are
outside his expertise
the statement of common ground confirms
that the specialists and the council
consider these inputs are reasonable
dsp in its paper that's appendix b to mr
hester does not suggest any of the cost
and value input assumptions made by jll
are unsuitable erroneous or
inappropriate
and it doesn't offer an opinion that any
alternative cost or value inputs should
be substituted for those used by jll and
previously endorsed by it dsp were not
called to give evidence
and did not produce any rebuttal
material in response to mr caldery's
evidence
i just flagged this up the exercise in
millennium's closing at paragraph 50
setting out different figures does not
recognize that none of the figures there
presented
apart from mr cool trees of course are
based on financial viability appraisals
so the role of mr hester relates only to
questions of policy mix
size or types of units
now as to mix and type the dsp work
undertaken on instructions shows that
the two scenarios which mr hester
considers more policy compliant
versions 102 and 103
are less valuable
than the mix assessed by gladman
value in a scheme is represented by the
residual land value which reflects the
value of the land to a developer with
that planning permission
the developers profit in these
appraisals is an input
and so an assessment of these newly
asserted mixes ketteris parabus
actually goes entirely against the
reason for refusal
it does not substantiate the reason for
refusal it directly undermines it
it was entirely unnecessary to go down
this route the iterative process of
assessment review reappraisal and
further consideration had already
established that the departures from the
shma mix in order to provide a higher
provision of family housing drove up
value and as officers put it was
therefore a robust mix to assess a best
case for gdv
it remains the case that out of all of
the combinations of mix and type put
forward the appendance mix is the most
valuable and mr cordrey's assessment on
a like-for-like basis of the three
scenarios considered by dsp is set out
in his rebuttal evidence of paragraph
3.7.1
mr cordrey had also based on a lack of
clarity as to what the council intended
to argue
also considered another version where
only only the affordable housing
reflected the smart mix
but that also generated a deficit of rlv
against blv
and when the scenario that mr hester in
fact contended for became clear that
further appraisal showed a significant
deficit
the point sorry that should be a
reference to the tdc closing
the point of the defense closing at 31
appears to be based on a
misunderstanding mr cordrey did appraise
the mix that the council through dsp
said reflected the two schma or lhn
documents in the same way that dsp did
there is no missing appraisal and no
additional appraisal has ever been
requested
as to size the minor difference in size
of the two-bedroom houses has been
appraised by mr cordrey in response to
the council's evidence and this shows
that the rlv remains the below the blv
in any event
that is even assuming the same values
per square foot as mr cordrey explained
in reality due to the reflective quantum
discount the revenue side would have to
be adjusted downwards by about 571 000
pounds which would have a broadly
equivalent downward effect on the
residual land value
in other words there's nothing to
suggest this would improve the viability
position and this is acknowledged by dsp
where they acknowledge that the effect
on value of increased property sizes is
uncertain because it depends on market
response
as to numbers or floor space the
appraisals as they masked reflect the
scheme for which permission is sought
the scheme and its parameters have been
clearly justified and the layout
considered in order to optimize its
value for the purposes of the fba even
if that reserve matters an alternative
mix is required
the council doesn't provide any
appraisal based on a scheme of more than
which is obviously because it wouldn't
be an appraisal of the scheme which
would receive planning permission
accordingly the starting point is the
costs and valuation inputs and
assumptions endorsed by the council's
advisors
when these are updated on an equivalent
basis that is not changing any of the
assumptions
but updating for changes in value and
build cost indices
the scheme remains unviable at 15
affordable housing
and that's the appraisal referred to by
mr cordray at 481-482
there's no dispute that if the same
approach is taken but simply updated
then the scheme remains unviable in that
the rlv is below the blv
mr hester's evidence of course doesn't
relate to any of these assumptions or
justify changing them
he suggests appraising different
variations to the scheme appraised
but it's been shown by dsp itself that
such changes actually lower the value
of the scheme compared to the schemes
appraised and so undermines rather than
substantiates the reason for refusal
so against that clear narrative these
closing submissions go on to pick up
some of the clear faults in the
council's case
first of all
viability itself
the ppg on viability
sets out for purposes of consistency and
transparency the approach to be taken to
viability appraisals in planning
the approach is clearly set out and it
was agreed with mr hester it's necessary
to consider whether the rlv
that's the value of the land with the
assumed planning commission
exceeds the blv that's the existing use
value with a sufficient premium to
induce the owner to sell
all of jll's assessments have been done
on this basis
as has the dsp review and offices
reports to committee
as mr cordray explains
one runs residual appraisals as an
iterative process until one arrives at a
deficit
and that displays the amount of
affordable housing a scheme can support
in the present case a comparison against
a deficit of 1.7 million has no role at
all
in assessing the viability of the scheme
the fact that a particular applicant
makes particular offers to secure
planning permission doesn't dictate
viability
as mr cordrey emphasized viability
appraisal is a level playing field
which which values the site with
planning permission it's applicant blind
the suggestion that because in seeking
to negotiate its planning commission the
specific applicant had been prepared to
accept the deficit does not go to the
assessment of the viability of the
scheme
which appeared to be the suggestion in
cross-examination
viability is as set out in the planning
practice guidance and the rics guidance
assessed against the benchmark land
value
actually in this case the benchmark land
value derives from the local plan and is
an agreed figure
the particular arrangements between the
appellant and the landowner are separate
from how viability is to be assessed the
councils never suggested the schemes
undeliverable which again appeared to be
suggested to mr paul and it's frankly
unclear at the end of the inquiry
whether the council is asking you sir to
approach viability by
not applying the ppg if that is the
suggestion then it's plainly
unreasonable to ask the secretary of
state to ignore his own guidance
as to build costs
the council's case in relation to build
costs is entirely untenable and
unsubstantiated
in its original appraisal
james lang lasalle used unit costs
derived from median bcis costs rebased
to kept
and that gave rise to build costs of
52.7 million pounds
the council retains specialist quantity
surveyors ermc to consider all
construction costs
ermc specifically considered the correct
basis for such costs noting that there
was a phallic index but concluding on
the basis of the specific scheme site
and detailed appraisal put forward that
given the level of design development of
the housing element of the scheme the
jll rate is considered reasonable
they went on to present their own cost
assessment
inputting different costs where they
disagreed with jl
and they were on specific other items
which were subsequently the subject of
the breed
but the sum costed for erm by ermc for
the residential build costs was
52.724 million
the figure was not only endorsed but
ermc used that basis in their own costs
plan
dsp also explicitly commented on this in
their report and noted the conclusion of
the quantity surveyors that these costs
were suitable
officers also expressly commented on and
endorsed the use of the bcis median rate
for kent as acceptable
further this was explicitly one of the
key inputs reviewed in the third
committee report in relation to which
officers advised members that there were
no reasonable limits of deviation
now following review of the council
statement of case
um
sorry following refusal the council
statement of case noted that dsp had
endorsed interalia the costs and that
the viability outputs accordingly were
not challenged but only points relating
to numbers size and mix
consistent with this the council does
not call any evidence to justify
departing from the agreed use of the
kent based bcis cost base taking the
default 15 year sample
it's not the subject of advice or
justification from dsp let alone ermc so
that advice stands
therefore the position on advice of the
council is that the use of that cost
base is suitable and that advice stands
mr hester's proof states at 3.38
that he asked dsp
not to change the appendant's
assumptions on costs and values
he accepted that these matters were the
preserve of specialists or dark arts i
think he called it and he had no role in
relation to such inputs
however it transpired in
cross-examination that in fact he had
instructed dsp
in its note to change the cost base to a
than it five-year one
now why this is wrong
is addressed fundamentally by mr cordrey
and his proof of evidence at section 4.5
and in his oral answers
there's no concept of considering costs
and values on a like-for-like
geographical basis as the values and
costs are driven by extraneous figures
the rmc recognized this
further to update on this basis gives
the ludicrous outcome that the council
now assesses build costs at a unit rate
of 126 pounds per square foot
um which is considerably lower than that
used in the june 2021 appraisal at a
time of very significant cost inflation
this is plainly contrary to the market
and common sense and shows that in no
sense is this an update
further the issue of sample size is
significant the change from kemp-based
to thanic based and then 15-year sample
to five-year sample
leaves a five-year sample reflecting out
turn costs from only 15 schemes in total
this is obviously less reliable than a
larger sample size and mr caldery's
approach is derived from a sample size
of 257 schemes
there's absolutely no explanation for
the change of year base from 5 years to
15 years which is again directly at odds
with those figures used by ermc in its
own cost plan
mr caldery's table at 4 5 11 shows the
value significance of such changes and
the cost based used in the dsp scenarios
is entirely unjustified
but more fundamentally than why it's
wrong
mr hester's position is entirely
unreasonable
because by a slight of hand
under the cover of an update he
requested a fundamental change to the
cost base directly contradictory to the
advice of the surveyors and quantity
surveyors retained by the council to
advise on these assumptions in relation
to the viability appraisals
it is very notable that dsp do not
provide any justification for moving
from not only kent to than it but from
15 to 5 year sample basis and that they
haven't been called to give evidence
dsp had advised on the local plan they
knew what assumptions had been made at
the high level local plan stage and they
had specifically endorsed and in their
own costings used the jll figure for
base residential construction costs
derived from the median bcis cost
rebates for kent
when asked mr hester could point to no
documentary evidence to support this
changed position
he referred only to the ppg but as mr
cordrey explained that says absolutely
nothing about a matter of such detail
and professional judgment once the
sleight of hand is exposed as being
without evidential foundation there is
effectively common ground that if the
previous costs and value inputs are
maintained and simply updated then all
of the dsp scenarios are unviable at 15
affordable housing the highest value one
being the mix proposed by gladman and
assessed in the financial viability
appraisal
i turn then to questions of constraints
and opportunities
as mr board explained and also explained
by you heard from mr travis mrs mira
miss caldwell there are a number of
constraints that must be reflected in
any scheme
the scheme proposed is optimized in
light of the constraints the master plan
can deliver smart compliant mixes and
others but for the fva the scheme put
forward was reasonably optimized for
value
officers recognize this accepting that
specific factors relating to the nature
and topography of the site as well as
the infrastructure requirements
justified it
the reason for refusal raises no concern
in relation to the parameter plans or
the form of the outline consent
although mr hester appeared to suggest
that alternative forms and amounts of
development may be possible
there are three fundamental difficulties
with his position
firstly as mr hester acknowledged his
proof of evidence and comments were not
based on consideration of the site
constraints
secondly no alternative scheme or
variation on a scheme has been presented
by the council
thirdly there is absolutely no evidence
to suggest that any notional changes
would drive value up rather than down
as mr cordrey explained adding for
example height to a building may well
not improve viability as the additional
space created would be proportionately
less valuable than would add cost
the council have not asked dsp to
consider anything other than at a high
level the two alternative scenarios
presented and each of those is less
valuable than the gladman scheme
assessed
similarly in cross-examination of mr
cawdry it will suggest that different
schedules of accommodation may be
capable of being devised
mr caldery said that no doubt you could
have different configurations and
schedules however he had considered the
schedule to see whether it optimized
value and was satisfied it did
the planning merits of different mixes
are outside his
expertise but again the council's
presented absolutely no evidence in
support of the case that a more valuable
scheme can reasonably be devised and
valued
turning to developers profit
um this can be taken very shortly
despite being instructed by mr hester to
provide a sensitivity calculation based
on a lower level dsp at all times have
considered and stuck by developers
profit of 17.5 percent
this is the same approach as mr crawdry
it's in the middle of the ppg range it's
a matter of a professional judgment by
specialist surveyors officers advised
that not only was 17.5 reasonable as
being in the middle of the range but it
was consistent with the position of the
council on other viability appraisals
salmerston grange is an example of
another site specific appraisal on an
outline scheme affected by the pandemic
when the council endorsed the use of 20
developers profit
it's of course unreasonable for an
authority to determine similar cases
inconsistently
there was some suggestion in
cross-examination that the appellant's
earlier offered to meet an affordable
housing percentage of 15
despite the viability of cradle sharing
a deficit had a bearing on developers
profit it does not as mr cordray
explained
developers profit reflects the scheme
and the risk reward for the developer in
undertaking it
it has nothing to do with the individual
applicant or landowner
the council's closing of paragraph 43 as
with mr hester
misunderstands that the developers
profit has nothing to do with the land
sale or land promotion
it reflects carrying out the scheme by
the developer with planning permission
the developers profit is on the rlv side
not the blv side or any action of the
landowner shortly the percentage is
agreed between the specialists at 17.5
percent and that's what mr cordres used
in his appraisals
local plan
as mr hester agreed it's inevitable that
more detailed evidence will be available
to form the basis of an appraisal at the
planning application stage than the
local plan stage as is recognized by the
ppg
the inputs and assumptions applied here
and endorsed by dsp were endorsed in the
context of a site-specific appraisal
there's no basis to renege on that
advice by reference to the previous
assessment relating to the local plan
which was at an earlier stage at a
higher level at a different time and
which did not relate to a specific
scheme
dsp were of course aware of the local
plan viability work having produced it
they nonetheless endorsed the final jl
inputs and assumptions are suitable for
the application specific site level
appraisal
turning to the smart and the lhn there's
a moot point as to whether any mix
considered sp 22 should relate to the
2016 schma or the 2021 paper on lhn
local housing need to support the local
plan review
it's moot for two reasons firstly
because asset out above either mix one
type generates a lower value than the
appellant's assessed mix
secondly because the myth will be
addressed as a reserve matter
however the points addressed by mr ball
in rebuttal in detail in short sp 22
requires development to have regard to
the shma as to mips and type as may be
reviewed or superseded
the 2021 paper remains out for
consultation and so its recommendations
may change it has not therefore
superseded the 2016 schma
outline scheme there was some suggestion
that it was inappropriate to assess
viability on an outline scheme that's
clearly incorrect there's nothing in
national policy or the local plan to
support such a contention salmon grange
illustrates another example of the
council doing just that and there was no
suggestion from officers or members at
any stage that there is a fundamental
difficulty with assessing viability on
an outline scheme
the decision maker just determines the
application before it and the way to do
it as the council did in this case is to
test the assumptions put forward
as to the rule six parties position
the factual position is that mr ross
produced a very short proof
suggesting a number of alternative
assumptions
as mr cordrey said the points were
effectively assertions without any
substantial evidence to support them
the assumptions put forward are
inconsistent with the position taken by
dsp and ermc
supporting mr cordrey's view that they
are not consistent with the assumptions
ordinarily made in such a appraisals
tailored to the site specific
circumstances of this case
mr crawdry provided a comprehensive
response to these points and those of
cpre in his main proof of evidence
mr cordrey provided additional evidence
in support of his position and
assumptions in his detailed rebuttal
evidence
on the friday before the inquiry
commenced the rule six party sent an
email saying that mr orst would not now
be given oral evidence
the only expert viability evidence
therefore called and tested is that of
mr caldery which must be given full
weight
the decision not to call mr horst has
denied the appellant the opportunity of
testing his evidence at inquiry
as noted there is very little if any
evidence to substantiate the points made
in writing
accordingly the written evidence can be
given minimal weight
overview
at the end of the evidence the
appellant's position is clear and
consistent
the scheme assessed against the
benchmark land value is unviable with 15
affordable housing
the mix
use for the purposes of the assessment
so the mix used for the purpose of the
assessment is the highest value mix
identified by any party
the council's position is not at all
clear
all of the evidence from its surveyors
is consistent with the appeal scheme
being unable to provide 30 affordable
housing
dsp endorsed the position that 15 was
the maximum the scheme could afford
that remains the position on a like for
like updated basis as demonstrated by mr
crawdery and accepted by mr hester
the variations as to size mix and tight
don't change this as shown by mr
cauldron accepted by mr hester
the council does not present any more
valuable schemes
it does not present a single financial
viability appraisal only some high level
variations which only confirm that the
assessed scheme is the highest value
scheme before the inquiry
those variations as now corrected show a
very significant deficit for the 2016
schmalmix that they say would be
consistent with sp 22.
and that is even allowing for the
unjustified vault fast on the cost base
the 2021 draft lhn position shows a very
marginal surplus on the same basis
that taking dsp's figure of 140 000 per
additional affordable unit would allow
for approximately four extra affordable
units
given that these are high level examples
the dsp evidence in fact shows that the
appellant's position at 15 is supported
and the evidence substantiates the
appeal of the appendage position and not
the reason for refusal
such judgments are based on professional
judgment
mr cordrey's judgment has been endorsed
by dsp and ermc
but even when the council departs from
their own advisors positions on costs
and values
the end point is the same on a range of
high-level examples considered at 15
the council's preferred 2016 mix falls
well below the blv and its emerging 21
mix broadly at the blv at this very high
level of assessment
at the detailed level of assessment mr
cordrey the only person to place
financial viability appraisals before
the inquiry they all show that at 15
affordable housing the residual value of
the scheme falls below the benchmark
land value
so questions of weight
don't help the council
whichever fva one chooses
to give weight to
they all support the same conclusion
mr hester at the end of the inquiry is
not in a position to say what level of
affordable housing the scheme can
sustain and he doesn't do so
if in reality the concern is simply a
lingering fear that the situation may
improve
then that's addressed through the review
mechanism
albeit that ordinarily the percentage
must be fixed at this stage
so you're left i'm afraid sir with a
reason for refusal
which objects to the level of affordable
housing being provided at 15
and with evidence from the council that
entirely fails to substantiate or
identify any higher figure that the
scheme can provide
briefly on the unilateral undertaking
the appellant's position is that the
evidence shows 15 is the appropriate
figure
and we ask that the decision letter
adopts that position
however if for whatever reason that you
would disagree then the 106 allows for
permission to be granted subject to a 30
figure or somewhere in between
as mentioned in the discussion earlier
the difficulties in this regard are
evidential
in that the council does not put forward
any positive case on what level of
affordable housing this scheme can
sustain
and does not produce an appraisal in
line with what appears to be mr hester's
suggestion that 30 percent should be
insistent upon in default
but that's to ignore the raft of
viability evidence before the inquiry
as i said there's no fva sharing of 30
affordable housing is viable
so for that reason the appellant submits
it's difficult to see
how an alternative percentage can on the
evidence be justified
against the regulation one two two test
but that is a matter for you
on on on the evidence if you find for
example that an additional one
could be afforded by reference to the
council's case and the dsp work then the
provision in the 106 allows you to deal
with that
there is also a review mechanism as
explained in the 106 discussion
if you're satisfied but 30 provision is
necessary to make the development
acceptable then permission can be
granted on that base and this would
presumably entirely overcome the
council's concern as to the provision of
the appropriate amount of affordable
house
i turn them to the second issue
and
the s p
a
i read out paragraph 50 that's the same
as my opening i won't read it out again
is that miss caldwell's appendix c
the satan's common ground confirms that
the council has also undertaken a shadow
appropriate assessment and the council
is satisfied that subject to the
mitigation secured the project won't
have any additional sorry any adverse
recreational effects on the spa
and the council and the appellant agree
that the specific requirement of the
habitat regulations is met namely that
subject to the legal obligation securing
this
contribution
no adverse effect will occur on the
integrity of the protected sites in
proximity to the application site
either alone or in combination
further the council confirmed the
proposed development level of
contribution secured through the legal
obligation is in accordance with local
planned policy a missed call will also
explain the beneficial effects of the
on-site public open space the upgrading
footpath and provision of a trim trail
um the county council were also
consulted and advised that they raised
no objection
um subject to the sam contributions and
most recently on the 10th of january
natural england confirmed firstly that
the european sites and their qualifying
features appear to have been
appropriately identified within the
shadow hra
secondly the identified avoidance and
reduction measures are sufficient to
avoid an adverse impact on the integrity
of european sites and relevant features
thirdly that the proposed avoidance and
reduction measures proposed to be
secured through legal obligations
including the provision of financial
contributions
in line with policy sp 29 of the local
plan is an established approach to
adequately secure deliverability for the
purposes of the strategic solution in
line with policy sp29
ms caldwell sets out the relevant legal
and policy tests in her evidence and
relies upon the shadow hra further
evidence was also given by mr livingston
that the council is satisfied the
identified mitigation is appropriately
secured and as facile compliance nation
mr livingston has said the sound plan is
established pursuant to sp 29 is
monitored and effective and the measures
secured are those that are required
for the permission that would be here
granted
the tariff-based nature of the
contributions and ongoing monitoring
ensure that the mitigation is
appropriate to address in combination
effects
the on-site public open space and
on-site management be secured through
the conditions and planning obligation
as discussed
accordingly it submitted that the
secretary of state can be satisfied that
the appropriate assessment is passed so
there'll be no adverse effect on the
integrity of the site from the project
to lane or in combination
and i don't need to read paragraph 56
it's the same as in my opening
other material considerations
57 there are a number of other
considerations referred to in
third-party representations and in
swra statement
these are now largely addressed in the
range of statements of common ground and
the proofs of evidence of
miss caldwell mr travis
and as you'll see the position statement
by mrs meera
the outcome is that the technical issues
have been properly assessed and
addressed and that the conclusion of the
assessments is that the appeal scheme
will mitigate its impacts and will
generate a net gain in terms of
biodiversity and flood risk
in relation to additional ecology
matters
there were particular concerns raised in
relation to breeding birds and
mitigation in relation to bats
these were all addressed in miss
caldwell's crew and in the round table
discussion the position of the council
is set out in the ecology statement
common ground which refers to the
response of the county council
and concludes that the proposed
development is in accordance with policy
sp 30 of the vacant plan
although third parties and the rule six
party raised ecological concerns no
proof of evidence was submitted on
ecology and their ecologist was called
to give evidence the only professional
view at the inquiry in relation to these
matters is those of miss caldwell
endorsed by the local planning
authorities
the position in relation to breeding
birds is set out in detail
miss caldwell's proof of evidence and
there's no point frankly me repeating it
there's no ecological evidence that
contradicts it ms caldwell answered each
and every point raised at the round
table session and was clear in her
conclusion that in her professional
judgment the impact had been carefully
assessed and reflected the low level of
territories found by reference to the
wider breeding bird population and the
proposed mitigation and compensation
which in her professional judgment was
entirely suitable to compensate for the
potential impacts caused
the presence of corn bunting and gay
grey partridge were assessed at
significant
at the local level only in skylark at
the site level only and the mitigation
has been devised specifically in light
of the species potentially affected
an area of over one hectare will be set
aside fenced and managed to promote and
support the breeding bird species in the
area
its location means it's well located
to the adjacent farmland and the nature
of vegetation will provide cover as well
as foraging for the affected species
the precise ecological management
fencing and education will be addressed
through conditions and reserve matters
but it will be a designated space for
these purposes
in addition the landscape strategy will
provide significant areas of other new
wildflower meadow seeding and native
thicket tree and hedgerow planting which
will provide new nesting and foraging
habitat for a range of breeding bird
species
there's considerable usable public open
space and play space across the
remainder of the site
concerns as to potential archaeological
excavations are baseless and do not
reflect the concept of preservation in
situ
it's common ground that the ecological
policy sp30 is complied with
this policy seeks a net gain for
diversity assets
sorry that should say biodiversity
assets
through a range of measures which as mr
livingston and mr ball explained should
be considered in the round
the appeal scheme provides a range of
habitat creation sorry enhancement
creation of new habitat creation of
linkages between sites enhancing
features of value and mitigating against
the loss of farm and bird habitat with
the agreed result that there is a
considerable net gain
indeed the biodiversity net gain report
not only shows a considerable net gain
in terms of the metric
seven odd percent gain in habitat units
and 54 gain in hedgerow units but the
measures have also been assessed for
functionality in light of the targeted
species
as to bats the assessment work has been
thorough and identified the presence and
patterns of fat use off the site for
foraging and commuting
an appropriate scheme of mitigation has
been devised there's considerable
retention of linear features and these
will be protected
appropriate mitigation will be put in
place including for example sensitive
lighting back boxes etc to be addressed
at the detailed stages of design
and again this issue is addressed
comprehensively in ms cordwell's proof
and there's no contradictory ecological
evidence
the impacts are the subject of specific
common ground with the county and
district councils
miss caldwell also addressed the
nitrogen deposition at charcoal farm
roadside nature reserve
she explained it had been assessed on a
precautionary basis the scheming
proposed the creation of an area of
calcareous grassland habitat north 16
hectares far away from main roads this
more than compensates for the total area
of the local nature reserve on a
precautionary basis
in reality the question of deposition is
unproven on the interest of the local
nitrogen
nature reserves or a local nature
reserve
which will reduce as one moves further
away from manson road there is no
identifiable residual harm from the
scheme in this respect
in respect to flood risk and drainage
this was dealt with by mr travis and
again all questions were comprehensively
addressed at the round table session
again there's no contradictory
specialist or expert evidence
mr travis explained that the site was in
flood zen one low risk from flu real
flooding the issues identified relates
to pluvial flooding where in extreme
events there could be localized flows of
surface water across the site
the historic issues have been fully
considered and reflected in the scheme
without doing any disservice to mr
travis's very thorough explanation the
concerns appear to be based on
misconceptions
the parameter plan has been devised to
avoid those areas identified as prone to
preluvial flooding and an open space
continues across the site to facilitate
this
however all surface water falling onto
developed areas will enter the site
surface water drainage system
this is an infiltration system
with where the detained water then
flowing in a controlled way as
groundwater into the aquifer
as a result surface water flows will be
reduced as water currently falling as
surface water will be taken to ground
the foul water system is entirely
separate and will discharge into the
southern waterfowl sewers pursuant to
the relevant statutory duties all set
out in court doctrine 108. the
betterment through reduction in surface
water flows across the site and so
downstream of the site will reduce
pressure on the downstream system
and on any existing issues relating to
the interface of surface and foul
systems elsewhere
the concern
in relation to tivoli brook is also
without foundation because of the scheme
design
and the downstream betterment in surface
flows
the scheme is not affecting off-site
existing infrastructure other than in
reducing pressure
on any downstream
infrastructure that should see
maintenance and monitoring of the scheme
will be secured by condition
mr travis also explained how all issues
have been designed in consultation with
the county councils lead local flood
authority who not only raised no
objection but confirmed the position of
betterment
there's also a statement of common
ground with the district confirming no
ground for refuse with the scheme on
flood risk or drainage
it seems fair to know that a number of
points raised by third parties in the
rule six party
under these headings uh in reality argue
against the allocation of the site
through the local plan
however the appendage environmental
information
and evidence the inquiry show how the
allocated site can be developed
appropriately
although acknowledging the constraints
in a way that appropriately addresses
all such issues
the same is true of concerns relating to
loss of agricultural land
inevitably farmland will be lost through
the development of a largely arable site
for residential development however
detailed consideration of the
agricultural land values see the
position statements miss thomas
uh shows that the scientists of grade 3a
and 3b quality so not best and most
versatile
all of the issues requirements pretend
to be addressed by the appellant
addressed through the office's report
and are the subject of common ground
with the council for agricultural and
sea paragraph 3.2 of the same common
ground
in relation to other concerns raised in
relation to gdp services the allegation
sorry the allocation is again relevant
the site's allocated for housing
development and the development makes
the contributions that the relevant
local planning authorities have sought
as set out in the sil compliance note
there's also a statement of common
ground on heritage consideration and a
position statement prepared by mrs mira
in summary following a comprehensive
review uh it's agreed the impacts are
non-existent or negligible other than in
relation to schottendein farmhouse where
there's a very low level of harm
it's agreed that the public benefits
arising from the scheme outweigh the
harm's designated heritage assets say
that the development meets the
requirements of paragraph 202 of the
framework
further the policy aligns with the mppf
in seeking to avoid then mitigate sorry
that's
that's in the wrong
place
can i just put an asterisk at the top of
further
uh sir
and i need to move that to the end of
paragraph 60.
right okay
the whole paragraph now from further to
the end
right okay
sorry about that that's a comment by
reference to sp30
so what paragraph does that go to
at the end of paragraph
60.
okay
yep i've made a note of that
thank you very much so i turned them to
the planning balance
um
it's a fundamental principle of planning
law that the decision maker can only
determine the application before him
the council puts forward no case but
it's necessary to consider alternative
developments and no alternative scheme
is put forward
it's well established that the
development plan is to be read as a
whole and the relevant development
control tests are those set by the
adopted policies themselves
the appellant submits
that the appeal proposals are called
entirely with the development plan and
so should be permitted without delay
as set out above
the statutory duty requires an
assessment of the proposed development
against the development plan read as a
whole
this is a fundamental component of
determining any planning application
council officers assessed the scheme
comprehensively against all relevant
development plan policies and found it
entirely compliant with those policies
recognizing the outline nature of the
application and the ability to rely on
conditions and planning obligations
the final officers report hammered home
that on the evidence there was no
arguable breach of policy sp 23
given the viability position was
independently verified and there was no
reasonable contradictory evidence to
justify altering any of the assumptions
it was made clear that such an argument
without contradictory viability evidence
which of course there isn't would be
untenable at appeal carrying a high risk
of a costs award
the first reason for refusal
identifies no breach of any identified
development plan policy
decision notices must state clearly and
precisely the full reasons for the
refusal specifying all policies
in the development plan relevant to the
decision
it's clear that in reasons two and three
the council identify the development
plan policies that they say are breached
subject to the mitigation
reason for refusal one identifies no
such policy because on the analysis of
officers there was no breach of policy
and there was no evidence to support one
this is explicitly the framing of the
wording of the reason for refusal
members concern and the reason for
refusal was simply that the proposed
level of affordable housing would not
meet the identified need for affordable
housing in the district there was no
evidence to dispute viability which had
been endorsed by officers and all
advisers
this is confirmed in the council
statement of case which also identifies
no breach of policy cs 21 22 or 23
the bin's procedural guidance is clear
that the case must set out the planning
arguments why planning permissions
should be refused
this was referred to in the appellants
left to the council prior to the cmc in
which it was asked which additional
scenario should be run to demonstrate
compliance and none were identified
again it's clear that the council
advanced no argument based on the reason
for refusal that there was
non-compliance with the development plan
read as a whole or a breach of
identified policies of it
the first suggestion that there was
non-compliance with the development plan
or specific policies of it
was raised for the first time in mr
hester's evidence in chief
in direct response to the point in my
opening that the council had not
identified any breach of the development
plan in its evidence
the appellant's opening was correct
the council has not identified in any
document before the inquiry
including the reason for refusal the
statement of case and mr hester's proof
of evidence
any an identification or analysis of a
breach of any planned policy
and had not identified which part of any
policy was breached
mr boar made this point in his proof and
mr hester did not produce a rebuttal
it's clear from mr hester's proof and
his answers in cross-examination that he
had not applied section 386 to the
development proposed on this appeal
there is no assessment against the
development plan as a whole and no
analysis of how or why individual
policies are breached
section 386 can't be bypassed as it
provides the development control
framework
the upshot is that the council itself
has not advanced a case of
non-compliance with the development plan
mr hester has at a very late stage
suggested he has
but his answers and cross-examination
demonstrated plainly that he had not
he recognized that he had not considered
all the relevant policies in conducting
an assessment
the first clear example of this
deficiency is by reference to sp21
this is the site-specific allocation
policy allocating site and it sets its
infrastructure requirements
mr hester was unable to identify any
conflict with the wording of the policy
his only suggestion was that the outline
scheme conflicted with the policy
because it proposed more than 4.4
hectares of open space
against a requirement to provide a
minimum of 4.4 hectares of open space so
this is plainly wrong
he also admitted that he expressed his
views without having had any regard to
the constraints affecting the site
giving extreme theoretical examples of
say a hundred units don't advance the
case
as mr ball said the approach is the same
if on detailed analysis there were such
site constraints but the site could only
deliver that number of units and it
could still meet all of the other
policies if requirements of sp-21 then
it could comply with the policy
it seems very odd that mr hester
advances a case on what the site can
consider can deliver consistently with
the plan
that is directly at odds with the joint
position of the council's planning
policy officers who are responsible for
the plan
and development control officers who
assess the appeal scheme and the site
constraints
there's no objection based on effective
use of land and as mr ball said the net
density is 38 dp
h
and that exceeds the sp 21 which advises
a density of average 35 dbph
the thickening up point if i can call it
that has frankly nothing to do with the
reason for refusal or with compliance
with sp21 or indeed with the permission
that would be granted which would be
tied to the description of development
of 450 units and tied to the parameter
plans in the development framework plan
sp 21 is a good example
of the deficiency because it means that
on analysis
the appeal proposals comply fully with
the strategic policy allocating the site
and setting its development requirements
on a proper analysis as mr ball did that
would weigh very strongly in favor of
the scheme within the section 38.6
assessment against the plan but that's
not the approach taken by mr hester
sp 22 controls the mix of housing types
and sizes
on the appeal outline planning
commission
this matter will be addressed at the
reserve matter stage there's no
conceivable basis on which the
development proposed on this appeal can
be said to conflict with sp 22
the mix that this development provides
will be determined not on this appeal
but at reserve matters
finally sp 23 is a policy relevant to
the provision of affordable housing
a percentage of less than 30 will be
policy compliant where it's shamed to be
appropriate due to viability
considerations at the date of the
decision as explained above there was no
alternative evidence other than other
than that the development would be
unviable if more than 15 affordable
housing was provided it's for this
reason that the council identified no
breach of sp 23
the reference to
strategic priority three provides no
assistance it is for strategic policies
but deliver the plan's objectives and
which determine whether a proposal
accords with the development plan
the strategic allocations are all
purposefully expressed as maximum
figures and as mr hester agreed there
will inevitably be variations in what
each can deliver when more detailed
assessments are undertaken
the council's policy response also
recognizes this and that the allocation
figures are estimates likely to balance
out over the planned period
the plan addressed this by providing for
more than in fact over thirteen hundred
units more than the housing requirement
there is therefore a buffer above what's
assessed is required
the appeal proposals accordingly promote
the strategic priorities by delivering
significant amounts of housing and
affordable on an allocated site in line
with the site-specific requirements of
sp-21
and in a way which ensures that such
housing is actually delivered
when viewed against sb21 and the
objectives there is no harm from the
scheme only benefit
the site was allocated with an estimated
capacity and a detailed and
collaborative approach has been taken to
optimize the site to meet the site
constraints and deliver much needed
housing this is how the system and the
plan is intended to operate and it's
what section 38 6 promotes
unfortunately section 38 6 has simply
not been applied in mr hester's analysis
as above the council were clear in not
identifying any breach of the
development plan
mr paul's primary position is that the
scheme complies with all relevant and
important policies of the development
plan and so should be granted permission
under section 38 6 and paragraph 11c
the complex analysis in the council's
closing paragraph 6 to 14 is with
respect are necessary if the scheme
complies with the development plan then
it should be granted permission under
both
at 38.6 and 11c
however if there is an identified breach
of policy it's still necessary to
conclude whether there's overall
compliance with the development plan
and of great importance to that will be
that the scheme complies with the
specific strategic allocation policy sp
21 so delivering 450 units on an
allocated site and providing priority
highways infrastructure
mr ball's tertiary position is that the
tilted balance is triggered and say the
appropriate development control test
under the framework is whether or not
identified harm of the proposal
significantly to possibly outweighs the
benefits of the scheme
in this scenario which is common ground
arises the most important policies in
the development plan for determining the
application are deemed out of date by
virtue of footnote eight
mr hester's position confidently simply
ignores footnote date
officers advised members it was
necessary to identify substantial harm
however as mr ball explains the council
identifies no harm of any substance
development control decisions are about
the land use consequences of particular
schemes of development
there's no general principle of
considering alternative schemes to the
one proposed and the council advanced no
alternative scheme
the land use consequence of this scheme
in terms of affordable housing is but it
will deliver 15 affordable housing
in no sense can this be described as a
harm it's a benefit and what is even
more significant about it is it's been
assessed by the council and its advisors
as a deliverable benefit
that is the purpose of the viability
provision in s p 23 in order to provide
housing and affordable housing benefits
schemes must be delivered
any harm is entirely notional in that it
relates not to the appeal scheme but
some incorrect alternative scheme
as stepped out above the council
presents absolutely no viability
evidence justifying a particular
percentage that this or any other scheme
could um
excuse me could sustain on the appeal
side in reality the only harm would be
caused by refusal of permission thereby
undermining the council strategy for
meeting market and affordable housing
needs in the district and delivering key
infrastructure improvements
turning to the benefits of the scheme
these are substantial
this appears to be common ground
certainly in his evidence mr hester
provides no comments on weight to
indicate any disagreement and no
rebuttal was provided mr hester agreed
with officers that great weight should
be given to the delivery of housing in
the circumstances and the link road
provided clearance demonstrable benefits
and ah provided a social benefit the
points in the council's closing on the
benefits aren't based on the evidence
given by mr hester or by mr ball
mr ball summarizes his position in
section 8 of his proof of evidence
delivery of up to 382 market units
attracts very significant weight
delivery of 15 affordable attracts very
significant weight provision of the
on-site link rate attracts very
significant weight the economic benefits
attract significant weight the provision
of open space moderate weight this suds
and betterment attracts moderate weight
and the fire diverse net gain moderate
weight
in conclusion permission should be
granted on any and all of the three
bases of consideration
ultimately as the above two paragraphs
make clear the suggestion that the
entire nation will harm significantly
and demonstrably outweighs the benefits
is as officers advised members prior to
refusal untenable
the evidence comes nowhere near
substantiating such a refusal of the
scheme the benefits reflect the pressing
need for housing and affordable housing
in the district the appeal scheme
represents the only identified means of
delivering the benefits required by sp
21 on the appeal site and as a result
it's respectfully submitted that
planning permission should be granted
thank you
thank you mr williams i'm just going to
quickly
save my copy of that because i just made
a few notes
where you
advised about a couple of changes so let
me just
save that in the right place
right there we go that's done
okay thank you
so
those are the closing submissions thank
you all three of you
for those
uh
we've dealt with the site visit so on
costs
are we in agreement that
ms williams the appellant's cost
application
can be made
in writing now
and dealt with in writing
given where we are with where are we
quarter six with time on a friday i
think that's preferable
it certainly would be for me i think
yeah so that'll be so can we set out a
time table
for that if because i want to get i want
to obviously get through that in sort of
quite sort of quick order
so if
the
appendage cost submission can be made
on monday
by the end of player monday that's
and then
if i was just thinking earlier on if
a response from the council
by the end of play on wednesday
and then final response by the appellant
by the end of friday next week is that
reasonable gives you lots more time than
you'd get normally in people doing it
so
is that okay
yeah obviously fit around other things
so that that
perspective i think sounds fine
okay
good okay so
call submission from the appellate end
of play monday reply from the council
end of play
on uh
wednesday and then uh the final response
on the appellate
by
the end of friday okay
good okay uh
site visit we've dealt with no need to
come back to that
before
i
and i presume there's no other costs
applications as we've confirmed before
okay
any more sort of little bits of
housekeeping that i need to clear up
before
uh
i close is uh
in terms of documents and there's no
other outstanding documents
is there other than the possibility of
the
kent county council appendices but i
think i shall i shall find those in
amongst all the evidence but if not as i
said before i'll i'll send a note about
that
but i'm not aware of any other
documents that we're awaiting or any
other
documents that need to be sent in post
inquiry unless i've missed
anything
well apart from the 106
the league
[Music]
are there any others
did they not not from our perspective so
i think there's nothing on my list no
good
okay
thank you so
that takes us to the uh the end thank
you for everyone's perseverance today
it's quite a long session but i think
it's well worth getting it completed on
the friday we're having to adjourn for
another another